GOOD MORNING. WARNING OR.
SANDOR STERN WAS WAS OUT LATE.
CELEBRATING HIS RECEIVING THE
TECHNET LEGISLATOR OF THE YEAR
AWARD. LAST NIGHT SO
CONGRATULATIONS SIR.
YEAH.
I WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO
TODAY'S JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING.
BETWEEN THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
AND THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS.
ON THE TOPIC OF CYBERSECURITY IN
CALIFORNIA LAW ACTIONS.
I DON'T THINK EVERYONE WHO IS
HE.
OUR YEAH.
I DON'T THINK EVERYONE WHO IS
HERE TO PARTICIPATE IN HEARING
INCLUDING THE WITNESSES WHO
TRAVELED FROM AROUND THE STATE
AND AROUND THE COUNTRY TO BE
HERE TODAY. I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARC BERMAN THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE. AND I'M
HAPPY TO BE JOINED BY MY CO
CHAIR FOR TODAY'S HEARING CENTER
AND WE STERN THE CHAIR OF THE
SENATE ELECTIONS IN
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE.
SINCE THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ELECTIONS THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASED FOCUS ON ELECTION
SECURITY NON THE INCREASINGLY
SOPHISTICATED THREATS POSED TO
OUR ELECTION SYSTEMS.
A LARGE PART OF THAT INCREASE
FOCUS IS A DIRECT RESPONSE TO
THE WELL DOCUMENTED EFFORTS THAT
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT UNDERTOOK
IN AN ATTEMPT TO INFLUENCE THE
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
ACCORDING TO THE UNITED STATES
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY THOSE
EFFORTS REPRESENTED A
SIGNIFICANT ESCALATION BY THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT OVER PREVIOUS
ATTEMPTS TO INTERFERE WITH OUR
NATION'S ELECTIONS.
AND INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS
WARNED THAT RUSSIA AND BULLDOG
EMBOLDENED BY THE LACK OF A
STRONG RESPONSE BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO ITS
INTERFERENCE IN THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN ELECTION.
IS CONTINUING TO INTERFERE WITH
U. S. ELECTIONS THIS YEAR.
HEARING CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
RECEIVED CONFLICTING AND
CONFUSING INFORMATION ABOUT
WHETHER OUR ELECTIONS RELATED
SYSTEMS WERE THE TARGET OF
RUSSIAN ATTACKS.
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
AND WELL IT APPEARS THAT RUSSIAN
OPERATIVES MAY HAVE TRIED TO
TEST THE SECURITY OF SOME STATE
WEBSITES IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
OUR SECRETARY OF STATE. WHO WE
WILL HEAR FROM SHORTLY ASSURES
US THAT THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S ELECTIONS
RELATED SYSTEMS WERE BREACHED IN
ANY WAY?
WHILE RUSSIA'S ATTEMPTS TO
INFLUENCE ELECTIONS HAVE
RECEIVED A GREAT DEAL OF PUBLIC
ATTENTION THEY'RE NOT THE ONLY
SOURCE OF POTENTIAL CYBER
ATTACKS WERE ELECTIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND TODAY'S HEARING IS NOT
INTENDED TO BE A FORM FOR
EVALUATING WHETHER RUSHES
EFFORTS HAD ANY EFFECT ON THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
INSTEAD IT THE PURPOSE OF THIS
HEARING IS TO HAVE A MORE FORMAL
DISCUSSION ABOUT ELECTION
SECURITY IN ORDER TO HELP
PROMOTE A THOUGHTFUL AND FACTUAL
ASSESSMENT. OF HOW CALIFORNIA
CAN DEAL WITH THE EVOLVING
THREATS TO OUR ELECTION SYSTEM.
PART OF THAT DISCUSSION WILL
INVOLVE AN EXAMINATION OF
CURRENT POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS IN PLACE TO
COMBAT THREATS TO ELECTION
INTEGRITY.
FOR EXAMPLE WHILE FOURTEEN
STATES STILL USE PAPERLESS
VOTING SYSTEMS ALLEY SOME
JURISDICTIONS
CALIFORNIA'S* PROHIBITED THE
USE OF SUCH SYSTEMS FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE.
SIMILARLY CALIFORNIA HAS LONG
STANDING PROHIBITIONS AGAINST
VOTING SYSTEMS BEING CONNECTED
TO THE INTERNET. HAVING WIRELESS
COMMUNICATIONS CAPABILITIES OR
OTHERWISE CONNECTING TO PUBLIC
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS IN ORDER
TO PROTECT AGAINST REMOTE
ATTACKS TO THOSE SYSTEMS.
IN FACT CALIFORNIA EVEN HAS ITS
OWN VOTING SYSTEM TESTING AND
CERTIFICATION STANDARDS THAT
EXCEED THE VOLUNTARY STANDARDS
DEVELOPED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A MUNIFICENT
WITH THREATS AND SAFEGUARDING
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS
WILL REQUIRE PROACTIVE EFFORTS
BY FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
OFFICIALS.
SOME OF THOSE EFFORTS ARE
ALREADY UNDERWAY INCLUDING A ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR COMMITMENT BY THE
GOVERNOR OF STE.
OF STATE FUNDING TO REPLACE
OUTDATED VOTING EQUIPMENT ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND I'M HOPING THAT TODAY'S
HEARING WILL HELP US DETERMINE
OTHER STEPS THAT WE CAN TAKE TO
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THE SECURITY
OF OUR ELECTIONS.
IN PUTTING TOGETHER THE AGENDA
FOR TODAY'S HEARING IN THE
PRIMARY FOCUS WAS ON THREATS TO
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN OTHER WORDS TODAY'S HEARING
WON'T BE TOO HEAVILY FOCUSED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA PROPAGANDA THAT'S
DESIGNED TO HELP ONE CANDID IT
OR HURT ANOTHER.
THAT MAY BE A TOPIC FOR A FUTURE
HERE.
BUT THE TWO ISSUES ARE NOT
COMPLETELY SEVER ONES AND I
EXPECT THAT THERE WILL BE SOME
DISCUSSION TODAY ABOUT THE
THREAT OF.
ABOUT THE THREAT TO PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN OUR DEMOCRACY WHEN
VOTERS RECEIVE MISLEADING OR
INACCURATE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
ACCURACY OF ELECTION RESULTS.
WE HAVE A VERY DISTINGUISHED
GROUP OF PARTICIPANTS FOR
TODAY'S HEARING.
AND AFTER WE HEAR FROM THE
WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA WILL
HAVE TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
FROM THOSE IN THE AUDIENCE.
AND ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY
DURING THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
PORTION OF THE AGENDA SHOULD
SIGN UP WITH THE SERGEANT AT
ARMS. RIGHT OVER THERE.
BUT BEFORE WE GET TO THE WITNESS
IS ON THE AGENDA A LIKE TO
INVITE MY CULTURE FOR TODAY'S
HEARING SENATOR HENRY STERN TO
MAKE SOME OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
PLEASE DO THE JOINT HEARING
WITH YOU TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INITIATIVE IN BRINGING THIS
ISSUE FORWARD.
.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT TIME TO
ASSURE THE VOTERS A CALIFORNIA.
THAT.
STRONG THIS WAY THEY CAN COME
BACK RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE IS TO
GO OUT AND VOTE.
THE REGISTER TO VOTE EARLY.
AND TO VOTE AND OUR SYSTEMS.
AS WE'VE SEEN THROUGH THE
DILIGENCE OF OUR SECRETARY OF
STATE. AND OUR NUMEROUS COUNTY
REGISTRARS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE PRETTY GOOD
CYCLE.
COMPARE TO THE REST THIS
COUNTRY.
SOME OF IT WAS BECAUSE OF.
.
REAL LEADERSHIP.
IT IN IN OUR SYSTEMS AND AND
VIGILANCE AND A AND A SORT OF.
A WILLINGNESS TO MODERNIZE BUT
SOME OF IT IS LOW TECH
SOME OF IT ISABOUT OUR
WILLINGNESS IS A STATE.
TO.
.
DISCONNECT FROM THE INTERNET AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR VOTING
SYSTEMS IN FACT.
OUR ON SITE
CURE WITH PAPER TRAILS THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY AUDIT.
.
AND INTERESTINGLY THAT THAT
ACTUALLY IS BROUGHT SOME MODICUM
OF OF SECURITY INTEREST I THINK
BACK TO THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTORATE.
BUT OF COURSE IT'S OUR DUTY HERE
IN THE IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUE TO KICK THE TIRES AND I
THINK.
DESPITE OUR BEST EFFORTS SYSTEMS
GET ALL. AND ITS EQUIPMENT GETS
OLD AND SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
NOW IS HOW TO SORT OF ADAPT THAT
HARD INFRASTRUCTURE.
INTO THE MODERN ERA.
BEYOND SAY WINDOWS TWO THOUSAND.
INTO.
THE TWENTY.
TWENTIES.
AND AND BEYOND THAT I THINK
WE'LL HEAR A LITTLE MORE ABOUT
THAT TODAY. BUT I WANTED TO SEND
THAT NOTE EARLY BECAUSE THERE'S
A LOT OF DISTRUST OUT THERE AND
AND AGAIN ACKNOWLEDGING WHAT WE
PROBABLY CANNOT SOLVE TODAY
WHICH IS THE SOFT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SPEECH.
AND OF ART SHOULD HAVE
DEMOCRATIC CONVERSATION WHICH
REALLY CAN'T BE PINNED DOWN IN
ANY PARTICULAR MEDIUM.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY ON FACEBOOK IT'S
SO ON YOUR TWITTER ACCOUNTS.
THERE ARE NUMEROUS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION MOVING A LOT OF
QUESTIONS I'M SURE PEOPLE HAVE
ABOUT THE DURABILITY OF OUR
DEMOCRACY IN LIGHT OF ALL THIS
CHEAP SPEECH AND OFTEN FAKE
SPEECH.
BUT TODAY.
WE'RE HERE TO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE BONES OF CALIFORNIA'S
DEMOCRACY ARE STRONG SO. WITH
THAT I'LL TURN IT BACK TO THE
CHAIR.
.
AND AND GET INTO IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
AND BEFORE HEAR FROM SECRETARY
PADILLA WHAT ANY OF THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES LIKE
TO MAKE ANY OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT LET'S
GET STARTED ON OUR AGENDA
LEADING US OFF TODAY WILL BE OUR
SECRETARY OF STATE. ALEX
PADILLA.
THE SECRETARY OBVIOUSLY NEEDS NO
INTRODUCTION TO THE MEMBERS OF
THESE COMMITTEES BUT I WOULD
NOTE THAT AS A SENATOR SECRETARY
PADILLA AUTHORED THE BILL THAT
LAID THE GROUNDWORK FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT VOTING
SYSTEM TESTING. AND
CERTIFICATION STANDARDS.
DURING HIS TIME AS SECRETARY OF
STATE SECRETARY PATILLAS BEEN A
CHAMPION FOR MODERNIZING THE
OFFICE INCREASING VOTER
REGISTRATION AND PARTICIPATION
AND STRENGTHENING VOTING RIGHTS.
SECRETARY VIDEO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
THANKYOU VERY MUCH A POUND
CHAIRMAN BERMAN CHAIRMAN STERN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND FOR
ORGANIZING THIS IMPORTANT.
AND OF SHE VERY TIMELY A
HEARING THE TIMING COULDN'T BE
ANY MORE APPROPRIATE.
ALSO TO COMMITTEE FOR PUTTING A
GREAT LINEUP OF SPEAKERS
TOGETHER OF COURSE VIA. A
BRITISH TOWARDS VOTERS THAT ARE
HERE FROM DIFFERENT PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA OF OUR PARTNERS THAT
WE WORK VERY VERY CLOSELY.
BECAUSE ELECTIONS ARE CONDUCTED
AT THE GROUND LEVEL AND THERE
ARE THERE ON THE FRONT LINES BUT
IT'S TREMENDOUS PARTNERSHIP.
THE OF ENJOYED BUT JUST AND
ADMINISTERING SAFE AND SECURE
ELECTIONS IN MODERNIZING FOR THE
FUTURE.
BUT REALLY I OUGHT TO IT TOTO
MAXIMIZE THE CYBERSECURITY OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ELECTIONS. A AND BEYOND IN OF
ALL WANT TO GIVE VOTE WORK
CALIFORNIA WELCOME TO
COMMISSIONER MASTERSON FROM THE
EAC.
A WHO'S BEEN A.
BUT A TREMENDOUS LEADER.
.
TRULY PROFESSIONAL AND SEVEN WHO
HAS RALLIED EXPERTS ACROSS THE
BOARD BOTH IN THE PUBLIC AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO TACKLE THESE
ISSUES. ARE ON A NATIONAL LEVEL
SO I I THINK YOU CAN HAVE VERY
MUCH ENJOYED HIS PRESENTATION.
AND INVITE YOU TO PICK HIS BRAIN
AS MUCH AS YOU HUMANLY CAN.
OUGHT TO BENEFIT FROM HIS.
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE.
BOB I WANT TO START MY TESTIMONY
TODAY WITH THE VERY VERY
CLEAR.
COMMITTEE AND ANYBODY WHO'S
LISTENING OR WATCHING.
WE HAVE SEEN NO EVIDENCE.
CALIFORNIA ELECTION SYSTEMS
HACKED OR BREACHED.
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
NONETHELESS I OPERATE UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT CALIFORNIA AND
IT'S VOTING SYSTEMS WILL
CONTINUE
TO BE A TARGET. OF RUSSIAN.
AT OTHER STATES AND NOT STATE
ACTORS
WHO SEEK TO UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRACY IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ELECTION.
AND BEYOND.
THIS IS THE NEW NORMAL.
CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE SOME STRONG
SECURITY MEASURES IN PLACE TO
ATTACKED OUR ELECTIONS.
BUT WE MUST
CONSTANTLY IMPROVE
STRENGTH IN OUR SYSTEM.
AND MY OFFICE.
JUDGE WITH COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS
NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IF WE
ARE TO DEFEND AGAINST FUTURE
CYBER THREATS.
I CONSIDER TODAY AN OPPORTUNITY
TO INFORM THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT
THE CYBER THREATS AND SECURITY.
BUT A ALSO ASK YOU TO RECOGNIZE
THAT WE MUST
TALK ABOUT OUR SECURITY EFFORTS.
WITHOUT GIVING AWAY THE
COMBINATION TO THE.
LET ME BEGIN WITH ONE OF THE
MORE IMPORTANT LESSONS.
BUT I'VE LEARNED IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AS SECRETARY.
YES
ACKNOWLEDGING MATTERS.
YES PARTNERSHIPS MATTER.
POLICY MATTERS.
EQUALLY IMPORTANT
IN ALL THIS.
CYBER VOCABULARY.
PUT SIMPLY WORDS MATTER.
WHEN WE ARE PRECISE
OUR TERMINOLOGY.
OR A MEDIA REPORTS.
.
WE.
ABOUT THE TERMINOLOGY THAT WERE
USING IN OUR DISCUSSION.
WE CANNOT.
EASILY GO FROM HAVING
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE.
TWO VERY COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
DIALOGUE
I KEEP A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES.
THE TERM HACK.
FAR TOO OFTEN IT IS USED AT THE
BLANKET TERM TO REFER TO A RANGE
OF ACTIVITIES OR EVENTS.
PERFECTLY A HACK IS DEFINED AS.
UNAUTHORIZED ACCESS.
TO AN INFORMATION SYSTEM WHERE
INFORMATION IS MANIPULATED OR
STOLEN.
TERMS HACK OR HACKED.
OR HACKING ARE OFTEN ERRONEOUSLY
USE TO DESCRIBE OTHER INCIDENTS
AND A WHAT WE'VE READ ABOUT LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS IS.
SCANNING.
RIGHT SCAMMING IS MORE SPECIFIC
SCANNING IS WHEN AN AND ENTITY
PINGS ON ONLINE SYSTEM FOR A
WEAKNESS.
SCANNING IS THE EQUIVALENT OF
SOMEBODY HAVE YOU KNOW WALKING
UP AND DOWN THE STREETS ARE
SHAKEN SOME GATES.
TO SEE WHO'S HOMEOWNER WHO'S
THAT OR WHICH CATER LOCKED OR
UNLOCKED.
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ENTITIES
WITH ALL MY PRESENTS EXPERIENCE
SCANNING.
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AGAIN THIS IS JUST THE REALITY
THAT WE LIVE IN TODAY.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
OF IT AND AND MAYBE PART OF
FRAME TODAY'S HEARING IN THE
FOLLOWING CONTEXT I'VE OBSERVED.
THREE.
SEMI RELATED DYNAMICS GOING ON
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL BUT AS WE
STOP AND CONSIDER EACH THAT ARE
THERE REALLY DISTINCT.
IN OF THE TOPIC UP HERE TODAY AS
ARTICULATED MISTER CHAIRMAN IS
VOTING SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS IN FRANCE.
IT'S SECURE ARE NOT.
WAS IT.
BREACHED
COMPROMISED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
ARE NOT AND THE ANSWER IS NO.
THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT THAN.
WAS THERE.
WHAT IS ART ARE GOING?
ASSERTED MISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN.
BACON DUCTED BY AGENTS OF THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
VETERANS ABSOLUTELY YES.
THE COUPLE WEEKS AGO YOU SAW THE
IT AND NOT SORT OF INDICTMENT OF
THIRTEEN INDIVIDUALS.
RIGHT AND THAT INDICTMENT LATER
THAT.
AND THERE'S MORE AND IT'S
CONTINUE.
BUT THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT THAN
THE QUESTION OF WAS THERE A BOOK
CHIANG DROVE A TALLY.
THAT WAS.
.
ABOUT MANIPULATED
CHOOSE NOT.
THIRD LOT OF PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW
WHO WAS THERE WAS ARE NOT
COLLUSION BETWEEN WILL.
A PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE OR HIS.
FOR HER CAMPAIGN AND THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
WELL LET.
MOLLER WHO COME TO CONCLUSIONS
ON THAT
CLEARLY THREE DIFFERENT ITEMS
RIGHT BUT AS WATCH THE CABLE
NEWS AT NIGHT THE STORYLINES
TEND TO GET BLURRED.
SO GET TO MY POINT CYBER
VOCABULARY MATTERS.
VOCABULARY IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
PUBLIC PERCEPTION.
IT'S JUST AS IMPORTANT AS THE
REALITY OF WHAT DID OR DID NOT
HAPPEN IN TWENTY SIX.
INACCURATE OR MISLEADING STORIES
ABOUT CYBER THREATS DO A GREAT
DISSERVICE.
IT UNDERMINES THE CONFIDENCE
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE.
IN OUR ELECTION SYSTEM.
MEMBERS IF YOU.
OR YOUR STAFF OR ANY OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS.
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
ABOUT MEDIA REPORTS
PLEASE
PLEASE DO NOT HESITATE TO REACH
OUT TO MY OFFICE
ALLOWED US TO A ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS. AND WHEN NECESSARY
AND HOPEFUL CORRECT THE RECORD.
LET ME TURN TO OUR SUMMER
OBSERVATIONS OF ACTIVITIES THAT
WERE HAPPENING PRIOR TO.
.
IT CALIFORNIA LONGO IMPLEMENTED
MANY SAFEGUARDS FOR VOTING
SYSTEMS TO ASSURE VOTERS
THERE BALLOTS ARE COUNTED.
ACCURATELY AD RELIABLY.
STATE LAW REQUIRES.
AS CENTER STERN REFERENCE.
THAT NO VOTING SYSTEM OR PART OF
THE BUILDINGS.
IN CALIFORNIA CAN BE CONNECTED
TO.
TO MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO SEE
THE MAGICALLY.
OR RIG AN ELECTION.
CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS ONE OF THE
MOST STRENUOUS VOTING SYSTEM
TESTING.
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN THE
COUNTRY.
NEW VOTING SYSTEMS APPLY FOR
CERTIFICATION IN CALIFORNIA GO
THROUGH MONTHS OF TESTING.
COULDN'T FUNCTIONAL TESTING.
SOURCE CODE REVIEW.
RED TEAM SECURITY TESTING THAT
INVOLVES.
EXPERTS LETTER TO KIND OF BREAK
INTO AND COMPROMISED VOTING
SYSTEM.
AS WELL ACCESSIBILITY AND.
VOLUME TESTING IS WHAT.
CALIFORNIA CELTIC
ARE REQUIRED TO PERFORM LOGIC
AND ACCURACY TESTING OF THEIR
VOTING SYSTEMS.
BEFORE EACH ELECTION.
AND FOLLOW SPECIFIC PROCEDURES
OR PROGRAMMING
APPOINTMENTS AND THE USE OF
VOTING EQUIPMENT.
AS WAS REFERENCE IN THE
INTRODUCTION CALIFORNIANS.
.
FOR THE MOST PART CASTOR VOTES
ON PAPER BALLOTS.
AND THE LIMITED VOTING SYSTEM
USED IN CALIFORNIA THAT INCLUDE
A DIRECT
RECORD RECORD ELECTRONIC SYSTEM.
IS MAINLY FOR ACCESSIBILITY
OPTIONS FOR VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES.
MUST HAVE VOTER VERIFIED PAPER
RECORDING.
FOR AUDIT RECOUNT AND MEDAL
TALLY PURPOSES.
IN ADDITION.
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS ARE
REQUIRED TO CONDUCT A MANUAL
TALLY OF WHAT PERCENT OF THE
PRECINCTS
AS PART OF BE OFFICIAL CANVASS
OF ELECTION RESULTS.
THE SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE VOTES
WERE ACCURATELY READ AND TAP.
IT SEPTEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN.
I A SECRETARY STATE CERTIFIED
VOTE CAP.
OUR NEW STATEWIDE VOTER
REGISTRATION DATABASE
AS OUR SYSTEM OF RECORD.
VOTE CAL ADHERES TO INDUSTRY
STANDARD SECURITY CONTROLS
ESTABLISHED
BY THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
STEP STANDARDS AND TECHNOLOGY.
AND THE INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FOR
STANDARDIZATION.
BUT CAL STANDARDS MEET THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE US
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
HEARING VOTER REGISTRATION DATA.
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR DISTRIBUTED BY THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SECRETARIES OF
STATE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE.
ARE DESIGNED TO PREVENT
MALICIOUS ACTORS
FROM INTERFERING WITH VOTER
REGISTRATION WEBSITES AND
DATABASES.
BOTH HEALTH DATABASE RESIDE ON
SERVERS.
LOCATED ON A SECURE INTERNAL
NETWORK.
AND DESPAIR OF REPEATING
THERE'S.
YOU KNOW AT A AS FOLKS ARE
PAYING ATTENTION THEY'VE ON THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN VOTING
SYSTEMS BEING SECURED AND.
WHAT ABOUT OUR VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION BECAUSE
WERE ALLOWED TO RICHARD OF
ONLINE?
VOTE HEALTH DATA.
DOES NOT RESIDE.
IN THE CLOUT.
NO ACCESS EXISTS BETWEEN THE
BOOK HELP PUBLIC WEBSITE
SERVERS.
USE FOR THE PUBLIC WEBSITE
AND THE BOOK CAO DATABASE
SERVERS
WHERE THE VOTER DATA RESIDES.
CONDUCT ROUTINE VULNERABILITY
SCANS AND SECURITY AUDITS TO PRO
ACTIVELY IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS
VULNERABILITIES.
IN ADDITION WE ROUTINELY APPLY
THE LATEST SOFTWARE.
SECURITY PATCHES TO ENSURE THAT
VOEPEL REMAINS PROTECTED
AGAINST EMERGING.
AND INCREASINGLY SOPHISTICATED
SECURITY THREATS.
VOCA ALSO PROVIDES
THIRTY REQUIREMENTS
A COUNTY.
THE COUNTY MUST PROTECT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY.
TAG PRETTY AND AVAILABILITY OF
THE DATA AND INFORMATION SYSTEMS
AUTHORIZED.
A TWO PROCESS STORE AND TRANSMIT
VOTER REGISTRATION DATA.
COUNTY VOTER REGISTRATION AND
ELECTION INFORMATION SYSTEMS
WHAT'S CONFORM TO RECOGNIZE
FEDERAL AND STATE GOVERNMENT
SECURITY STANDARDS AND
PRACTICES.
INCLUDING SYSTEM HARDENING
AND MUST UTILIZE DIVERSITY OF
DESIGN.
COUNTY.
MUST PROVIDE ANNUAL PRIVACY AND
SECURITY AWARENESS TRAINING
TO ALL STAFF UTILIZING ITS
COUNTY VOTER REGISTRATION AND
ELECTION INFORMATION SYSTEMS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE MANUAL AND THE
INFORMATION PRACTICES ACT.
AND EACH COUNTIES REQUIRED TO
CONDUCT.
TENUOUS VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT
AND REMEDIATION PENETRATION
TESTS
AND RED TEAM XTRASIZE.
FELLOWSHIP TO WHAT'S HAPPENED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND.
.
WE'VE CONTINUE TO WORK
DILIGENTLY TO HARDEN OUR
INFORMATION SYSTEMS AND PREPARE
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN THESE
ACTIVITIES INFORMED FRANKLY BY
WHAT WE LEARNED. A NOT JUST
INTERNALLY AT THE STATE LEVEL
WITHIN THE STATE FAMILY BUT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH FEDERAL
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
ABOUT WHAT WAS ATTEMPTED IN
TWENTY SIX.
ABOUT WE HAVE SENT TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN ELECTION CONDUCTED AN
AGENCY WIDE SECURITY AUDIT.
IDENTIFIED HIGH RISK SYSTEMS.
THE COMMISSION THEM AND REPLACE
THEM.
WE REPLACE OBSOLETE DEVICES AND
UPGRADED FIREBALLS.
WE INCREASED TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
MONITORING AND ALERTS
CAPABILITIES.
WE STRENGTHENED AGENCY POLICIES
TO HARDEN PROCEDURES AND
PROCESSES RELATED TO SECURITY.
WE IMPLEMENTED ADDITIONAL
SECURITY TOOLS TO DETECT AND
PREVENT MALWARE AND VIRUSES.
WE ENHANCE THE SECURITY OF OUR
SERVERS.
WE POSTED CYBERSECURITY TRAINING
FOR COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
AND WE ADDED REDUNDANCIES TO OUR
SYSTEMS TO MITIGATE THE IMPACT
OF POTENTIAL OUTAGES.
AND WE INCREASINGLY WORK WITH
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERS.
PUTTING BUT NOT LIMITED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
SHARE INFORMATION
AND BEST PRACTICES.
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH FEDERAL
AGENCIES IN PARTICULAR HAS
IMPROVED OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST YEAR AND HOPE CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE IN THE MONTHS AND YEARS
AHEAD.
I ALSO. WOULD LIKE TO INFORM THE
COMMITTEE THAT I SERVE AS AN
ALTERNATE MEMBER OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
GOVERNMENT COORDINATING COUNCIL
FOR ELECTION THAT DISTRICT.
AND THE ORANGE COUNTY REGISTRAR
VOTERS KNOW KELLY WHO YOU WILL
HEAR FROM. A LATER TODAY IS A
MEMBER OF THAT SAME COMMITTEE.
I'M SPEND A MINUTE BY DISCUSSING
RESOURCE.
TO CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN OUR
CYBERSECURITY MY OFFICE AND
COUNTY OFFICIALS NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
I'VE BEEN WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW TO
CURATOR RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
DEVELOP AND EXPAND OUR
TECHNOLOGY STAFF.
AND AS YOU'RE LIKELY AWARE
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS DO
NOT CURRENTLY RECEIVE ANY STATE
OR FEDERAL FUNDING.
THE NEED TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS IS
MOST EVIDENT
AND ARE OUTDATED.
AGING
VOTING.
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
VOTING SYSTEMS ARE AT OR NEAR
THEIR LIFE EXPECTANCY.
THE DUE DILIGENCE OF COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS AND OUR
OFFICE.
IT'S HELP MITIGATE RISK.
TWENTY SIXTEEN
WRITTEN FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
BUT WE CAN'T TAKE THE LONGEVITY
OF OUR SYSTEMS FOR GRANTED.
COUNTY VOTING MACHINES.
SOME INSTANCES ARE LITERALLY
FALLING APART.
VENDORS NO LONGER MAKE
REPLACEMENT PARTS.
COUNTIES ARE TURNING TO EBAY
AND SCRAP PARTS FROM OTHER
STATES.
KEEP THEIR MACHINES OPERATING.
SOME COUNTIES WERE CUT OPERATING
SYSTEMS THAT ARE SO OLD THEIR
VENDORS NO LONGER PROVIDE TECH
SUPPORT.
MEANING CALIFORNIA VOTING
MACHINES CANNOT BE PATCHED OR
UPDATED.
WITH
pSECURITY SOFTWARE.
MEMBERS.
REMEMBER THE TWO THOUSAND
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THE AGE OF FLORIDA'S VOTING
SYSTEM.
TIME CONTRIBUTED TO THAT CRISIS.
AND IN RESPONSE.
CONGRESS ACTED ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS.
PASS THE HELP AMERICA VOTE ACT.
PROVIDED FUNDING.
TO MODERNIZE VOTING SYSTEMS
IN ALL FIFTY STATES.
HOUSE MORE THAN THIRTEEN YEARS
AGO.
TODAY SEEMS LIKE WE'RE RIGHT
BACK WHERE WE STARTED
WITH AGING VOTING SYSTEMS
THAT ARE AT RISK OF FAILING.
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES ALONE CANNOT
BEAR THE FINANCIAL BURDEN OF
PURCHASING.
THE NEW SYSTEMS THEY NEED.
THEY NEED.
YOUR HELP.
OUR VOTING SYSTEMS WERE DESIGNED
AND ENGINEERED FRANKLY IN THE
LATE NINETEEN NINETIES.
WHAT DID YOUR CELLPHONE LOOK
LIKE?
TWENTY YEARS AGO.
WHAT DID YOUR TELEVISION LOOK
LIKE
TWENTY YEARS AGO?
WHAT WAS THE CAPABLE OF?
AT THAT TIME.
WE WOULDN'T SETTLE FOR TWENTY
YEAR OLD TECHNOLOGY.
AND ON OUR PHONES ARE
SMARTPHONES ARE CONSUMER
PRODUCTS.
AND A VOTING SYSTEMS
BE NO DIFFERENT.
SO YES I'M THE SPONSOR OF
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIX EIGHT BY
SOME OF EVER GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
WHICH SEEKS TO IF YOU UP TO FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
BONDS.
SUPPORT THE REPLACEMENT OF A
COUNTY VOTING SYSTEMS.
THAT WAS INTRODUCED LAST YEAR
WE'VE MADE LITTLE PROGRESS THAT
YOUR HUSBAND THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. IN THE BUDGET.
FOR THE REPLACEMENT OF VOTING
SYSTEMS
ACQUIRE A COUNTY MATCH WHO WERE
TALKING FULLY LEVERAGE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS TO UPGRADE AND REPLACE
VOTING EQUIPMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S A GREAT START.
INVESTING IN NEW VOTING
EQUIPMENT IS THE MOST IMMEDIATE
URGENT NEED TO SECURE OUR
ELECTIONS.
SO I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
STATE INVESTMENT IN YOU VOTING
SYSTEMS.
SUPPORT OUR GOING STATE SUPPORT.
STATE AND COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS.
THERE'S MUCH MUCH MORE A I CAN
SPEAK TO THIS MORNING BUT I
WANTED AT LEAST START WITH THESE
HIGHLIGHTS.
.
LET ME JUST CONCLUDE WITH THIS
AND NOT PREPARED TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS.
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR DEMOCRACY
CLEARLY DEPENDS ON OUR ABILITY
TO GUARD AGAINST CYBER THREATS.
COMMUNICATING CLEARLY AND
RESPONSIBLY WITH THE PUBLIC.
STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS WILL
REMAIN VIGILANT AS A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ELECTIONS
YOU'RE UP.
WHEN I DO WHAT DAIS FROM
ELECTION.
BUT AT DISSIPATED CYBER THREATS
REQUIRE THE MOBILIZATION AND
LEADERSHIP OF THE ENTIRE
GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP
AND BLOWING SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS
TO PROVE CALIFORNIA'S ELECTION
CYBERSECURITY.
HAPPY RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SECRETARY
SECRETARY PEDIA.
DO ANY.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE S.
CENTER SENATOR ANDERSON.
I.
.
I HAVE JUST GOTTEN A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU SO.
I CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE.
THE VOTER RATE THE CHANGE IN
VOTER REGISTRATION ISSUE THAT
OCCURRED IN RIVERSIDE ARE. IN
JUNE OF TWENTY SIXTEEN. ANOTHER
THERE'S A BIG BROUHAHA OVER THAT
WERE.
PEOPLE A GUARD TO WRECK START
SAID SOMEBODY SWITCHMAN VOTER
REGISTRATION WITHOUT. ME DOING
THAT.
AND I KNOW THE DA.
PURSUED IT BUT HE COULD GET
THEIR IP ADDRESSES.
SO WHAT WE DOING ABOUT THAT.
HOW'S IT LOOK AT HOW DID HOW
COULD DID OCCUR.
.
SO FAMILIAR WITH WHAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING THERE TO ALLEGATIONS
OF AND CALL THEM INCIDENTS.
WE AT.
TWO SOURCES YOU KNOW HOW WE
HEARD FROM A FLURRY OF VOTERS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WHERE WOULD
THIS HAPPEN.
ANSWER IS NO.
ARE WE AWARE OF ALLEGATIONS BY
THE DA. THAT SOMETHING WAS
SYSTEMATICALLY HAPPENING YET FOR
HER TO MEDIA REPORTS
AND REACHED OUT AND ASK FOR.
NAMES OF VICTIMS NAMES OF VOTERS
THAT THIS HAPPENED TO.
A AND HAVE ONLY BEEN SUPPLIED A
HANDFUL FRANKLY AND.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THAT
HANDFUL THAT WERE ACTUALLY
EXPLANATIONS HAVING RESEARCHED
THE ARAB REGISTRATION RECORDS
OF ALL BUT ONE WHICH.
LOSE MEETINGS ARE INCONCLUSIVE
SO A I WOULDN'T CATEGORIZE IT OR
CONCLUDE THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING RAMPANT OR SYSTEMIC
ABOUT GOING ON BUT IF YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT THE
DA HASN'T.
PROVIDED TO OFFICE WERE HAPPY TO
INVESTIGATE.
WHAT WOULD BE THE?
?
RATIONAL EXPLANATIONS THAT YOU
WERE ABLE TO RUN DOWN.
IN THOSE HANDFUL THAT.
THANK THINGS LIKE GOING BACK AND
FINDING EITHER ORIGINAL VOTER
REGISTRATION CARD OR BE
REGISTRATION RECORDS THAT SHOWED
THAT.
BUT IT'S PARTY AFFILIATION OR
ANY OTHER ISSUE IN QUESTION
ADDRESS CHANGE.
OKAY AND THEN. THERE WERE TWO
RECENT NBC STORIES.
RELATED TO THE PREACHER VOTING
SYSTEMS.
AND.
AND HE WAS IN SEVENTEEN STATES.
AND OUR I WONDER IF YOU COULD
JUST SPEAK TO THAT. YOU KNOW
WHAT.
WHAT'S THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN
NBC STORIES AND
WHAT'S ACTUALLY GOING ON.
IT KNOW IS INTO A SIDEBAR. OF A
CAPILLARY ISSUE WERE.
WHAT?
TING PROMPTING MY FIRST GOAL
WHO'S WORKED WITH SENATOR
ANDERSON YOU CYBER VOCABULARY IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD.
SO A TWO PART RESPONSE ONE
THE THE RECENT NBC REPORTS AND
THEN.
ALTHOUGH SHED LIGHT ON THE.
TWENTY ONE STATE.
LIST YOUR QUESTION OR ISSUE.
THE RECENT AND BEACH REPORTS A.
FRANKLY PROVIDED NO NEW
INFORMATION.
DIDN'T PROVIDE OUR OFFICE ANY.
MISSION THAT WE DIDN'T ALREADY
HAVE ABOUT PREVIOUS SCANNING
REPORTS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
UNNAMED SOURCES SORT OF ALLEGING
THAT SOMETHING MORE THAT
HAPPENED BUT THEY COULDN'T TELL
US EXACTLY WHAT.
US ALONE WE RESPONDED.
WITH.
THAT TO THE ABBEY TO REPORT THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC SECURITY AS
WELL.
.
HAD SENT CONCLUSION.
A.
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHAT NBC WHAT
INFORMATION A. B. C. NEWS FROM
LAST WEEK THINK THEY HAD BUT.
THEY'RE NOT SHARON IT IT'S HARD
TO TELL THERE'S NOTHING NEW.
AT THAN THE PRIOR A SCANNING
QUICKLY SCANNING REPORT A.
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO SO HERE'S
WHAT HAPPENED THERE LAST FALL.
OF
GOT A CALL FROM THE PART OF A
MUCH SECURITY.
A.
BASICALLY SINGLE WE HAVE SOME
NEWS TO SHARE WITH.
A WEEK INTO.
NOW REFERRAL TO TELL YOU THAT
THE RUSSIANS WERE SCANNING.
YOUR STATE ELECTIONS NETWORK.
AGAIN SCANNING.
NOT HACKING NOT BREACH NOT.
YOU KNOW TAKEN DOWN NOT
MANIPULATED INFORMATION
SCANT.
UPON FURTHER QUESTIONING
OUR TECHNICAL FOLKS THEIR
TECHNICAL FOLKS.
IT TURNS OUT DATA.
IT WASN'T ACTUALLY ARE ELECTIONS
THAT WERE BY DESIGN.
THE SECRETARY SIX ELECTIONS.
SYSTEMS ARE NOT ON THE STATE'S
GENERAL NETWORK.
EXCEPT IT WAS SCAMMING ACTIVITY
GOING ON IT WAS THE STATE'S
GENERAL NETWORK.
WHICH ARE ELECTIONS ELEMENTS ARE
NOT ALL.
FOR THIS PRECISE REASON FOR
SECURITY.
SO.
TWO ITEMS ABOUT THAT FOLK OFTEN
HOW MUCH COULD WESTERN NUMBER
ONE.
A COMMITTEE YEAR TO TELL US THAT
THE RUSSIANS FOR SCANNING OUR
NETWORK.
RIGHT THE TIMELINESS IS THE
CONCERN THERE.
TO GET BETTER.
NUMBER TWO THE QUALITY OF THE
IN.
RIGHT SEWER I GET.
AT OF A RESPONSIBILITY TO BE
TRANSPARENT AND HONEST WITH THE
PUBLIC QUITS.
A CLEAR ABOUT WHAT DID WHAT DID
NOT HAPPEN. WILL BE HACKED NO
WAS OUR SCANNING. YES SCARY
THOUGHT HACK OF RECKLESS GETTING
HAPPENS EVERYDAY.
AND IT HAPPENS TO THE. UP A TON
OF FOLKS.
.
LESSON LEARNED FROM THAT IS THE
THE NEED TO A IMPROVE UPON THE
PROTOCOLS AND PRACTICES FOR HOW
BOTH AND INFORMATION AND
INTELLIGENCE SHARED.
EITHER FROM COUNTIES TO THE
STATES TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OR THE FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO THE STATES
OR NOW TO LOCALS ANDA THAT'S
BEGINNING TO HAPPEN.
THE SENATOR.
SECRETARY.
MR ARBOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND.
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION AND A DESCRIPTION
OF THE DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES AND
DISTINGUISHING THEM BECAUSE. I I
pDIALOGUE AS WELL AS THE.
THE MEDIA PRESENTATION OFTEN A
LOT OF ISSUES ARE CONFLATED
TOGETHER YEAH I AND IT DOES MAKE
IT A TRICKY UP FOR THE FOR THE
PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO BUY TO
FOLLOW AND UP FOR FOR THOSE WHO
WERE EVEN A.
I IN AN INTERESTED LEVEL
FOLLOWING. OF ONE THING THAT.
IN TERMS OF HAVING OVERALL
CONTEXT OF IT DONE BECAUSE YOU
DID THAT DO A GREAT JOB IN TERMS
OF PROVIDING OVERALL CONTEXT. OF
THE ONE THING THAT I WANTED
FURTHER CLARITY ON. I'VE ALWAYS
ON THE TIMELINE OF AYE INDEED
HOW IDEN THIS LEVEL OF SCANNING.
ATTEMPTS TO HACKING ATTEMPTS AT
BREACH AYE ATTEMPTS ON WOULD YOU
CHARACTERIZE THIS IS A
PHENOMENON THAT'S BEEN PRESENT
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TWENTY TWELVE
TWENTY TEN. IN ELECTIONS BEFORE
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT'S A ON A
STEADY UPSWING AS ELECTIONS ARE
PROGRESS. I OR IS THIS SOMETHING
WHERE YOU FOUND AYE THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN PROVIDE SOMETHING OF A
UNIQUE SPIKE IF YOU WILL TOOK.
.
AGAIN WALKING THE LINE BETWEEN
THE.
BEING CLEAR AND AUDITS OF THE
PUBLIC VERSES NOT GIVE AWAY THE
COMBINATION TO THE SAFE.
IMAGES TIE IT.
SCANNING NO PRO.
ACTIVITY OF THAT NATURE
APPETITE A CONSTANT.
BASS.
TO ANY ENTITY THAT HAS.
A PUBLIC INTERFACE BOTH IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
OF.
YOU KNOW SOME PEOPLE SAID LOOK
THERE'S JUST VALUE IN DATA
MINING RIGHT. ON THE DARK NET
BAD ACTORS.
IDENTITY THEFT THAT CETERA.
AND TOOK.
THAT DRIVES A LOT OF THE
ACTIVITY SEPARATE APART FROM
THOSE WHO ARE SPECIFICALLY.
TARGETING OR OR OR WHO SPECIFIC
GOALS IS TO CREATE CHAOS
FUSION AND UNDER MY CONFIDENCE
IN OUR DEMOCRACY BUT THAT'S A
VERY VERY CLEAR OBJECTIVE.
AND JUST THE SHEER FACT THAT
WE'RE HAVING THIS HEARING.
THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT THE
RUSSIANS HAVE SUCCEEDED IN PART.
RIGHT BUT THAT'S DIFFERENT BEN.
COMPROMISE ANY VOTING SYSTEMS
ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CHANGE THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTIONS.
CALIFORNIA AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
WE'VE SEEN NO EVIDENCE OF THAT
UP AT YOUR QUESTION YOU KNOW.
TWENTY FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
I I ASSUME IT'S GOTTA BE
HAPPENING.
FROM A VARIETY OF ACTORS
FOR A VARIETY A OF A OBJECTIVES.
LOT PEOPLE LEAD YOU KNOW
WHISPERED IN MY EAR TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE KANATA SWING STATE
IN ECONOMIC A DIFFERENT IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAUGHT THAT YOU
HAVE NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT. I
DISAGREE FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE A HIGH VALUE TARGET.
IT'S I HAVE TO OPERATE UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION WITH WHETHER IT'S
IT'S REAL OR NOT AND I CHOOSE TO
OF IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE DIDN'T
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE WELL. AND
TWENTY TWENTY AND BEYOND.
AND.
THE FOLLOW UP BY IN REGARDS TO
THAT DONE.
IS WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE OVER
TIME MORE SPECIFIC TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN.
.
IN THESE TYPES OF STE.
HACKING SCANNING EXCEPT FOR A.
AYE EXCLUSIVE TO RUSSIA WAR I OR
THEIR POTENTIAL CHINESE STATE OR
NON STATE ACTORS OR OTHER
COUNTRIES THROUGHOUT THE WORLD I
IN TERMS OF THE A BASE OF.
OF THESE KINDS OF FOR.
I INTERACTIONS WITH THE
ELECTIONS IT SO AGAIN.
YOU.
PROBABLY MULTIPLE MULTIPLE
SOURCES OF THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY.
YOU KNOW AND WE CAN DEBATE OR
QUESTIONER INQUIRE ABOUT THE
ULTIMATE OBJECTIVES OF THE KIND
OF ACTIVITY.
THE THE THE THREAT AND THE
TACTICS ARE WHAT THEY ARE AND WE
HAVE TO BE PREPARED TO DEFEND
AGAINST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA.
I THINK MISTER CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING MR SECRETARY THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US UP I WANTED TO GO
BACK TO WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THE
COUNTY OFFICIALS IN THE COUNTIES
NOT RECEIVING ANY STATE OR
FEDERAL MONEY. SO DOES THAT MEAN
EACH COUNTY HOUSE TO UP WITH
THIS IN THEIR BUDGET SO EACH
COUNTY MAY HAVE MORE OR LESS AND
REALLY EACH COUNTY. IS OPERATING
A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY DEPENDING
ON HOW MUCH MONEY THEY ALLOCATE
TO THE VOTING SYSTEMS.
ARE SOMEONE ABOUT YOU ASKED THAT
THE SPECIFIC QUESTION TO THE
REPRESENTS IN THE COUNTY THAT
THEY CAME UP TO TESTIFY.
BUT.
YOU SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS YOU
KNOW OUR COUNTIES REIMBURSE FOR
CONDUCTING A SPECIAL ELECTION.
THE FULLER LAKE I THINK THOUGH.
A WHERE THE COUNTIES BUDGETS
FOR.
VOTING SYSTEMS AND EQUIPMENT.
RIGHT THERE'S NOT INHERIT BILL
TEN LINE ITEM THAT'S EACH AND
EVERY YEAR IT COMES AND GOES
OVER TIME AND DEPENDING ON THE
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT THAT WERE
ENTERED YOUR BUDGET SURPLUSES
ARE DEFICITS.
AND HOW THIS MEASURE UP WITH
COMPETING PRIORITIES AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL RIGHT UP IN EVEN. A
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
RIGHT HAD WE AUGMENT THE KEY ANY
PARTICULAR COUNTY
OF THEIR IT DEPARTMENT AND.
FURTHER BETTER TRAINED THEIR IT
STAFF.
IN AREAS OF CYBERSECURITY
ABOUT WHETHER COMPETING MAYBE
WITH THE A DIFFERENT CHAU WITHIN
THE WITHIN THE COUNTY OR MAYBE
TO SATELLITE SO OFTEN TEAR
COUNTIES. FUNCTIONS YES EVERY
COUNTIES A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
BUT WE ALL HAVE A VESTED STAKE
IN.
FREE AND FAIR AND SECURE
ELECTIONS.
SO OF BY WHAT I WOULD ARGUE THAT
STATE NEEDS TO BE A PARTNER IN
THAT INVEST.
I AGREE WITH YOU AND I WILL ASK
MORE QUESTIONS OF.
THE COUNTIES THAT ARE HERE BUT
IT WORRIED ME WHEN YOU SAID THAT
SOME OF THE ELECTION SYSTEMS ARE
LITERALLY FALLING APART SO IF I
VOTINGFORWARD ABOUT BEING
COMPROMISED WE PROBABLY ONE HAVE
THE BEST VOTING.
MACHINES OUT THERE BUT THANK
YOU.
FOLLOWING UP ON THE SANDERS
POINT.
HEAR YOU MENTION THAT KIND OF.
THE.
BIGGEST THING THAT WE COULD DO
RIGHT NOW IS TO INVEST IN
UPDATED. ELECTION SYSTEMS OTHER
THAN THAT OTHER CHANGES THAT YOU
THINK WE SHOULD BE MAKING
IMMEDIATELY.
TO INCREASE ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE SECURITY.
AND I YOU KNOW I GIVE AWAY THE
KEYS TO THE SAFE BUT. YOU KNOW
I.
AND ANYTHING THAT YOU FEEL
CONFIDENT OR COMFORTABLE SAYING.
BY OTHER. INITIATIVES THAT WE
SHOULD BE UNDERTAKING YES I
THINK.
WHAT WILL ARGUE WORKING A WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO? PROVIDE YOU
KNOW CARE A GUIDANCE
GUIDELINES.
CONSEQUENCES.
FOR THIRD PARTIES WHO WERE.
A ARE NOT ACCESS TO SOME
ELEMENTS OF YOUR.
BUT REGISTRATION EIGHT BUCKS
EVEN RIGHT THE CURRENT STATE LAW
DOES ALLOW.
NOT NOT ALL OF THE VOTERS
INFORMATION TO
SHARED BUT PERTINENT.
ELEMENTS OF THE VOTER FILE TO
BE SHARED WITH CAMPAIGNS FOR
OUTREACH PURPOSES.
YOU KNOW JOURNALISTS
A ACADEMICS FOR RESEARCH
PURPOSES AT CETERA. A AND WE
HAVE HISTORICALLY JUST TRUSTED
THAT THAT DATA WHAT THE THIRD
PARTY HAS LAWFUL ACCESS TO THIS
PROPERTY.
.
BOB SHORE THAT UP A LITTLE BIT
AGAIN.
DIFFERENT THAN.
A CARING ARCH HURDLES SYSTEMS
FOR ELECTION MINISTRATION
PURPOSES.
BUT WE HEAR FROM TIME TO TIME
OWES.
SOME OF INFORMATION WAS ACCESSED
ON THE WEBER SOMEBODY THIRD
PARTY GOT MIGHT BE COMPROMISED.
THAT GOES BACK TO UNDERMINING
VOTERS COPY TO THE PUBLIC'S
CONFIDENCE IN A OUR ELECTIONS.
BOB THAT'S ANOTHER ITEM THAT I
THINK THE SLIPPED STITCH WOULD
RETAIN SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
THANK YOU.
SHED A COUPLE QUESTIONS THANK
YOUR TESTIMONY I I WILL SAY
SHARE.
YOUR.
CONCERNED ABOUT SORT OF
PREMISE OF THIS HEARING IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND LORD OF THE.
THE.
THE CONCESSION I GUESS WE HAVE
TO MAKE THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
RUSSIAN IMPACT ON OUR NATIONAL
ELECTION DOWN I'M I'M I'M
FRANKLY FRUSTRATED THAT.
THAT THEY'VE SET THE FRAME BUT I
THINK WE CAN TAKE IT BACK HERE
TODAY THROUGH.
EVIDENCE OF YOUR DILIGENCE IN
HOUSE.
IN AYE I OF IT'S PRETTY
REMARKABLE.
.
I DID WANT TO ASK ABOUT THIS
SORT OF.
YOUR SECURITY AUDITS OF ALL
STATE AGENCIES.
OUR SOPHISTICATION IN BUILDING
THE SECURE INTERNAL NETWORKS THE
MANAGEMENT OF OUR DATA SYSTEMS.
.
I WANT TO ASK ON THAT FRONT.
THERE WAS A.
.
THERE'S A ARTICLE ABOUT A
SACRAMENTO BEE.
.
BREACH
BUT.
I WAS TAKING AN OLD VOTER
DATABASE.
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND
SORT OF THE PRESS REPORTED AS A
HACK.
ULTIMATELY OUR VOTER FILES FROM
MY UNDERSTANDING WERE NOT
ACTUALLY HACKED BUT A THIRD
PARTY HAD AN OUTDATED SECURITY
SYSTEM IN THIS CASE A NEWSPAPER.
CAN YOU HELP US MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION TO BECAUSE.
THE LOOSE WORDS AND AND OUR
PRESS RIGHT NOW I THINK OUR.
THERE THEIR CANDY RIGHT FOR FOR
READERS THEY LOOK THEY LOOK
EXCITING IF YOU SEE THE WORD
HACK ON THE FRONT PAGE YOU'RE
GONNA YOU'RE GONNA PICK UP THAT
PAPER YOU GONNA CLICK THAT LINK
BUT.
JUST TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
YEAH I DID ARE TOO GOOD A MORE
ABOUT THE DANGERS IN LANGUAGE
THERE DISTINGUISHING THAT OUT.
THAT PARTICULAR INSTANCE AND DO
WE NEED I MEAN ON THAT NOTE I
GUESS THAT THE SECOND PART IS.
IS THERE ANYTHING WE SHOULD BE
DOING.
EITHER TO ASSIST THE COUNTY'S IN
A SIMILAR KIND OF SECURITY
AUDIT.
.
ONUS ON THE CYBER FRONT.
TO TO PROTECT ANY
VULNERABILITIES ARE INTERFACE
WITH PRIVATE ACTORS RATE LIKE WE
WE CAN'T TELL A NEWSPAPER. A
FROM THE SECRETARY STATEHOUSE
NECESSARILY HAD OF HOW TO MANAGE
THEIR SERVERS BUT.
THAT INTERFACE WITH PUBLIC DATA.
JUST HOW DID TIGHTEN THAT UP.
KNOW EXACTLY AND SERBIA THE
INCIDENT REFERRING TO THE PUBLIC
OF A RECENT EXAMPLE OF A.
YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS EXPLAINING
TO TO CHAIRMAN BERMAN HERE.
SO.
SACRAMENTO BEE.
OF OUR GREAT JOURNALISTS THERE
THEY HAVE LAWFUL ACCESS TO
VOTER INFORMATION FROM OUR
OFFICE.
SO WHEN IT WAS REPORTED THAT
THERE WAS A. A A BEACH OTHER
SERVER YOU KNOW OR SOMEHOW THERE
WAS UNLAWFUL ACCESS TO
INFORMATION THAT WAS BEING
HOUSED ON THEIR SERVER.
HOW DOES GET WRITTEN RIGHT IN
THE NEWSPAPERS ON BLOGS IT'S
ATTITUDE VOTER INFORMATION
COMPROMISED OR STOLEN OR YOU
KNOW WHATEVER THE? THE
SENSATIONAL HEADLINE IT'S.
MOST PEOPLE WILL IMMEDIATELY
THINK.
I OFFICE
RIGHT SO WE GET THE PHONE CALLS.
WHEN.
LOOK AT OUR SYSTEM PAY WERE.
WHAT WERE FRONT RUNNER TOES BUT
WERE FIGHT HERE?
THE REAL INCIDENT WAS A THIRD
PARTY.
AND SEWER AGAIN WHERE ARE OUR
OFFICE OF WORKING WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
CRAFT LANGUAGE TO IMPROVE UPON.
A THE GUIDANCE.
THE THE DIRECTIVES INFECTED
REQUIREMENTS AND AND THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR NOT FOLLOWING
SOMA.
SECURE MAINTENANCE OF VOTER
INFORMATION FOR THIRD PARTIES.
I YEAH I THAT THAT WAS THE OTHER
COMPONENT AYE QUESTION THERE'S
ON ON THE CONSEQUENCES FRONT.
.
IN ADDITION TO.
OUTDATED OR SLOPPY MANAGEMENT ON
THE PRIVATE SECTOR SIDE OF THEIR
OWN SERVERS AND NETWORKS I'M
ALSO WONDERING FOR INDIVIDUALS.
.
WHEN THERE'S MISINFORMATION
BEING SPREAD SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
ELECTIONS SO WE'VE SEEN
ALLEGATIONS OF FOLKS SAYING THE
WRONG ELECTION DAY LAST CYCLE
YOU CAN VOTE ONLINE. THIS KIND
OF THIS INFORMATION.
THAT GETS
POTENTIALLY SORT OF BOMBARDED ON
VOTERS IN IT COULD COME LAST
MINUTE RIGHT THESE KINDS OF
THINGS COULD COME LATE AND THEY
COULD. THROUGH DIVERT US IN.
CONSEQUENCES FOR THOUGH FOR
THOSE KINDS OF ACTIONS AND.
WHO ENFORCES TOO BECAUSE I THINK
WE WE BLUR THE LINE THERE
BETWEEN? ACTUAL CRIMINAL ACTION
WHICH SEEMS TO EVEN EMERGE OUT
OF YOUR OFFICE INTO THE AG'S
FEAR BUT JUST WONDER ABOUT THAT
SORT OF.
MISINFORMATION NIGHT THAT WAS A
BIG CHALLENGE FOR US IN IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN READ THOSE A LOT
OF.
INFORMATION A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION THAT WAS OUT
THERE.
ITS WHAT IN A TALK ABOUT GOOD
OLD FASHIONED YOU KNOW
CAMPAIGNER INFORMING THE PUBLIC
WITH ITS KNOCKING ON DOORS OR
WHAT HAVE YOU TO. THE TOOLS OF
A TRADITIONAL MEDIA. MASS MEDIA
BROADCASTS ITS HEADER VERSES
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS AND
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES.
A BED HAVE ON THE UPSIDE THE
BITTER REACH A LOT MORE PEOPLE
LOT MORE QUICKLY A LOT MORE
EFFECTIVELY.
GOOD INFORMATION HAD THE DOUBTS
HAD TO BE ABLE TO REACH A LOT
MORE PEOPLE HAVE MORE
EFFECTIVELY. INTO WITH.
NOT SO GOOD INFORMATION RIGHT
AND AND IT'S
THE PROVERBIAL HAD PUT THE
TOOTHPASTE BACK IN THE TUBE BAD
INFORMATION IS OUT THERE WHETHER
IT'S.
POLLING PLACE CLOSED.
ORDER.
BUT MY LEAST FAVORITES WAS DONE
AT THE GIVE YOU PROVISIONAL
BALLOT IS NOT GONNA BE CAD
ABSOLUTELY NOT TRUE. RIGHT RIGHT
AND IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO GO BACK
INTO HAVING PEOPLE DIDN'T GET A
CHANCE TO VOTE BECAUSE THEY
FOLLOWED BAD ADVICE YOU BET. BUT
INFORMATION SO IT WE TRY THE
BEST YOU CAN ON ALL OF OUR
PLATFORMS TO PUT OUT TO BE GOOD
RIGHT PROPER INFORMATION THAT
PEOPLE KNOW THAT.
OUR OFFICE
COUNTY REGISTRAR VOTERS OFFICE
IS THE TRUSTED SOURCE IF THERE'S
QUESTIONS.
AND.
.
YOU KNOW HAVING BEEN IN
WASHINGTON A COUPLE WEEKENDS AGO
AT A NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SECRETARIES OF STATE CONFERENCE.
OF THE REPRESENTATIVES FROM A AT
A MINIMUM FACEBOOK TWITTER.
MAKING PLEDGES TO ALL
SECRETARIES OF STATE TO HAVE
POINTS OF CONTACT
READILY AVAILABLE A TO HELP IN
ASSISTING YOU TAKEN DOWN BY
INFORMATION OR ADDRESSING. OF
MISINFORMATION THAT COMES VIA
THEIR PLATFORMS IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ELECTION
A AND GO AND VOTE AND SO AND SO
WHAT AND WHAT FORM DOES THAT
AGREEMENT TAKE IS THAT IT.
IT SAID JUST A OF A PRIVATE
COMMITMENT IS IS IS THERE ANYWAY
TO TO. REALLY PIN THEM DOWN AND
SAY ANSWERING THEM OWE YOU OR
SOMETHING THAT CAN REALLY BUYING
THEM TO THAT WHAT LARA EXPLORE
EVENT I MEAN RIGHT NOW WITH.
IT'S IT'S A PRIVATE COMMITMENT
AND THE.
.
AND A GOOD WORKING RELATIONSHIP
YEAH I MEAN THERE YEAH AND THEY
ALSO CAN'T MAKE FALSE STATEMENTS
PUBLICLY ARE PUBLICLY TRADED
COMPANIES SO THEY ARE MAKING
THAT COMMITMENT WE CAN HOLD THEM
TO THAT I I. I DO THINK THERE'S
GONNA BE A CHALLENGE.
TAKING THINGS DOWN QUICKLY
ENOUGH IS PROBABLY GOING TO BE
HARDER THAN HAVING VERY CREDIBLE
SOURCES WITH A LOUD ENOUGH
MEGAPHONE TO ACTUALLY GET THAT
INFORMATION SO I DID WANT TO
DRILL DOWN JUST.
I KNOW THIS IS IN A BUDGET
HEARING BUT WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S.
REQUEST.
ARE YOU GONNA HAVE.
SORT OF IN HOUSE AND AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL ADEQUATE RESOURCES
TO GET THAT MESSAGE OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW A DAYS THESE THIS IS.
GOING TO THAT SORT OF SOFT
INFRASTRUCTURE PART YES WILL BE
UPDATING VOTING EQUIPMENT BUT
ARE YOU HAVE THAT THIS SORT OF
PERSONNEL IN DIGITAL RESOURCE
DIDN'T TO.
PUSH A REALLY CREDIBLE
COMMUNICATIONS PLATFORM THAT.
VIA SO THE LINE ITEM IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET.
STRICTLY FOR VOTING SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT FULLER.
AT COMMUNICATION IT'S NOT
FULLER.
KETTERING CERTAIN BET SOCIAL
MEDIA REPORTS
A IF IT'S.
A AND THE APPETITE OF
LEGISLATRE TO ADELINE AND THE
BUDGET TO THAT EFFECT WE
WELCOME.
YEAH I'M AND I'M JUST WARNING
RIGHT NOW CAPACITY WISE IN HOUSE
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS WHAT IS THE
PERSONNEL LOOK LIKE THEY'RE I
MEAN WHAT DO YOU WHAT WHAT WHAT
IS YOUR TEAM LOOK LIKE TO DO
THIS SORT OF.
MYTH BUSTING IN MINUTES A LOT
TO PROBABLY TRACK AT THEIR
IMAGINED.
YOU HAVE TO BE READY FOR SO WHAT
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE A BUT LIMITED
COMMUNICATIONS AND OUTREACH
BUDGET AND PERSONAL POSITIONS.
WE.
LEVERAGE PARTNERSHIPS TO THE
BEST OF OUR ABILITY BOTH AT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL AND IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR I TOLD SOARED
LIKE THAT TWITTER AND FACEBOOK
CONVERSATION
REFERRING TO.
OKAY THANK YOU WE.
THAT'S ALL I'VE GOT EM DUE TO
MAKE A CLOSING REMARKS HERE I
MEAN I I DID WAS A BEFORE YOU
ENDED.
NBC
SACBEE REPORTING EVEN ON ITSELF
YOU KNOW EVEN MAINSTREAM MEDIA
HERE THEY'VE GOT TO BE CAREFUL
ABOUT.
SORT OF BLOWING THOSE LINES OF
JOURNALISTIC INTEGRITY AND I I I
I WANNA REALLY.
UNDERSCORE HIGH LIGHT YOU KNOW
STAMP THIS WORDS MATTER CYBER
VOCABULARY MATTERS
OUR ELECTION SYSTEM I'M HERE
FROM YOU IS BEEN ROCK SOLID.
WE GOTTA KEEP UPDATING BUT.
.
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY NBC IS
LISTENING AND.
.
THINKS TWICE BEFORE JUST FEEDING
THE PUBLIC PARANOIA JUST BECAUSE
THEY'LL CLICK IT IT'S A
DANGEROUS DANGEROUS ENTERPRISE.
WITHOUT A LIGHT CLOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU BYE AND I THINK THAT
THE NEW JUST TO SORT OF
EMPHASIZE THE THE THE MAIN PLACE
TO CHAT TO CONVEY HERE TODAY. A
NUMBER ONE IT'S BEEN SAID A
COUPLE TIMES NOW CYBER
VOCABULARY RIGHT WORDS MATTER
NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TO THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN.
YOU KNOW THAT THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR VOTING SYSTEMS YES THEY NEED
AND INVESTMENT EVER BEEN
OVERTAKEN.
AFTER THE FIRST STEP OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGET.
.
BUT IN A
BUT THERE WOULD THERE WAS NO
BREACH OUR ACT OF ANY KIND IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
WERE PREPARING FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND BEYOND BUT THAT'S
VERY DIFFERENT.
VAN DECLARE MISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN THAT'S THAT'S GOING ON
A WILL CONTINUE TO GO ON.
AND EFFORTS AT NOT JUST
MISINFORMATION BUT.
TRULY COMPROMISING A SYSTEM.
.
WHETHER IT'S AGENTS OF THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT OR OTHERS.
THEY WILL LEARN
WHAT WORKED AND WHAT DIDN'T WORK
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TRY AGAIN
THIS YEAR. AND LEARN WHAT DOES
OR DOESN'T WORK AND EIGHTEEN AND
TRY TO GET A TWENTY TWO AND I
HAVE NO DOUBTS AS TO HAVE TO%
COST WOULD BE PREPARED. AND
COSTLY BE IMPROVING AND THAT
REQUIRES US TO WORK TOGETHER.
THANK MISS SECRETARY THANK YOU.
OUT WITH THAT WE WILL LET THE
SECRETARY GET ON WITH HIS DAY
AND INVITE MATTHEW MASTERSON TO
THE DYESS.
WE HAVE BEEN TO ADVERTISEMENT.
AT.
NOT THE DICE ARE.
WHERE'S.
WELCOME MR MASTERS THANK YOU.
WELL WE DON'T A SCROOGE.
PUTTING A REAL BRAIN TRUST.
YEAH RIGHT YEAH YOU DON'T DON'T
LEAVE ME FOR MISTER HARPER.
.
MORNING AND.
THANKS RING THE TRIP WEST.
AND GOVERNMENT FOR BEING HERE
AND FOR ALL YOUR SERVICE.
BOTH IN THE LAST ADMINISTRATION
AN EARLY ON IN THIS CURRENT.
WHITE HOUSE.
.
YOU KNOW YOUR WORK IMPLEMENTING
HAVA.AND REALLY BEEFING UP.
OUR ATTENTION ON CYBERSECURITY
THREATS NATIONALLY IS.
PRETTY MUCH UNPARALLELED AS FAR
AS I CAN TELL SO.
.
I'M I'M STILL AYE I DO HAVE TO
SAY IS AN EDITORIAL COMMENT UP
FRONT I'M I'M STILL PRETTY
SHOCKED AND.
DISAPPOINTED THAT.
.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE RENEWING YOUR
EXPERTISE IN WASHINGTON IT IT IS
A LOT OF KNOWLEDGE TO LEAVE ON
THE TABLE BUT. MAKE NO MISTAKE
CALIFORNIA WILL TAKE FULL
ADVANTAGE OF YOUR BRAIN POWER
TODAY IN GOING FORWARD SO. THEIR
LOSS IS OUR GAIN.
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
JUST TO OF FOR THAT FOR THE REST
OF.
MY COLLEAGUES YOUR DAY A
COMMISSIONER MASTERS IN A IS A A
CURRENTLY A MEMBER OF THE U. S.
ELECTION IT ASSISTANCE
COMMISSION WHICH ADMINISTERS
HABA AND. AND THIS IS A STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
ADMINISTRATION A SAFE AND SECURE
ELECTIONS I GET RECENTLY
COMPLETED IS ONE YOUR TERM IS
THE CHAIR. AYE HE MADE
CYBERSECURITY TOP PRIORITY THERE
AND RECEIVED PRAISE FOR HIS
NONPARTISAN AND OBJECTIVE MANNER
IN WHICH YOU HANDLE THE ISSUES
HE WROTE REPORTS FOR BOTH THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND FOR THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ON
CYBERSECURITY IN OUR VOTING.
CHRISTIAN MESSAGE AND HAS A
WEALTH OF EXPERIENCE IN
ELECTIONS ISSUES IN ADDITION WAS
MET A SERVICES MEMBER THE EAC
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS STAFF TO
THE SEA. AND IS STAFF IN THE
OHIO SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE.
AS FORMER STAFF
APPRECIATE GUY COMES UP THROUGH
THE RANKS SO THANK YOU FOR
FLYING OUT HERE.
PLEASE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
.
BOTH THE CHAIRMAN BERMAN
CHAIRMAN SHARON THANK YOU FOR
THAT KIND INTRODUCTION I
APPRECIATE IT.
I CAN ASSURE YOU.
I'M STILL AT THE AC STILL DOING
THE GOOD WORK AYE THAT WE HAVE
TO DO AND AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO SO I APPRECIATE THAT. ARE
GOOD MORNING TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU ARE ALL
FOR HAVING ME OUT AGAIN MY
NAME'S BOB MATT MASTERSON.
I AM A COMMISSIONER AT THE
UNITED STATES ELECTION
ASSISTANCE COMMISSION ON
HOPEFULLY TODAY CAN PROVIDE OF.
A NATIONAL PERSPECTIVE ON WHERE
WE ARE NOW WITH CYBERSECURITY IN
THE ELECTION SYSTEMS THE WORK
THAT'S GOING ON AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AS WELL AS THE WORK ACROSS
THE COUNTRY BY THAT THE GREAT
ELECTION OFFICIALS AT THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVEL.
I WILL QUICKLY GO THROUGH
ROSTER ORAL TESTIMONY YOU HAVE
AN EXTENDED VERSION OF MY
TESTIMONY THERE ON SO I WON'T
DWELL ON ON MUCH OF THAT.
ARE THERE CAN BE NO DOUBT ABOUT
THE REAL AND SOPHISTICATED
THREATS AGAINST OUR NATION'S
ELECTION SYSTEMS INCLUDING
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS VIA
SOCIAL MEDIA AND OTHER OUTLETS.
AS WELL AS CYBER THREATS AGAINST
HER ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN FEDERAL
ELECTIONS DEMONSTRATED ARE THAT
WE'RE IN A NEW OPERATING
ENVIRONMENT ELECTIONS ONE THAT
POSES BOTH NEW CHALLENGES AND
NEW OPPORTUNITIES TO
COLLABORATE.
THE REALITY IS THAT IN TODAY'S
WORLD IF YOU OPERATE ANY IT SIT.
INCLUDING ELECTION SYSTEMS YOUR
TARGET OF NATION STATE ACTORS
FROM ACROSS THE GLOBE AND OTHER
SEEKING DISTRAUGHT THIS MONTH
DEMOCRACY.
ELECTION SECURITY HOWEVER BOTH
PHYSICAL AND CYBER IS NOT A NEW
CONCEPT FOR ELECTION OFFICIALS
NATIONWIDE AS YOU JUST HEARD
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
ELECTRONIC VOTING SYSTEMS AND
STATEWIDE VOTER REGISTRATION.
VOTER REGISTRATION DATA BASES
MORE THAN A DECADE AGO ELECTION
OFFICIALS HAVE FOCUSED
TO BETTER SECURE THE ELECTIONS
PROCESS.
ELECTION OFFICIALS ARE COMPLEX
IT SYSTEM MANAGERS IN FACT IN
MANY COUNTIES
THE COUNTY ELECTION OFFICE IS
THE LARGEST IT SYSTEM OPERATION
IN THE COUNTY.
AND AS SUCH JURISDICTIONS USE
MULTI LAYERED APPROACH TO ENSURE
THE INTEGRITY OF THE LECTURES
PROCESS.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT VOTERS
PERSONAL INFORMATION FOR EXAMPLE
ONLY AUTHORIZED PERSONNEL HAVE
ACCESS TO THE VOTER REGISTRATION
DATABASE DATABASE TRAFFIC IS
MONITORED FOR IRREGULARITIES.
EVERY TIME A RECORD IS ACCESS TO
CHANGE DETAILS FROM THAT SESSION
ARE LOGGED AND ROUTINE OFFLINE
BACKUPS HELP ENSURE ALL DATA CAN
BE RESTORED. IF ANY UNEXPECTED
MODIFICATIONS OCCUR
AND ADDITIONAL VOTING EQUIPMENT
AS WE HEARD FROM THE SECRETARY'S
PUBLICLY TESTED PRIOR TO THE
ELECTION TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
SYSTEMS ARE READY TO RUN THAT
ELECTION
WITH THAT PERSONNEL.
WITH POST ELECTION AUDITS
BECOMING THE NORM. ON THEY ARE
BECOMING THE NORM IT'S NOT A
QUESTION OF WHETHER TO AUDIT AT
THIS POINT IT'S HOW TO AUDIT.
ALL ELECTION OFFICIALS ARE
MOVING TO VERIFIABLE AN AUDIBLE
VOTING SYSTEMS AND ARE LOOKING
TO IMPLEMENT MORE EFFICIENT AND
MORE EFFECTIVE AUDITS TO PROVIDE
VOTERS.
WITH GREATER CONFIDENCE IN THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION.
CHAIN OF CUSTODY PROCEDURES
ASSOCIATED WITH TRANSPORTING AND
SECURING BALLOTS ARE FOLLOWED
THROUGHOUT THE ELECTIONS PROCESS
VOTING EQUIPMENT IS SEALED AND
MONITORED.
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS BY
ELECTION OFFICIALS IN APPROVED
OBSERVERS BALLOTS AND OTHER
SENSITIVE ELECTION MATERIALS ARE
KEPT IN SAFE. AND OTHER SECURE
AREAS ARE MAINTAINED BY CLERK'S
OFFICE WHICH IS OFTEN WITHIN A
SECURE FACILITY. THESE ARE JUST
A FEW OF THE MEASURES THAT
ELECTION OFFICIALS TAKE TO
SECURE IN IT NATION'S ELECTION
SYSTEMS.
WHILEWATCHING OFFICIALS ARE AT
THE HEART OF THESE EFFORTS WE AT
THE US ELECTION ASSISTANCE
COMMISSION OR E. A C.. HAVE LONG
HELP THEM IN THEIR WORK TO
ADMINISTER ELECTIONS
FOR THOSE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
A SAID LIKE OFFER JUST VERY
BRIEF BACKGROUND ON OUR WORK.
THE A SEA IS A BIPARTISAN
INDEPENDENT FEDERAL AGENCIES WHO
WERE NOT AN EXECUTIVE AGENCY OUR
BRANCH BUT INDEPENDENT OF THE
EXECUTIVE AGENCY ARE CREATED BY
THE HELP AMERICA VOTE ACT AFTER
THE TWO THOUSAND ELECTION.
OPERATES STUDY BY THE WAY HOW
MANY CLASSES I NOW SPEAK TO
WHERE THE KIDS DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE TWO THOUSAND ELECTION AS AND
I THINK. MAN I'VE GOTTEN OLD.
UNBELIEVING HANGING CHADS KNOW
THAT HALLOWEEN COSTUME CHARGES
THE AC WITH HELPING
ELECTION OFFICIALS ADMINISTER
ELECTIONS IN A VARIETY OF WAYS
THIS INCLUDES BUT IS NOT LIMITED
TO THE CREATION OF THE VOLUNTARY
VOTING SYSTEM GUIDELINES WHICH
ARE. GUIDELINES USED TO TEST AND
CERTIFY VOTING SYSTEMS TESTING
AND CERTIFYING VOTERS VOTING
SYSTEMS THROUGH THE FIRST AND
ONLY FEDERAL RUN VOLUNTARY
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. AND
PROVIDING BEST PRACTICES TO THE
STATE'S REGARDING EVERY FACET OF
THE AUCTIONS PROCESS.
INCLUDING SECURITY FOR VOTING
SYSTEMS AND POLLING PLACES
ELECTION DATABASE INTEGRITY AND
CONTINGENCY PLANNING FOR
ELECTIONS IN GENERAL. AHEAD OF
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTIONS ARE
WORK TO ADVISE ELECTION
OFFICIALS ON BEST PRACTICES TOOK
ON A WHOLE NEW DIMENSION.
IN THE WAKE OF REPORTS ABOUT
ATTACKS ON TO STATE LEVEL VOTER
REGISTRATION SYSTEMS THE A SEIZE
EFFORTS AND FOCUS TURTON TOWARD
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY. THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION TO HELP
PROTECT US ELECTIONS FROM
SPECIFIC CYBERSECURITY THREATS
IDENTIFIED BY THESE AGENCIES.
THE A. C. MET ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS WITH STAFF FROM D. H.
S. THE FBI THE WHITE HOUSE AND
OTHERS TO DISCUSS SPECIFIC AND
NONSPECIFIC THREATS STATE LOCAL
OFFICIALS.
ALEXIAN SYSTEMS ARE WERE FACING
AND THE DYNAMICS OF THE ELECTION
SYSTEMS AND IT'S EIGHT THOUSAND
PLUS JURISDICTIONS NATIONWIDE.
THIS RELATIONSHIP WAS FORMALIZED
IN JANUARY OF LAST YEAR WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
DOOR DESIGNATED ELECTIONS IS
PART OF THE NATION'S CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE A. C. LED THE EFFORT TO
CONVENE THE ALEXIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE SUBSECTOR WORKING
GROUP.
I WOULD LOVE ACRONYMS IN
WASHINGTON AS YOU KNOW.
CONSISTING OF STATE LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIALS
AND COLLABORATION WITH THE HST
AC WORK TO ESTABLISH THE
ELECTIONS GOVERNMENTS SECTOR
COORDINATING COUNCIL OR GCC.
ABOUT HIS WORK ARE MYCOLLEAGUE
AND YOU'LL KELLY WILL SPEAK
ABOUT LATER TODAY AND I'M HERE
TO TELL YOU THAT ARE BETWEEN
SECRETARY PADILLA AND NEIL KELLY
CALIFORNIA'S WELL REPRESENTED.
ON LEADING ON THIS ISSUE WITHIN
THE GCC.
THE GCC WILL INFORM HOW THE.
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
IN EAC WORK WITH STATE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE
DESIGNATION OF ELECTION SYSTEMS
IS PART OF CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND IS A
CRITICAL MILESTONE IN THE EFFORT
TO ESTABLISH A CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SUBSECTOR THAT
CAN FACILITATE TIMELY AND
ACTIONABLE INFORMATION SHARING
AND COORDINATE BETWEEN. OUR
ELECTION OFFICIALS AND FEDERAL
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
ISSUES SUCH AS CYBER AND
PHYSICAL SECURITY AS WE HEAD
INTO THE MID TERM ELECTIONS AND
BEYOND.
THIS ON IT'S OWN HOWEVER IS NOT
ENOUGH.
ELECTION ADMINISTRATION THAT
ADMINISTRATORS CRUCIAL WORK OF
STRENGTHENING THE RESILIENCE OF
ELECTION SYSTEMS
IS MADE MORE DIFFICULT BY THE
LOW FUNDING CURRENTLY ALLOCATED
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY TO UPDATE
SYSTEMS. AND DEVELOP ADDITIONAL
SECURITY EXPERTISE.
I KNOW THIS IS A PROBLEM
CALIFORNIA IS TRYING TO TACKLE
PROACTIVELY AND HEAD ON.
ELECTION OFFICIALS MUST HAVE
ACCESS TO RESOURCES MONETARY AND
OTHERWISE.
TO HELP THEM SECURE THE PROCESS
IF WE DON'T INVEST IN ELECTION
ADMINISTRATION IN INTEGRITY
ELECTION OFFICIALS WILL
CONTINUALLY HAVE TO MAKE WRIST
BASED BUDGET DECISIONS IN AN
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT OPERATING
ENVIRONMENT.
I IN ORDER TO FUNNEL MORE
RESOURCES TO THESE EFFORTS THE
AC HAS WORK TO GO BEYOND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND BEGIN
FORMING MORE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS.
IN ADDITION TO OUR WORK WITH THE
FBI DHS THE AC HAS WORKED WITH
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
STANDARDS AND TECHNOLOGY
SECRETARIES OF STATE STATE
ELECTION DIRECTORS LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIAL.
ARE THE GOVERNOR'S IS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS PRIVATE
SECTOR ENTITIES SUCH AS ALL
HARVARD'S BELFER CENTER THE
CENTER FOR INTERNET SECURITY.
THE CENTER FOR ELECTION
INNOVATION RESEARCH
THE CENTER FOR DEMOCRACY AND
TECHNOLOGY GOOGLE CLOUD FLARE
AND REALLY ANYONE ELSE THAT IS
WILLING TO PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES TO ELECTION OFFICIALS.
ELECTION OFFICIALS NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DRAW ON THE EXPERTISE OF
NEW PARTNERS AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE SECTOR
ACADEMIA. AND EVEN WHITE HAT
HACKERS
IF WE'RE ABLE TO COMBAT
SOPHISTICATED ATTACKS.
FROM NATION STATE ACTORS.
WORKING ACROSS SECTORS IN
INDUSTRIES BOLSTERS THE VAST WEB
OF PHYSICAL AN ONLINE SECURITY.
ELECTION PERSONNEL IN THE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES AND
PROCESSES AND EACH JUROR SICK
DICTION THE MAKE UP A SECURE
ELECTION PROCESS.
IF NECESSITY IS THE MOTHER OF
INVENTION WE HAVE CLEARLY SEEN
THAT THIS YEAR WITH A HOST OF
INNOVATIVE NEW ELECTION SECURITY
APPROACHES IN RESOURCE IS
GENERATED. SUCH AS TABLE TOP
EXERCISES PLAYBOOKS CUSTOMIZED
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY TRAINING
TO BEST PRACTICES AND BOOKS.
I'VE COME ABOUT.
EVEN SO MORE RESOURCES AND
SERVICES ARE NEEDED AS WE
APPROACH THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN MID
TERM ELECTION.
THERE ARE HOWEVER A NUMBER OF
THINGS
THAT I'VE BEEN ADVISING ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO DO TO STRENGTHEN
THE ABILITY OF ELECTION SYSTEMS.
TO PREVENT DETECT AND RECOVER
FROM POTENTIAL ATTACKS.
IT'S TYPICALLY HERE FIVE THINGS.
THAT.
WE'VE ENCOURAGED ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO DO RIGHT NOW MANY
OF WHICH AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM
THE SECRETARY THEY'RE ALREADY
DOING HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
ONE IS ENSURING THAT ALL ASPECTS
OF THE VOTING SYSTEM.
INCLUDING THE ELECTION
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM BALLOT
CREATION SYSTEM.
TABULATION ARE PROPERLY AIR
GAPS FROM THE INTERNET
THIS INCLUDES USING CLEAN MEDIA
TODAY LOAD BALLOTS.
TO OUR CONDUCT ELECTION NIGHT
REPORTING AND PROVIDE RESULTS ON
ELECTION NIGHT.
IF A VENDOR PERFORMS THESE TASKS
ON BEHALF OF A COUNTY ARE THEY
NEED TO HOLD THAT VENDOR
ACCOUNTABLE TO THOSE SAME
PROCEDURES
AND PROVIDE THE SAME SECURITY
PROTECTIONS THEY HAVE IN PLACE.
AUDIT SYSTEMS DATA PROCESSES
PROCEDURES
FOR ELECTION.
PREELECTION TESTING POST
ELECTION AUDITING
CHANGE A CHAIN OF CUSTODY IN
COMMAND ACCESS CONTROLS PHYSICAL
SECURITY IN ESSENCE REVIEW THEIR
ENTIRE OPERATION TO ASSESS WHAT
NEEDS TO BE UPDATED. ARE WITH AN
EYE TOWARDS CYBERSECURITY.
SS DATA RESIDENTS YOU SECURE
SYSTEMS APPROPRIATELY ARE USING
AVAILABLE RESOURCES.
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE INCIDENT
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY PLAN
IF THERE'S ONE THING THAT ALL
ACTION OFFICIALS WORKING THAT
THE STATE LOCAL LEVEL CAN DO
RIGHT NOW.
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE INSTANT
RESPONSE RECOVERY PLAN
THE REALITY FOR ALL OF US IS
THAT CYBER INCIDENTS ARE GOING
TO HAPPEN.
WE'RE GOING TO BE IMPACTED BY
CYBER INCIDENTS WHETHER IN THE
STATE A COUNTY TO A VENDOR OR
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION HOW DID YOU
DETECT HOW DID YOU RECOVER AND
WHAT YOUR PLAN.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL AVAILABLE
RESOURCES INCLUDING THOSE FROM
DHS
STATE GOVERNMENT ACADEMIA
PRIVATE SECTOR
A COUPLE I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
ARE THE PLAYBOOKS OFTEN THE
BELFER CENTER.
DEFENDING DIGITAL DEMOCRACY
PROJECT WHICH CAME OUT TWO WEEKS
AGO I WHICH PROVIDE COMMONSENSE
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO STATE
LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS.
TO OUR PROTECT THEIR SYSTEMS
RECOVER ARE AN INCIDENT RESPONSE
PLANNING AS WELL AS
COMMUNICATIONS A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATION YOU JUST HAD A WITH
THE SECRETARY WAS HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO RESPOND TO PROVIDE
CONFIDENCE IN THE PROCESS. IN
THE BELFER CENTER TOOK A LOT OF
TIME WORKING WITH ELECTION
OFFICIALS
PROVIDE COMMUNICATIONS OUR
INFORMATION THE OTHERS FROM THE
CENTER FOR INTERNET SECURITY OR
SEE I S.. ARE THEY PROVIDED
EIGHTY EIGHT TECHNICAL IT
CONTROLS BUT ELECTION OFFICIALS
CAN CHECK ARE IN USE TO ASSESS
THEIR PREPAREDNESS AYE AND CYBER
HYGIENE AYE IN PREPARATION FOR
THE MID TERM ELECTIONS.
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
BECAUSE OF ALL THE ATTENTION
THAT'S BEEN PAID ELECTION SYSTEM
SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN THEIR
NUMBER OF RESOURCES AVAILABLE
SOME OF WHICH I JUST
HIGHLIGHTED.
ALL THAT ELECTION OFFICIALS HAVE
NEVER HAD ACCESS TO BEFORE.
AS THE ELECTION COMMUNITY WORKS
TO CONFRONT THE EMERGING
THREATS.
THE AC STANDS READY TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT STATE
LOCAL OFFICIALS WERE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF DEFENSE.
WE CONTINUE TO PRODUCE BEST
PRACTICES INCLUDING CHECKLISTS
FOR VOTING VOTER REGISTRATION
DATA BASES ELECTION NIGHT
REPORTING AN INCIDENT RESPONSE
PLANNING. AND PRODUCTS THAT
PROMOTE CYBERSECURITY FOR THE
BENEFITS OF THE WHOLE COMMUNITY.
TO THIS AND THE AC HAS BEGUN
EXPANDING ON ITS VOTING SYSTEM
PROCUREMENT SUPPORT. OUR THAT IT
ALREADY PROVIDES ELECTION
OFFICIALS AS WELL AS DEVELOPING
CYBER INCIDENT RESPONSE PLANNING
TOOLS.
THE AC OFFERS HANDS ON ALEXIAN
IT MANAGEMENT TRAINING FOR STATE
LOCAL OFFICIALS.
THE TRAINING FOCUSES ON.
THE MINDSET KNOWLEDGE AND
RESOURCES NEED A BY ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO MANAGE THE
DESPERATE AND OUR COMPLEX IT
SYSTEMS THAT THEY MANAGE
I IN ADDITION TO RESPOND TO. US
SOMETHING SECRETARY PADILLA SAYS
THE AC HAS AVAILABLE GLOSSARY OF
ELECTION I T. TERMINOLOGY AS
WELL AS A GLOSSARY OF CYBER
ELECTION TERMINOLOGY TO HELP
CREATE A COMMON LEXICON. ARE FOR
THE ELECTIONS ENVIRONMENT TO USE
WHEN TALKING ABOUT CYBERSECURITY
IT MANAGEMENT ON ELECTIONS THE
GOAL OF THIS IS TO ALLOW ALL OF
US TO SPEAK THE SAME LANGUAGE
THAT WHEN WE COMMUNICATE WITH
THE PUBLIC.
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE OTHER
I'M PORTANT STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
WERE ALL SAYING THE SAME THING
CONSISTENTLY.
THE EAC ALSO CONTINUES TO TEST
AND CERTIFY VOTING MACHINES
AGAINST THE MOST UP TO DATE
STANDARDS POSSIBLE. ARE THE MOST
RECENT VERSION OF OUR VOTING
SYSTEM GUIDELINES VSG TO DORADO.
WAS RECENTLY RECOMMENDED BY THE
A SEIZE
TECHNICAL GUIDELINES DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE IN SEPTEMBER. WITHIN
ANTICIPATED RELEASE DATE IN MID
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THESE GUIDELINES
ARE WRITTEN TO ENCOURAGE
INNOVATION AND COMPETITION AND
COMPETITION AND HAVE BEEN
HEAVILY INFLUENCED.
AND.
INFORMED BY THE WORK THAT LA
COUNTY HAS DONE IN BUILDING AND
DESIGNING THEIR OWN FOR VOTING
SYSTEM.
I CAN ASSURE YOU LA COUNTY IS
LEADING THE WAY.
THE DILIGENT EFFORT OF THOSE
INVOLVED IN A MINISTRY THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTION MAINTAIN
THE INTEGRITY OF THAT ELECTION.
BUT WE CAN AND SHOULD ALWAYS
SEEK SEEK TO DO MORE.
VOTERS WANT AND EXPECT A
COORDINATED WHOLE OF NATION
RESPONSE
TO THESE THREATS AGAINST OUR
DEMOCRACY SO THAT THEY CAN HEAD
TO THE POLLS OR. BALLOT DROPBOX
WITH CONFIDENCE.
AND TO THOSE VOTERS I HAVE ONE
MESSAGE.
GET INVOLVED
OFFICIALS RUN ELECTIONS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO ALL VOTERS
STAYING GAUGE
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS.
BECOME A POLL WORKER
OBSERVE PREELECTION TESTING
WATCH POST ELECTION AUDITING
CHECK YOUR VOTER REGISTRATION
INFORMATION TO MAKE SURE IT'S UP
TO DATE AND CORRECT. ASK
QUESTIONS AND ENGAGE YOUR LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIALS
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY VOTE.
THEY WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU.
WE NEED LESS FINGERPOINTING AND
MORE CANDID AND OPEN
CONVERSATIONS AMONG ELECTION
MINISTRATIONS FEDERAL AGENCIES
PRIVATE INDUSTRY CYBER NATIONAL
SECURITY EXPERTS AND LEGISLATORS
WE NEED A PLAN TO INVEST IN
ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURE ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
THESE THREATS AREN'T GOING AWAY
AND REGULAR FUNDING RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS
ARE NEEDED TO HELP PROTECT THE
PROCESS.
ELECTIONS ARE MORE SECURE WHEN
WE FULLY COORDINATE EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS EXISTING THREATS
SURE CUTTING EDGE STRATEGIES
THAT STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THEM.
IMPROVE INFORMATION SHARING AND
HELP JURISDICTIONS BEST PROTECT
SYSTEMS WHEN BUDGETS ARE TIGHT.
THIS TYPE OF COORDINATED
RESPONSE FROM ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
WILL ENSURE THE CONTINUED
ACCESSIBILITY ACCURACY AND
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTION
PROCESS.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME TODAY AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER THAT.
.
BEFORE I JUMP IN THEM CIRCULATE
TO SEE IF ANY OF THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
QUESTIONS.
A CHAIR. OUT SORRY SENATOR ALAN.
RIGHT FOR SMOG JUST WANTED THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT.
AREA OF NATIONAL DEFENSE AND
NATIONAL SECURITY.
I I JUST WANTED TO TO TO ASK YOU
IF THERE'S ANY A PARTICULAR BEST
PRACTICE YOU SEEN OUT THERE IN
YOUR WORK WITH THE STATE'S.
I'M ANY ANY PARTICULAR STATE
STORY THAT YOU CAN HIGHLIGHT TO
US THAT WE CAN.
THAT WE OUGHT TO LEARN FROM AND
BE ABLE TO ADOPT OR OR OR BY THE
WAY IF THERE'S A BAD STORY.
NO BAD STORIES NOT OKAY NOW NOW
COP.
SURE THERE'S AYE AYE AND
FRANKLY HUNDREDS OF STORIES THAT
ARE HIGHLIGHT THE KIND OF
INNOVATIVE NATURE OF ELECTION
OFFICIALS ARE WHO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS UNLIMITED BUDGETS TO
HELP SECURE IN AND IMPROVE THE
PROCESS. A COUPLE A HIGHLIGHT.
ONE IS US SVERAL STATES HAVE.
ENGAGE THE NATIONAL GUARD AYE
IN A VARIETY OF WAYS TO HELP
THEM SECURE THE PROCESS AND IT'S
RESULTED IN A KIND OF AN
INNOVATIVE.
APPROACH TO USING RESOURCES
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY AVAILABLE A
WEST VIRGINIA HAS BROUGHT IN A
NATIONAL GUARD MEMBER AS A
MEMBER OF THEIR ELECTIONS TEAM
TO SIT IN THE STATE FUSION
CENTER. I'D MONITOR THAT THE
CYBERSECURITY AROUND ELECTIONS
PROCESS THAT'S AN INTERESTING I
INNOVATIVE APPROACH ARE ANOTHER
ONE IN.
IS THE STATE OF COLORADO.
IT IMPLEMENTED THE FIRST
STATEWIDE WRIST LIMITING AUDITS.
.
BUT THE FIRST STATEWIDE WRIST
LIMITING AUDITS A WRESTLING
AUDITS ARE.
NEW.
EFFICIENT PERCHED AUDITING I
THINK THERE'S PROBABLY MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS TO APPROACH
AUDITING A. IS BUT A COLORADO ON
THAT.
LARGE SCALE THE STATEWIDE AUDIT.
WAS ABLE TO CONDUCT REALLY
EFFICIENT AUDITS THE PROVIDED A
GREAT DEAL OF TRANSPARENCY IN
CONFIDENCE AND SO I WAS OUT
THERE TO WITNESS IT AND IT WAS.
A REALLY.
ONE COOL.
TO WATCH BUT REALLY INFORMATIVE.
NOW THE KEY FOR COLORADO IS ARE
THERE ENTIRELY SENSUALLY
COUNTED.
STATEWIDE AND SO THAT ALLOWS
FOR FLEXIBILITY ON HOW THEY
CONDUCT AUDITS AND SO ONE ONE
SOLUTION ELECTIONS DOESN'T SERVE
ALL EIGHT THOUSAND JURISDICTIONS
ARE BUT THERE'S A LOT TO BE
LEARNED FROM WHAT THEY GET OUT
THERE IN COLORADO FOR SURE.
COLORADO SEEMS TO BE A WE WE'VE
BEEN WE'VE BEEN LEARNING A LOT
FROM THEM WE'VE YOU KNOW EVEN
OUR NEW.
ELECTION SYSTEM WITH ADDRESS THE
VOTE CENTERS WHERE WHERE WE'RE
USING A LOT OF THEIR MODEL YEAH
I'VE MOVING FORWARD BUT.
I'M WILL GOOD I'M I'M GLAD THAT
I I ASSUME YOU'RE SHARING THIS
INFORMATION WITH OUR SECTOR
STATES OFFICE WOULD YOU KNOW
YOUR YOUR TIMEFRAME IN TERMS OF
YOUR YOU'RE STILL AT THE
COMMISSION AND TELL THERE'S A
REPLACEMENT THAT SELECTED IS
THAT. YEAH THERE'S AYE AYE
SENATE CONFIRMATION PROCESS IN.
AND I'M I'M THERE DOING THE
WORK UNTIL.
EITHER THAT HAPPENS OR OR.
NEW I OPENER FEW DRUGS ARE
LEARNING ABOUT ME. A FOOD TRUCK
YEAH WELL MAYBE YOU BOTH YEAH I.
NO.
BUT THERE HAS BEEN AN APPOINTEE.
SUBMITTED THOUGHT SO MUCH MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE.
THAT THE SPEAKER.
HAS.
IT'S IN THE PROCESS WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE IT GOES THROUGHOUT
THE VETTING PROCESS AND SO IT
COULD BE. AT THE WHITE HOUSE
COULD USE ANOTHER NAME IT'S IT'S
TOTALLY UP TO THEM ON HOW THAT
WORKS AND CAN YOU I'M CAN YOU
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TO THE ISSUES
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP IN THE LAST
PANEL WITH REGARDS TO.
THE NEWS MEDIA AND WORKING WITH
OUR FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA TO HELP
BETTER UNDERSTAND AND EXPLAIN
AND AND JUST.
JUST BE MORE ACCURATE IN IN
ADDRESSING THE.
THE VARIOUS.
TERMS IN THE VARIOUS THE RATS.
IT REALLY DOES APPEAR AS THOUGH
THERE'S THERE'S JUST SO MUCH.
CONFUSION OUT THERE AND I DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH OF IT IS.
IN OF WILLFUL IGNORANCE OR.
.
YOU KNOW.
CLICK BAIT. EVEN PRACTICED BY
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA BECAUSE
THEY NEED THE CLICKS TO.
I A KID YOU CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE
EXTENT TO WHICH WERE WERE WERE
WORKING ON ON INFORMING
JOURNALISTS.
ABOUT THESE.
I TERMS AND AND IT JUST
IMPROVING PEOPLE CYBER
VOCABULARY SURE SO THAT SO I
THINK IT'S FANTASTIC QUESTION IN
AND.
THE ACCURACY AND AND.
PURSE
PRECISION OF OUR OWN.
TERMINOLOGY WILL HELP DRIVE THE
WAY THAT THAT FOLKS PUBLICLY
TALK ABOUT WHETHER IT'S THE
MEDIA VOTERS OR OTHERS AND SO I
A REALLY SIMPLE EXAMPLE THAT
THAT ALL OF YOU I'M SURE OF
EXPERIENCE. IS THE COMPLETION
BETWEEN VOTING SYSTEM AND VOTER
REGISTRATION SYSTEM ELECTION
SYSTEM.
THE VOTING SYSTEM IS NOT THE
VOTER REGISTRATION SYSTEM
THEY'RE NOT ONE IN THE SAME AYE
MANY CASES THEY'RE NOT IN ANY
WAY CONNECTED AT ALL.
BUT WHEN THE HEADLINE SCREAMS
VOTING SYSTEM HACKED IT IMPLIES
THAT THE TABULATION OR OR.
VOTE TOTALS WERE WERE HACKED
WHEN IN FACT WHAT WE SAW IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WAS THE TARGET OF
VOTER REGISTRATIONS.
AND SO THAT VERY IMPORTANT ODD
DISTINCTION EYES ONE THAT VOTERS
AYE IN AND SOMETIMES THE MEDIA
DON'T OFTEN MAKE THAT WE NEED TO
REINFORCE AS A COMMUNITY. ARE
THAT THE THERE ARE A LOT OF THAT
ELECTION NIGHT REPORTING SYSTEM
IS NOT THE SAME AS THE VOTING
SYSTEM THESE ARE THESE ARE ALL
SEPARATE.
SOMETIMES DEPENDENT SOMETIMES
NOT DEPENDENT SYSTEMS AND THE
WAY WE TALK ABOUT THESE NEEDS TO
BE DONE WITH PRECISION ASA THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE RIGHT SYSTEMS AND THE RIGHT
TYPE OF ACTIVITY ARE THAT WAS OR
WASN'T GOING ON ALL THE OTHER
PART OF THAT IS TRANSPARENCY THE
BEST WAY. I THINK ABOUT THAT I
KNOW HERE IN CALIFORNIA YOU ALL
I HAVE.
O. LAWS THAT SUPPORT.
VOTER ENGAGEMENT AND
OBSERVATION OF THE PROCESS
THAT'S CRITICAL ARE BECAUSE THE
BEST WAY.
TO EXPOSE THE PUBLIC IN EDUCATE
IS TO ALLOW THE MAN TO
PARTICIPATE RIGHT. ARE AND SO
EMBRACING THAT TRANSPARENCY
INVITING THE
AN ISSUE THEY TRUST THE LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIAL TO EXPLAIN TO
THEM WHAT'S GOING ON BECAUSE
THEY'VE ALREADY HAD THAT
RELATIONSHIP AND DIALOGUE WITH
THEM SO OPENING THE PROCESS OUT.
AYE ENGAGING IN THAT WAY I ONE
OF THE INTERESTING THINGS WE SAW
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN ON A NATIONAL
LEVEL IS REALLY THE LOCAL
REPORTING.
.
WAS VERY STRONG.
THEY WOULD GO OUT TO THE LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIAL OFFICES AND
VISIT THE WAREHOUSES
THE THE SYSTEMS ARE AND WHAT NOT
AND SO IN MANY CASES THE LOCAL
REPORTING WHICH MUCH STRONGER.
THAT ANDTHEN OF SOME OF THE
NATIONAL REPORTING BECAUSE THEY
HAD A RELATIONSHIP WITH THOSE
LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS ARE TO
SEE THE PROCESS AND EXPERIENCE
AND SO THE MORE WE CAN ENCOURAGE
THAT OPEN THE PROCESS UP. I
THINK THE BETTER OFF WE ALL ARE
YEAH I I CAN AGREE MORE I I DO I
DO THINK YOU YOU. USE THE WORD
BORING I MEAN THAT THAT'S PART
OF THE PROBLEM YOU KNOW. WHAT
ABOUT YOU KNOW AND I I HAVE GONE
TO LOOK AT?
?
YOU KNOW I I'VE GONE DE AND
ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY HERE.
TWO TO GO AND SPEND SOME TIME
YET AS POLITICIANS WERE ON
ELECTION NIGHT WHERE AND WE'RE
SO FOCUSED ON THAT.
POLITICAL SITE WE'RE GOING TO
THE POLITICAL PARTIES WHERE
WHERE WHERE. WE'RE DOING THAT
THE LAST DITCH GET OUT THE VOTE
EFFORTS BUT IF YOU'RE EVER NOT
ON THE BALLOT.
.
ON A SPECIAL ELECTION THERE
WHATEVER ELSE GO SPEND SOME TIME
TO ENSURE RECORDER'S OFFICE AND
YOU SEE THAT PROCESS.
I PLAY OUT IT IS A LITTLE BIT
IT'S INTERESTING AS A AS AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL IS ACTUALLY
VERY INTERESTING. BUT I'M BUT
GIVEN ARE ARE TWENTY SECOND
ATTENTION SPAN SPECIAL. ASIDE.
I THINK SOMETIMES THAT THAT AND.
YOU KNOW THE THE IF IT'S NOT
EXCITING ENOUGH FOR FOR IT FOR
PEOPLE TO REALLY GET INTO. AND.
AND I GUESS THAT'S WHAT
CONSTANTLY CONCERNS ME WITH
REGARDS TO AND TO THE PUBLIC AND
AND THE MEDIA ATTENTION AND.
I BUT I JUST CAN'T EMPHASIZE
ENOUGH HOW IMPORTANT IS FOR.
FOR FOLKS MAYBE THIS COULD BE
YOUR NEXT BIG PROJECT SOME YOU
TEAM UP WITH A MEDIA PERSON.
AND.
AND JUST JUST REALLY FOCUS TIME
THAT I TRY TO TELL YOU WHAT TO
DO YEAH YACHTS AYE I'M OPEN TO
SUGGESTION SO YEAH YEAH YEAH YOU
CAN DO IT OUT OF THE FOOD DRUG.
I YEAH BUT I LIKE WHERE THIS IS
HEADED BUT YOU CAN YOU TRAVEL
AROUND THE COUNTRY SERVE TACOS
AND AND. AND ALSO.
IMMEDIATE TRAINING BUT THE REAL
YOU KNOW BUT BUT BUT REALLY I'M.
ARE YOU KNOW THAT.
SPEND SOMETIME WORKING ON THIS
AGAIN BECAUSE IT IT'S.
IT'S THAT IT'S ACTUALLY NOT THAT
COMPLICATED ONCE YOU EXPLAIN THE
DIFFERENCE I'M TERM YOU THE
DIFFERENT TERMS A DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS BUT THE AVERAGE PERSON'S
HAS NO IDEA AND AND FORTUNATELY.
THE AVERAGE JOURNALIST HAS NO
IDEA I WOULD POSIT THAT THE
AVERAGE LEGISLATOR HAS NO IDEA.
I AND SO I.
YOU REALLY FOR SPENDING
SOMETIME.
FOCUSED ON I MEDIA LITERACY IN
THIS AREA I THINK WOULD BE VERY
VALUABLE FOR JOKES IN THE
ELECTIONS COMMUNITY AYE AYE I
COMPLETELY AGREE AND I I WILL.
HUMBLY.
SUBMIT TO YOU ALL THAT ARE NOT
NOT THIS ROOM OBVIOUSLY BUT
THOSE WHO HAVE WON AN ELECTION
JUST BECAUSE YOU'VE WON AN
ELECTION DOESN'T MEAN YOU KNOW
HOW ELECTIONS RUN RIGHT.
NOT THIS ROOM THOUGH OF COURSE.
AND SO TAKE THE TIME TO TO DO
THAT I CAN TELL YOU THAT NEIL
KELLY IN ORANGE COUNTY WHO
YOU'LL HEAR FROM LATER HAS A HAS
A VIDEO.
DOCUMENTARY BEHIND THE SCENES
LOOK AT HOW THEY AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WILL STRIKE YOU WITH
EVERY ELECTIONS OFFICE I PROMISE
YOU IS THEY LITERALLY ASK
THEMSELVES WHAT CAN GO WRONG
PLAN FOR THAT AND WHAT ELSE
COULD GO WRONG AND SO THE NUMBER
OF THEM OUT OF CONTINGENCY.
PLANNING AYE IS ON BELIEVABLE.
THE QUESTIONS
YEAH JUST JUST QUICKLY AND BLAH.
REALLY ONCE AGAIN EVERYTHING
THAT A CENTER ALLEN SAID AND AND
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR VIEW THAT
YOU KNOW THAT SUNLIGHT IS THE
BEST DISINFECTANT FOR FOR SOME
OF THESE ISSUES AND CAN AGREE
MORE.
AND WAS HEARTENED BY YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF.
RESOURCES MATERIALS FOR
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS BECAUSE. OF
YOU SAID THERE ARE OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND ELECTIONS JURISDICTIONS
NATIONWIDE THAT'S MASSIVE.
AND A LOT OF THEM DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES OF AN ORANGE
COUNTY YEAR SACRAMENTO.
AND SO MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THE BEST PRACTICES AND
KIND OF SHOW THEM SOME OF THOSE
PITFALLS THAT MIGHT OCCUR.
AND HOW TO HOW TO PREPARE FOR
THEM IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
.
DOWN THE FEDERAL LEVEL SEVERAL
BILLS HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED IN
CONGRESS ON ELECTION SECURITY
ISSUES.
AND LAST WEEK IT WAS REPORTED
THAT THE HOMELAND SECURITY
REAUTHORIZATION BILL MIGHT BE
AMENDED TO INCLUDE LANGUAGE
STRENGTHENING THE DEPARTMENTS
ELECTION CYBERSECURITY MANDATE.
DO YOU BELIEVE ANY SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES ARE ARE LIKELY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND YOU ALSO
MENTIONED EARLIER THE JUST A
LACK OF FUNDING AND WHAT A BIG
PROBLEM THAT IS. YOU THINK
THERE'S ANY POSSIBILITY THAT
THERE MIGHT BE FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR ELECTION SECURITY AT OR AND
OR VOTING SYSTEMS REPLACEMENT
SURE SO IT'S IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION IN.
I WILL I WILL NOT.
.
TRY TO GUESS WHAT CONGRESS MAYOR
MAY NOT DO.
BUT I EVEN WITH THE BILL THAT.
OR BILLS THAT ARE OUT THERE
MUCH OF THAT WORK THAT'S
CONTAINED IN THAT BILL IS
ALREADY BEING DONE AS A PART OF
A GOVERNMENT COORDINATING
COUNCIL WORK OR OTHER.
DHS EAC EFFORTS SO FOR EXAMPLE
THE INFORMATION SHARING
PROTOCOLS THAT ARE.
WITHIN THAT THE SECURE
ELECTIONS ACTS ON THE SENATE
SIDE ODD THAT IT HAS BEEN A
FOCUS THE PRIORITY OF THAT THE
GOVERNMENT COORDINATING COUNCIL
TO ENSURE THAT. A TIMELY AND
ACTIONABLE AYE INFORMATION I
GETS DOWN ALL THE WAY TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
AS IT NEEDS TO.
AND BECOMES AVAILABLE AND SO
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S BEING
DONE AS A PART OF THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE DESIGNATION WORK
OUR REGARDLESS OF SORT OF HOW
CONGRESS CHOOSES TO MOVE FORWARD
ATTRACT. EYES FAR AS RESOURCES.
THAT THE GOOD NEWS THAT I'VE
SEEN I KNOW CALIFORNIA'S IN THE
MIST MIDST OF THIS DISCUSSION IS
STATES HAVE COME UP WITH SOME
REALLY CREATIVE WAYS TO DO IT TO
TACKLE THIS RESOURCE CHALLENGE.
AND FUNDING CHALLENGE MY HOME
STATE OF OHIO EYES WORKING
THROUGH BILL NOW OUGHT TO SPLIT
THE COST BETWEEN THE COUNTIES IN
THE STATE IN A PRETTY INNOVATIVE
WAY AND THEN TAKE ADVANTAGE. OF
THE STATE'S PURCHASING POWER SO
THAT THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
NEGOTIATE CONTRACTS TO GET THE
BEST VALUE ON BEHALF THE
COUNTIES WHAT THE COUNTY STOP
THE FLEXIBILITY AND SO. I WOULD
I TELL YOU AS AN OVERALL MESSAGE
OF THAT WON'T SURPRISE YOU IS
NOT OF THE STATE'S THAT I'VE
INTERACTED WITH ARE WAITING TO
FIND OUT WHAT MAY OR MAY NOT
HAPPEN IN CONGRESS THEIR
PROACTIVELY TAKING THIS ON. OUR
AND IF SOMETHING GOES ON THOUGH
RESPONDED THAT.
I DID PRETTY THAT NOTHING THAT'S
THE EXACTLY THE MINDSET THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO HAVE UP HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR FOR MAKING
THAT'S ABOUT A LOT I'M THRILLED
TO BE HERE I APPRECIATE THAT
THEY INVITE VERY MUCH YEAH.
JUST A COUPLE CLOSING QUESTIONS
UNLESS THERE'S ANY OTHERS
OKAY SO.
.
VERY SIMPLE QUESTION.
DO YOU FEEL CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTION SYSTEM IS SECURE.
I'D I THINK CALIFORNIA'S TAKING
ALL THE PROACTIVE STEPS ON YOU
HEARD THE SECRETARY LETS THROUGH
ALL OF THE WORK THAT HE IN HIS
OFFICE OF DONNA KNOWING MANY OF
THE REGISTRARS HERE.
THEY'RE TAKING ALL THE STEPS
THEY CAN OUGHT TO SECURE THE
PROCESS BUT I'D I'D ENCOURAGE IN
AND THEY KNOW THIS BETTER THAN I
DO. OTHER THAT THERE'S NO SUCH
THING AS SECURE RIGHT IT'S AN ON
GOING.
EFFORT THAT THAT CONSTANTLY IS
IN NEED OF NEW INFORMATION NEW
RESOURCES AND SO ARE ALL OF US
ARE WORKING ON A DAILY BASIS TO
RESPOND OF INFORMATION WE GET. I
PUT IN PLACE THE BEST PRACTICES
WE CAN'T EITHER PROTECT THE
SYSTEMS OR RESPOND AND RECOVER
LET ME ASK YOU THIS IN THIS WAY
THEN.
ARE WE HEARING TO THE BEST
PRACTICE FIVE BEST PRACTICES
THAT YOU OUTLINED IN YOUR
TESTIMONY YOU AS FAR AS I'M
AWARE YES I MEAN I'VE BEEN
OBVIOUSLY GOOD GONE THROUGH BUT.
YOU ASKED A QUESTION EARLIER TO
TO.
THE SECRETARY ABOUT WHAT STEPS
CAN WE HELP. TAKE TO HELP LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIALS KIND OF
EVALUATE THEIR.
CYBER POSTURE RIGHT ARE AND I
THINK SOMETHING LIKE THAT THE
CENTER FOR INTERNET SECURITIES.
EIGHTY EIGHT.
CONTROLS OR ARE A GOOD STEP TO
WEAR A LITTLE LOCAL ELECTION
OFFICIALS CAN SELF ASSESS CAN
TAKE THAT INFORMATION TAKE IT
OVER THEIR IT WHETHER IT'S
COUNTY CONTRACTED HOWEVER AND
SAY WHERE ARE WE ON THIS WHERE
DO WE NEED MORE RESOURCES ABOUT
IMPROVE. SO THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
OBJECTIVE WAY OUGHT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT SOME OF THAT
EXCELLENT.
.
AND I WAS GONNA ASK YOU JUST TO
BRIEFLY COMMENT ON SORT OF.
BEYOND THAT THAT BILL FOR POOR
YOU REFERRED TO FROM HARVARD.
.
THAT SORT OF WE WE WERE TEASING
US WHEN OUR LAST PANEL TO THE
NOTION OF HAVING. PROACTIVE
CREDIBLE RESPONDERS AND BUILDING
CAPACITY IN THAT SORT OF CUT ON
THE COMMUNICATIONS SIDE ON THE
PUP FROM THE SURPLUS COMMUNICATE
DO YOU DO. IS THAT WHAT'S
UNDERNEATH THE BELL FOR REPORT
AND AND OTHER SUGGESTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE FOR US IN TERMS OF.
ARMENIANS COUNTY REGISTRARS OR
SECRETARY STATE OR OTHER ACTORS
TO SORT OF.
SORT OF B. KNOW WHAT BE LOUDER
THAN.
THE MISINFORMATION YES SO THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT'S IN PART OF WHAT
THE BELFER CENTER DID IN THE
DEAD THREE PLAYBOOKS AND ONE OF
THEM WAS COMMUNICATIONS PLAYBOOK
THAT'S. THAT'S
GEARED EXACTLY TO THAT UP
PROACTIVE MESSAGING PROACTIVE
CONVERSATIONS TO HAVE WHEN
YOU'RE NOT IN THE ELECTION CYCLE
THEM ONCE THEY HAVE WHEN YOU'RE
IN IT AND THAT IF THERE IS AN
INCIDENT HOW TO TALK ABOUT THE
INCIDENT. ARE AND WHAT NOT.
BUT THE THE OTHER PART IN THIS
AND IT'S A CHALLENGE IS A THIRD
PARTY VALIDATORS RIGHT HAVING
PEOPLE THAT CAN TALK ABOUT THE
ELECTIONS PROCESS INVALIDATE THE
STEPS. THAT FOLKS ARE TAKING IS
TOUGH BECAUSE THE REALITY IS ARE
THAT FOR MANY GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS THIS ISN'T UNIQUE TO
ELECTIONS ARE.
PEOPLE JUST ASSUME THAT THE
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS GO SAY NO
EVERYTHING'S OKAY RIGHT AND SO
WHAT YOU NEED TO SOME THIRD
PARTY VALIDATION ON ELECTION
OFFICIALS HAVE DONE A GOOD JOB
AND WILL CONTINUE I THINK TO DO
A GOOD JOB. OF BRINGING THE
PUBLIC IN EXPERTS AND OTHERS
THAT CAN TAKE A LOOK INVALIDATE
THE WORK THEY'RE DOING BECAUSE
THIS OPTION IS EITHER GOING TO
SAY THAT RIGHT AND SO HOW CAN WE
TAKE YOU GETTING THIRD PARTY
CERTIFICATIONS THINGS LIKE THAT
TO SHOW. WERE TAKING THOSE STEPS
WHETHER IT'S AYE SO A WHATEVER
THE CASE MAY BE.
AND AND DO YOU FEEL I MEAN IN
TERMS OF YOU LOOK AT THE
NATIONAL LANDSCAPE WHERE WHERE
WHERE DO YOU SEE S. FALLING IN
THERE'S.
OUR OUR OUR MODE OUR MOST STATE
SORT OF ADHERING TO THE.
VOLUNTARY VOTING SYSTEM
GUIDELINES THAT YOU'VE
ESTABLISHED IN THE A CC I MEAN
ARE WHAT WHERE DO WE SORT OF
FALL IN THE PACK FOR.
THE NATIONAL SURE SO.
ONE IS A FORTY SEVEN OUT OF
FIFTY STATES YOU SOME PART OF
OUR PROGRAM TO EVALUATE THEIR
VOTING SYSTEMS THAT COULD MEAN
FOR INSTANCE MY HOME STATE. OF
FULL CERTIFICATION SYSTEMS WITH
THIS WITH THE STICKER PAC
STICKER ON THERE IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA THEY CERTIFY THEIR OWN
SYSTEMS MUCH LIKE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THEY USE OUR
STANDARDS AS AS. I.
WHAT A A CORE AT THE CORE OF HOW
THEY TEST AND EVALUATE THE
SYSTEMS ARE OTHER STATES WILL
USE OUR TEST LABS WOULD HAVE
THEIR OWN?
STANDARDS BY WHICH THEY
EVALUATE IT BECAUSE WE ARE
CREDIT THE VOTING SYSTEM TEST
LABORATORIES I CALIFORNIA HAS
FOR YEARS NOW BEEN VERY
PROACTIVE IN DILIGENT IN THEIR
ASSESSMENT OF VOTING SYSTEMS I
IN FACT.
WE AT THE AC STOLE ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA SECRETARY STATE
EMPLOYEES OUGHT TO COME HELP US
A MINISTER AND YEAH I KNOW IT'S
A BRUTAL ACTUALLY.
UP.
OKAY.
BOB BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THE WORK
THAT CALIFORNIA WAS DOING SO
YEAH ABSOLUTELY CALIFORNIA I HAS
FOR YEARS NOW BEEN BEEN
EVALUATING AND AND.
INNOVATING AROUND HOW THEY TEST
SYSTEMS
CREATE ONE LAST QUESTION BECAUSE
I KNOWWE GOT TO KEEP MOVING BUT
ABOUT THE DESIGNATION OF
ELECTION SYSTEM IS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN JANUARY DHS.
IDEA WHAT IMPACT YOU THINK IT'S
GOING TO HAVE THE DESIGNATION
MEAN WE USE THIS CRITICAL
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
DESIGNATION FOR THE POWER GRID
OR OTHERS ARE SENSITIVE SYSTEMS
THAT WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON
NATIONAL SECURITY BUT. TO CENTER
AROUND POINT EARLY HE MENTIONED
THIS IS A MATTER OF NATIONAL
DEFENSE NOW WE'VE ACTUALLY
IDENTIFIED ELECTION SYSTEMS
THROUGH DHS AS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SO. IF YOU'RE
GONNA BE.
IT IN IT DO YOU SEE ANY
POTENTIAL IMPACT THEIR IN ANY
MEANINGFUL WAY YEAH I DO AT VERY
MUCH ON I KNOW.
NEIL KELLY'S CAN SPEAK TO THIS
AS WELL BUT.
THAT THE TWO MAJOR AREAS OF
IMPACT ARE ONE. THAT INFORMATION
SHARING SO THIS IS GOING TO
PROVIDE.
INEFFICIENT AVENUE TOWARDS.
TIMELY AND ACTIONABLE
INTELLIGENCE INFORMATION BEING
SHARED WITH ELECTION OFFICIALS
THAT OTHERWISE WASN'T AVAILABLE
TO THEM PREVIOUSLY.
THAT THAT THAT IS THE MAIN
FOCUS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING WITHIN
THE CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
SECTOR AND I THINK IT'S
ABSOLUTELY VITAL ARE THAT
ELECTION OFFICIALS HAVE THAT
INFORMATION FOR WHAT KIND OF
INFORMATION IS SHORT SO I ATE A
COULD BE EVERYTHING FROM JUST
GENERAL CYBER THREAT INFORMATION
SO. THAT WITHIN THE EIGHTEEN
AREAS A CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
DO YOU MAY SEE ACTIVITY IN THE
FINANCIAL SECTOR OR ELECTRICAL
SECTOR THAT CAN HELP INFORM THE
ELECTION SECTOR OR COULD BE. ARE
MUCH LIKE WHAT WE SAW IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN.
PACIFIC INDICATORS ARE THAT WERE
PROVIDED BY THE FBI DHS DOWN THE
LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS ABOUT
THREATS FACING THEIR SYSTEMS
THAT THEY ELECTION OFFICIALS
COULD GO BACK AND LOOK. AT THEIR
SYSTEMS AND SAY HAVE WE SEEN ANY
OF THESE IF SO WHAT HAPPENED ALL
WHAT WENT ON IN SO THAT'S THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND WILL
RECEIVE THAT INFORMATION I MEAN.
EXPLAIN REALLY BRIEF THE FLOW SO
IT SURE STATE WHERE WHATEVER ANY
DETECTS THE THREAT HOW HOW WOULD
THEN MAKE ITS WAY. BACK TO
CALIFORNIA YET SO SO THE IDEA
WOULD BE EACH STATE'S GONNA HAVE
TO KIND OF FIGURE OUT THEIR BEST
MODE OF COMMUNICATION AS FAR AS
GETTING IT ALL THE WAY OUT TO
THE YOU KNOW THE THE LOCAL. OF
THE SMALLEST OF LOCALS RIGHT
BECAUSE EACH STATE IS DIFFERENT
IN HOW THEY COMMUNICATE ACROSS
THE COUNTY SOME STATES HAVE MORE
CENTRALIZED CONTROL SOME.
STATES DON'T BUT THE IDEAS THAT
THERE ARE STATE LOCAL POINTS OF
CONTACT IN EVERY OUR ELECTION.
JURISDICTION IN EVERY STATE ARE
THAT AS INFORMATION BECOMES
AVAILABLE THERE SOMETHING CALLED
THE MULTI STATE INFORMATION
SHARING AND ANALYSIS CENTER MSI
SACK ROLLS OFF THE RIGHT SUPER
ANOTHER ACRONYM WERE HERE FOR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE'RE
HERE TO HELP RIGHT.
AND THE MSI SACK IS DESIGNED
AND BUILT TO SHARE THIS TYPE OF
INFORMATION WITH WITH STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TRIBAL TECH
AND TRIBAL AND TERRITORIAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AND SO
UTILIZING THE RESOURCES AT THE
IMAX ISAC AS WELL AS. DHS IS
CAPABILITIES PUSH IT ALL THE WAY
OUT SIR STEP NUMBER ONE I WAS
GETTING ALL THE LOCALS IN IN
WHATEVER WAY THE STATE WANTS TO
GAUGE IT SIGNED UP FOR THEM AS I
SAT TO RECEIVE.
PA THE ELECTIONS INFORMATION.
AND THERE'VE BEEN SOME STATES
LIKE A COLORADO.
WHICH OF TOLD LOCAL ELECTION
OFFICIALS ONE YOU MUST SIGN UP
FOR THEM AS I SECRETARY WHEN YOU
YOU HAVE TO DO IT AYE INTO IF
YOU HAVE A CYBER INCIDENT YOU
MUST REPORT IT TO THE STATES SO
EACH STATE KIND OF FIGURING OUT
HOW THEY WANT TO HANDLE THAT.
AND WHAT LEVERAGE THEY HAVE ON
THE LOCALS TO DISSEMINATE.
CENTER HERTZBERG.
YOU ALLUDED TO THE DAYS PAPA
GONE BY OF HANGING CHADS FOR
SOME OF US REMEMBER THOSE
VIVIDLY.
IN FROM FLORIDA AND WE RESPOND
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN TWO
THOUSAND WITH A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR BOND ISSUE TO
UPDATE THE SYSTEM ARE JUST
CURIOUS FROM OUR NATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE. DO YOU HAVE ANY
INSIGHTS AND WITH RESPECT TO
WHAT WE DID IN AND AND WHETHER
IT WAS SUCCESSFUL IN ANY
RESPECT.
BUT CHAU I'D I HAVE NO AYE I
ASSUME IT WAS SUCCESSFUL AS
YOU'RE STILL A SUCCESSFULLY
RUNNING ELECTIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO I THAT IT TIME
FIFTY THREE PERCENT OF OUR
SYSTEMS.
IN CALIFORNIA HAD.
WELL WHAT WERE FLORIDA HAD WHICH
RESULT IN THE HANGING CHAD OR
JUST CURIOUS IF YOU HAD ANY
RESEARCH IN THAT REGARD FROM A
NATIONAL PERSPECTIVE. IT SO BUT
AS FAR AS NOT. RESEARCH AS FAR
AS THE WHITE SUCCESS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF BOB NOT GOOD
HABA YOU HAD ALL THIS OTHER
STUFF IS AN HISTORICAL CONTEXT
WHICH HAD A BUDGET CHANGE FOR
SHORT OF HONORED THIRTY SOME
MILLION DOLLARS OF SECTOR STATES
OFFICE.
TRY TO UPDATE GET FURTHER WE
ALSO HAVE LOCAL POINTS OF VIEW I
JUST TRYING TO GET YOUR NATIONAL
POINT OF VIEW IF YOU SAW ANY OF
THAT.
I SAW THE IMPACTS AS WELL AS WE
FEEL THE ELECTION COMMUNITY
EARLIER BEFORE WE SAW THE CYBER
PROBLEM WE HAD ANOTHER BIG
MANAGEMENT PROBLEM. BUT I'M JUST
CURIOUS TO SEE IF HE HAD THE
POINT OF VIEW IN THAT YET SO I
THINK WELL ONE.
IN ONE A PARTICULAR AREA IT WAS
PARTICULARLY.
IMPACTFUL THAT IS PROVIDING
FULL ACCESSIBILITY TO TO VOTERS
WITH DISABILITIES IN
AND NEEDS TO I MEAN THAT WAS AT
THE CORE OF WHAT HAVA. I DID IN
WELL IN PART OF THE REASON WHY I
THAT CHANGE WAS SUCCESSFUL BUT
THERE WERE THERE WERE MUCH UP.
MANY OTHER SUBTLE I
IMPROVEMENTS THAT I THINK OVER
TIME HAVE BEEN CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ELECTIONS AND ONE THAT
I HIGHLIGHT.
THAT CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY IT'S
BEEN VARIABLE THEN IS UP ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS OF FROM FLORIDA TWO
THOUSAND THAT NOW THE NATION.
HAS WORKED TO ADDRESS OVER TIME
IS.
THE USABILITY OF THE BALLOTS IN
THE SYSTEM SO THAT VOTERS ARE
ABLE TO UNDERSTANDING CAST THEIR
VOTE ALLY AS THEY INTENDED AND
THERE'S BEEN A TON OF WORK. DONE
TO IMPROVE NOT JUST THE SYSTEMS
BUT THE ACTUAL BALLOT DESIGN AND
LAYOUT.
SO THAT VOTERS UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY'RE VOTING ON.
UNDERSTAND.
HOW HOW TO CAST THEIR BALLOT IN
THAT IT'S?
IT COUNTED APPROPRIATELY GIVE
ANY MEASURABLE OUTCOMES THERE
THAT YOU THINK IS WIDE ELECTION
THE COMMITTEES OF ONE OF THE
COMMITTEES I REPRESENT WHERE.
CLEAR THERE WAS GREAT CONFUSION
ABOUT HOW THE BALLOT WAS WOULD
LIKE WE SAW IN FLORIDA AND THE
LIKE IT'S STILL HAPPEN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND.
FOURTEEN YET SO THERE'S. A
WEALTH OF RESEARCH ACTUALLY NOW
ON BOTH THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE A I CAN'T BE MADE
ON BALLOT DESIGN ABOUT LAYOUT
EVEN JUST VOTER INFORMATION OF
THE A. C..
.
PROVIDED A GRANT.
TO DESIGNING OUR DEMOCRACY
GRANT ARE ON THIS AND THAT IT
WAS BUILT UP OFF OF THAT WITH AN
ONGOING PROJECT BY THE CENTER
FOR CIVIC DESIGN. OUR DO IT%
LOOKING UP LOOKING AT THIS
EXACTLY THIS EXACT ISSUE SO THAT
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN OUGHT TO
VOTERS TO THERE ARE BEST
PRACTICALLY YOUR BEST PRACTICES
IN PUBLISHED OUT THERE IN THE
LAST.
PRACTICE.
THE OPEN PRIMARY STATES.
YOU KNOW HAVE YOU SEEN THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE CONFUSION THERE WERE
SOMEONE DON'T DON'T RULE DON'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
NATURE OF OPEN PRIMARIES. SO OF
THEIR PERFECT PART PARTY
PREFERENCE TO PICK THE FIRST ONE
IN THE BECAUSE SOME CHALLENGE IF
YOU HAD ANY. ANY HOMEWORK IN
THAT AREA I'VE NOT SEEN A LOT OF
GUIDANCE I KNOW THIS IS A
CHALLENGE AND IN IN SEVERAL
STATES WITH OPEN PRIMARY SORTA
ESPECIALLY AS MORE STATES ARE
MOVING TO VOTE BY MAIL AND HOW
TO HANDLE THAT AS WELL. AYE
WHICH IS IT IS A CHALLENGE AND
AND THE ONLY OTHER THING ALL
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU ON YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT HOW THE WHICH IS
A REALLY GOOD ONE. IS THERE A
LOT OF LESSONS LEARNED ABOUT
PURCHASING
ARE AND HOW TO PURCHASE SYSTEMS
OF WHEN HARPER WAS PASSED AT THE
AC CERTIFICATION PROGRAM WAS AN
UP AND RUNNING YET. AND THE
MONEY WAS PROVIDED AND STATES
AND LOCALS WERE TOLD JUST GO BY
SYSTEMS
I AM ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE NOW IS YOU ALL LOOK AT
FUNDING FOR ELECTION OFFICIALS.
I IN THE WORK OF THAT'S BEEN
DONE FOR INSTANCE IN LA COUNTY
IS WE HAVE A MUCH MORE INFORMED
INFORMED PURCHASER OF ELECTION
SYSTEMS ARE ELECTION OFFICIALS.
KNOW WHAT THEY EXPERIENCE AFTER
TWO THOUSAND NO THE CHALLENGES
THAT THEY FACE WITH THE SYSTEMS
ARE AND ARE MUCH CLEARER ON HOW
THEY WANT THE SYSTEM SHOULD
PERFORM THE SERVER VOTERS. AND
THAT CAN ONLY HELP BUT SAVE
MONEY AND PROVIDE BETTER SERVICE
TO VOTERS.
THE FOOD TRUCK AND YEAH THE
NATIONAL
PUBLIC DISSEMINATION CAMPAIGN
INVOLVES TACOS IN THAT IS A
CULMINATES IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S
A LOT THEY DON'T IS THAT THE.
THAT THE COMMISSIONER AND I WERE
TALKING ABOUT SACRAMENTO YES AND
WHAT A LOVELY COMMUNITY IT IS.
ONLY MY GET INTO THE MOVIES
NOW. WE'RE ALL IN TROUBLE IF
THAT HAPPENS.
YEAH THAT WAS MY IT'S IF I DON'T
WANNA GIVE IT AWAY BUT IT'S IT'S
A RESULT OF FOOD TRUCKS AND WHY
NOW PARA.
BUT THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT LONG
YOU JUST GIVE US.
WITH THAT WILL ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU AND IF IN YOUR
CLOTHES YOU DO WANT TO.
ARTICULATE IF YOU HAD A MAGIC
WAND.
AND COULD DO ANYTHING YOU WANTED
WILL YOU I SEE.
THIS IS A GOOD VENUE TO.
TO TO LET US KNOW BUT.
YOU CAN YOU CAN CONTINUE THAT
BRAINSTORM TO AND COME BACK TO
US YEAH SO I I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
A OF A MAGIC ONE.
AS FAR AS THE DAC AYE I THINK
WERE.
EXACTLY WHERE WE NEED TO BE
DOING THE WORK THAT THAT WE'RE
DOING I'M I'M PLEASED TO BE
THERE. ARE THAT THE MAGIC WAND I
WOULD HAVE.
OR CHANGE I WOULD MAKE IS IS UP
FOR I'VE WORKED IN THIS SO JUST
OVER A DECADE NOW IN THIS
ELECTION TECHNOLOGY SPACE ARE IN
RIGHT NOW IS BY FAR AND AWAY THE
MOST ATTENTION I'VE EVER SEEN
PAID TO IT. AND I HOPE WE ALL
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT ATTENTION
THAT'S BEING PAID TO GET THE
RESOURCES TO GET THE INFORMATION
TO GET THE SERVICES ARE AYE I
MENTIONED GOOGLE AND CLOUD
FLARE.
UP GOOGLE IN FLAT CLOUDFLARE
CURRENTLY OFFERING FREE SERVICES
TO LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
HELP PROTECT THEIR WEBSITES.
THAT'S AN UNBELIEVABLE OFFERING
FROM TWO SIGNIFICANT COMPANIES
RIGHT AND AYE I WOULD HOPE THAT
WE CAN ENCOURAGE MORE PRIVATE.
PUBLIC PARTNERSHIPS LIKE THAT TO
BRING THOSE TYPES OF SERVICES TO
BEAR TO THE LOCAL ACTION
OFFICIALS BECAUSE THE SMALL
COUNTIES IN PARTICULAR ONLY AS
GOOD AS OUR WEAKEST LINK. AND
THE SMALL COUNTIES IN PARTICULAR
OTHERS RESOURCES COULD BE
ENORMOUSLY IMPACTFUL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU PRITCHETT
THAT'S COMMISSIONER.
SO NEXT WE HAVE OUR FIRST OF TWO
PANELS ON THE AGENDA TODAY.
ON THIS PANEL INCLUDES THREE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST EXPERIENCED
ELECTION ADMINISTRATORS. IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER THEY ARE NEIL
KELLY THE REGISTRAR OF VOTERS
FOR ORANGE COUNTY.
MISTER KELLY IS AN APPOINTEE OF
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURE
GOVERNMENT COORDINATING COUNCIL
THE GCC WHICH WE'VE.
TALK ABOUT A LOT TODAY.
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED TO INFORM
HOW THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY WORKS WITH STATE AND
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO IMPLEMENT
ITS DESIGNATION OF ELECTION
SYSTEMS AS PART OF THE NATION'S.
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
MISTER KELLY HAS BEEN WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER VOTERS
OFFICE FOR NEARLY FOURTEEN YEARS
AND IT'S BEEN THE REGISTRAR
THERE FOR THE LAST TWELVE YEARS.
SECOND DEAN LOGIN AS THE
REGISTRAR RECORDER COUNTY CLERK
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY MISTER
LOGAN IS ALSO THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLARK'S. AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS MISTER LOGAN
HAS MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE YEARS
EXPERIENCE IN ELECTIONS
ADMINISTRATION. IN RECORDS
MANAGEMENT AT THE LOCAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENT LEVELS AND IT'S
BEEN THE REGISTRAR OF VOTERS FOR
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. AND THIRD WE
HAVE GAIL PELLERIN THE SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY CLERK REGISTRAR OF
VOTERS.
MS PELLERIN HAS TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE SERVING AS
THE PRIMARY ELECTIONS OFFICIAL
IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. FIRST IS
THE COUNTIES ELECTIONS MANAGER
AND SHE'S HOW THE POST OF COUNTY
CLERK SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
MS PELLERIN HAS SERVED AS AN
INTERNATIONAL ELECTION OBSERVER
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ALEXIAN OBSERVATION
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TEAM
AND IT'S BEEN A MEMBER OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S VOTING
ACCESSIBILITY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
IT'S TWO THOUSAND SIX.
AND THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH WE'RE
WE'RE REALLY LUCKY TO HAVE ALL
THREE OF YOU AYE HERE JOINING US
TODAY.
AND A WHAT. APPARENTLY LED THE
THREE OF YOU DECIDE WHO YOU GO
FIRST.
AND AND.
CORD POOR NIELSEN GETTING THROWN
OF THE BUS ABOUT YEAH.
GOING INTO THE LAWS OF MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
A CHAIRMAN STERN BOTH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
JUST WANTED TO SAY.
BEFORE I START IT'S ALWAYS A
GOOD DAY WHEN I HAVE TO FALL
SECRETARY PEDIA AND COMMISSIONER
MASTERSON SO GIVE IT MY BEST
SHOT.
ME TO SOMEONE HARPER YOU RAISE
A POINT ABOUT SCANNING SYSTEMS
AND I JUST WANTED TO TELL YOU
WHY BEEN SITTING HERE IN THE
OFFICE OUR SYSTEM HAS BEEN
SCANNED FOR ABOUT.
I TAKE FIVE THOUSAND TIMES
A RIGHT TO THE FAR WALL
FROM IP ADDRESSES THAT ARE
OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTRY
SO TO PUT IT IN PERSPECTIVE THAT
THE.
TYPE OF OF SECURITY IN ISSUES
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH ARE AT
THE FOREFRONT EVERYDAY.
SCURRYING ELECTIONS HAS ALWAYS
BEEN AN IMPORTANT THEME
A PARADIGM SHIFT OCCURRED IN
SECURITY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
ELECTIONS WHEN WIDELY REPORTED
ATTEMPTS WERE MADE TO DISRUPT
ELECTIONS IN THE UNITED STATES.
IN ADDITION THERE HAS BEEN A
GREAT DEAL OF ATTENTION ON
ISSUES RELATED TO BALLOT
INTEGRITY VOTER REGISTRATION
SYSTEMS AND ENSURING THE
ELIGIBILITY OF VOTERS.
AS A RESULT IN ORANGE COUNTY
WE'VE BEEN AGGRESSIVELY PURSUING
SECURITY MEASURES TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS.
I BELIEVE IN A PROACTIVE RING OF
SECURITY.
IS CRITICAL TO SAFEGUARD THE
MILLIONS OF BALLOTS ARE CAST IN
ORANGE COUNTY.
EVERY YEAR.
AS YOU WELL KNOW IN YOU SPOKE TO
CHAIRMAN STERN A IN JANUARY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE DEPARTMENT
HOMELAND SECURITY. DESIGNATED
STATE AND LOCAL VOTING SYSTEMS
AS CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN
ORDER TO OFFER A FEDERAL
RESPONSE TO THESE THREATS.
MANY ELECTION OFFICIALS ARE
BOLSTERING CYBERSECURITY AND
RESILIENCE LEVELS AS WELL AS
PHYSICAL SECURITY WHICH IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. FOR FUTURE
ELECTIONS BY FOCUSING ON THE KEY
DIGITAL COMPONENTS.
OF THEIR ELECTION SYSTEM SUCH AS
VOTER REGISTRATION DATA BASES
ELECTION MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS AND.
THE ALL CRITICAL IMPORTANT
ALEXIAN AT REPORTING SYSTEM.
I AM ONE OF TWENTY FIVE ELECTION
OFFICIALS HALF OF WHICH ARE
SECRETARIES OF STATE THAT HAVE
BEEN APPOINTED TO THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT HOMELAND SECURITY
GOVERNMENT COORDINATING COUNCIL
OR GCC.
FOR THE ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURE
SECTOR
MY INVOLVEMENT AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL GIVES ME UNIQUE INSIGHT
INTO THE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH TRYING TO PROTECT NEARLY
EIGHT THOUSAND DISPARATE
ELECTION. JURISDICTIONS.
THE PURPOSE OF THE GCC IS TO
FOCUS ON COMMUNICATION PROTOCOLS
THREAT NOTIFICATION INCIDENT
RESPONSE AND EXTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS.
TWENTY SIXTEEN CERTAINLY SHOWED
US THAT THERE WAS A GREAT DEAL
OF WORK THAT NEEDED TO BE DONE
TO IMPROVE THIS COMMUNICATION
THERE IS A LOT OF PRESS
ATTENTION I'D AROUND THAT VERY
ISSUE.
THE GCC IS NOW FINALIZING
COMMUNICATIONS PROCESSES FOR
ELECTION SPECIFIC NOTIFICATIONS.
WE'VE ALSO PROMOTED THE
LEVERAGING A MULTI STATE
INFORMATION SHARING FUSION
CENTERS AS COMMISSIONER
MASTERSON SPOKE TO FOR
CONTINUOUSLY MONITORING THREAT
DETECTION AND INCIDENT AWARENESS
AND RESPONSE.
MEMBERS OF THE GCC ARE NOW GOING
THROUGH FEDERAL BACKGROUND.
CLEARANCES IN ORDER TO EXCEL AT
ACCESS TIMELY THREAD
INFORMATION.
SO I THINK YEARS IMPORTANT
QUESTION HOUSES GOING TO BENEFIT
LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS.
NOT JUST THE GCC MEMBERS.
TO THAT END THE GCC IS ACTIVELY
WORKING ON DEVELOPING A SECTOR
SPECIFIC PLAN WITH INFORMATION
FOR LOCAL ELECTION OFFICES THIS
WILL OUTLINE THE FEDERAL
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THOSE LOCAL OFFICES.
IT WILL PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR HARDENING ELECTION SYSTEMS
AND DELIVER A TEMPLATE FOR BEST
PRACTICES.
WHICH INCLUDES TRAINING TABLETOP
EXERCISES CHAIN OF CUSTODY
PROCEDURES AND MORE.
THERE CURRENTLY IS A WEALTH OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FROM
HOMELAND SECURITY AS WELL AS THE
NATIONAL GUARD WHICH HAS BEEN
SPOKEN TO THAT WILL PROVIDE
ENHANCED SECURITY FOR EVEN THE
SMALLEST ELECTION OFFICES.
AND MANY OF THESE RESOURCES ARE
FREE OF CHARGE SOME SOME THERE
ARE CHARGES BUT MANY OF THEM
FREE.
FOR INSTANCE IN CONJUNCTION WITH
DHS ELECTION OFFICES CAN
REGULARLY MONITOR ELECTION
SYSTEM THREATS AND
VULNERABILITIES TO DEFEND ANY
CYBER RELATED NETWORK ATTACKS.
INCLUDING PHISHING SCAMS MALWARE
DENIAL OF SERVICE ATTACKS AND
OTHER COMMON PRACTICES EMPLOYED
BY MALICIOUS ACTORS.
IN ADDITION PARTING WITH DHS AN
IN HOUSE IT ADVISORS PRIVATE
SECURITY PARTNERS STATE AND
LOCAL SAYS THOSE AND OTHERS WILL
HELP TO ENSURE THAT ELECTION
SYSTEMS ARE SECURE WITH
TECHNOLOGIES AND STANDARD
OPERATING PRACTICES.
SO ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
GOT UP EARLY ON WHEN WHEN I WAS
INVITED TO SPEAK WAS YOU KNOW
THERE A FEW COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE STILL USING
ELECTRONIC SYSTEMS ORANGE COUNTY
BEING ONE OF THEM.
NUMBER FORTUNE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WE HAVE THE REQUIREMENT OF
HAVING A PAPER BACK UP ON THOSE
ELECTRONIC BOOTHS.
THESE VOTER VERIFIED PAPER LA
BALLOTS PROVIDE EVIDENCE OF EACH
VOTERS INTENT IN A WAY THAT
CANNOT BE COMPROMISED BY
COMPUTER ELEMENTS OF THE VOTING
SYSTEM THAT'S CRITICAL.
IN ADDITION AIR GAPS PROTECT
AGAINST NETWORK INTRUSIONS AND
STRICT STEALIN CHAIN OF CUSTODY
MEASURES ARE IN PLACE.
NOW THERE ARE MANY BRILLIANT
MINDS AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT
WOULD PROBABLY HAVE A GOOD
DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE THAT SEALS
PROVIDE AID A LEVEL OF SECURITY
THAT IS.
AND NOT THE BEST.
ARE HOWEVER I FEEL IT THESE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE IN PLACE
ARE STRONG BARRIERS.
AND AND THEY'RE VERY IMPORTANT.
SO IN MY OPINION THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH AND I WANT TO GET INTO A
LITTLE BIT OF THE MEAT POTATOES
SOME OF THE THINGS I THINK WE
SHOULD BE DOING TODAY.
WE MUST CONSIDER MY OPINION
MOVING TOWARDS A ROBUST SYSTEM
OF RISK LIMITING AUDITS.
PURPOSE OF A SOUND ELECTION
AUDIT IS TO PROVIDE CONFIDENCE
THAT ELECTION OUTCOME IS
CORRECT.
ANY POTENTIAL ERRORS AND
TABULATION MUST BE DETECTED AND
CORRECTED.
RISK LIMITING AUDITS CAN BE
INCREDIBLY EFFICIENT.
AN ELECTION WITH TENS OF
MILLIONS OF BALLOTS CAN.
ATTENTION WOULD BE CHECKED BY
EXAMINING ONLY A FEW HUNDRED
RANDOMLY SELECTED BALLOTS.
I PLAN ON CONDUCTING ONE OF
THESE RISK WINNING AUDITS IN
JUNE AS A PILOT PROGRAM. ON THE
PURPOSE OF THAT IS TO SHOWCASE A
PROOF OF CONCEPT THAT YOU CAN'T
ON LEGACY SYSTEMS CONDUCTORAS
LOOMING ON IT AND I THINK THAT'S
CRITICAL.
THERE'S A LOT OF FOCUS ON VOTING
SYSTEMS COMMISSIONER MATCHES AND
TALKED ABOUT THIS DELINEATION
BETWEEN VOTING SYSTEMS AND VOTER
REGISTRATION SYSTEM.
BUT IN MY OPINION THE REALITIES
IS GREATER VULNERABILITIES THAT
ARE OUT THERE.
OUTSIDE OF THE VOTING SYSTEM.
SO FOR INSTANCE WE KNOW THAT IT
VOTER REGISTRATIONS.
WAS SUCCESSFULLY INTRUDED UPON
IN ILLINOIS WERE SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND VOTER RECORDS.
WERE AT STAKE.
IN ORANGE COUNTY THERE ARE ON
AVERAGE I WANNA GIVE A PRACTICAL
EXAMPLE TO
S. RATES WE HAVE ELEVEN HUNDRED
DEATHS THAT OCCUR EACH MONTH IN
ORANGE COUNTY.
AND I WOULD WANT TO BE ABLE TO
DETECT WITHIN MY VOTER
REGISTRATION DATABASE ANY
ANOMALIES IN THAT DATA MY SING
ANY TRENDS THAT MIGHT BE
OCCURRING THAT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY
SIMPLE TO DO.
BUT WHAT ABOUT PARTY CHANGES.
WHAT A PARTY CHANGES WERE DONE
IN A SUBTLE WAY THAT THAT WERE
IMPERCEPTIBLE THAT YOU COULD NOT
DETECT THEM?
HAVING THE ABILITY TO DETECT
NUANCES IN THE DATA WOULD BE
INVALUABLE.
CAPTURING SNAPSHOTS OF THAT
DATABASE IN CONDUCTING AUDITS ON
THE VOTER REGISTRATION SYSTEM I
THINK IS JUST AS IMPORTANT AS
CONDUCTING AUDITS ON THE VOTING
SYSTEM.
OUR A AND IT'S CRITICAL.
FINALLY I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
FUNDING ISSUES I THINK IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT ELECTION OFFICES
HAVE SUFFICIENT EQUIPMENT
TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND RESOURCES
TO MAINTAIN A SOUND SECURITY
POSTURE FOR THEIR ELECTION BASED
SYSTEMS.
INCLUDING REPLACING AGING VOTING
EQUIPMENT THAT IS NEARING AND OF
LIFE I'M ONE OF THOSE CITIES
USING WINDOWS TWO THOUSAND ON A
PORTION OF THE SYSTEM AND LOVE
TO ENGAGE ON THAT DISCUSSION.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF REASONS FOR
THAT.
BUT NO LONGER MEET STATE
TESTING AND CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS AND SOME OF THE
SYSTEMS AND THEY WILL SOON FAIL
TO MEET SUCH REQUIREMENTS DUE TO
A LACK OF TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND
REPLACEMENT PARTS.
I'M GRATEFUL TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE IN THE GOVERNOR FOR
INCLUDING FUNDING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR THE REPLACEMENT OF
SYSTEMS.
BUT I KNOW IT'S NOT LOST ON THIS
COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO TO PUT
IT OUT THERE THAT CONGRESS HAS
STILL NOT APPROPRIATE THE FULL
THREE HUNDRED NINETY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS LEFT IN HAVA.
THAT NEEDS TO BE APPROPRIATED
IN MY HUMBLE OPINION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
TO LOGIN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BERMAN AND
CHAIRMAN STERN AND MMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M DEAN LOGAN THE
REGISTRAR RECORDER COUNTY CLERK
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY I'M HERE
TODAY BOTH IN MY CAPACITY AS THE
CHIEF ELECTIONS OFFICIAL FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
BUT ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLARK'S ELECTION OFFICIALS AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE A PART OF THE THE
CONVERSATION TODAY ON
CYBERSECURITY CALIFORNIA
LECTIONIS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST ON BEHALF OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
REGISTRARS OF VOTERS WHO
REPRESENT THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND OF ELECTION
ADMINISTRATION IN THE STATE. I
WANT TO CONVEY HOW SERIOUSLY WE
TAKE THE SECURITY AND INTEGRITY
OF THE ELECTIONS PROCESS.
LOCAL AND STATE ELECTION
OFFICIALS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN SYSTEM
SECURITY AND EXCISING DILIGENCE
AND MONITORING FOR THREATS AND
VULNERABILITIES THAT UNDERMINE
OUR ELECTIONS PROCESS.
I WE'VE HEARD FROM A PREVIOUS
BECAUSE AND I APOLOGIZE THE
REPUBLICAN HERE A LOT OF
REPETITION HERE BUT THAT WEEK
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT. THE REPORTS
AND WE'VE BEEN ASSURED THAT
THERE WERE NOTES THAT THERE'S NO
SPECIFIC INFORMATION TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT CALIFORNIA
ALEXIAN SYSTEMS WERE
COMPROMISED.
OR THAT THE VOTE TABULATION
PROCESS AND TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH
MANIPULATED IN CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER WITHOUT QUESTION OUR
AWARENESS AND ALERTNESS IS
HEIGHTENED BASED ON THE
RECOGNIZABLE ACTIVITY AND
THREATS.
THAT HAVE BEEN REFERENCED IN
YOUR BRIEFING PACKETS AND BY
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS.
WHAT IS CLEAR IS THAT THERE ARE
BAD ACTORS ACTIVELY TRYING TO
DISRUPT THE ELECTIONS PROCESS
AND THAT THREAT IS COMPOUNDED BY
INCONSISTENT INFORMATION SHARING
AND INCIDENT REPORTING?
AS WE MOVE INTO ANOTHER MAJOR
ELECTION CYCLE IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON ALL OF US FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS
TO BE VIGILANT ABOUT SECURITY
WHILE ENCOURAGING ACTIVO TO
PARTICIPATION TO DEMONSTRATE THE
STRENGTH OF OUR REPRESENTATIVE
FORM OF GOVERNMENT.
WITH RESPECT CYBERSECURITY
PREPAREDNESS FOR ELECTIONS THERE
ARE TWO IMPORTANT POINTS ODD TO
REMEMBER FIRST CYBERSECURITY IS
NO DIFFERENT FOR ELECTIONS THAN
IT IS FOR OTHER CRITICAL SECTORS
INVOLVING THINGS LIKE HEALTHCARE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND FINANCIAL
SERVICES.
THE BEST CYBERSECURITY PRACTICES
ADOPTED BY INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY PROFESSIONALS ACROSS
THE SPECTRUM OF GOVERNMENT IT IS
FREE ARE EQUALLY APPLICABLE TO
ELECTIONS ADMINISTRATION
AND STRICT ADHERENCE TO THOSE
PRACTICES IS ESSENTIAL TO
ELECTION SECURITY.
SECOND CYBERSECURITY INVOLVE
SEVERAL LAYERS OF PROTECTION
AGAINST ATTACKS INCLUDING
PHYSICAL SECURITY GENERAL IT
SECURITY PROTOCOLS AND SYSTEM
SPECIFIC FEATURES.
EACH OF THESE LAYERS IS PRESENT
IN THE CYBERSECURITY DEFENCES
PROTECTING ELECTIONS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND EACH INVOLVES
PEOPLE AND PROCESSES IN ADDITION
TO HARDWARE SOFTWARE AND
FACILITIES.
WE REMAIN CONFIDENT THAT OUR
SYSTEMS DESPITE THEIR AGING
LIMITED AGILITY IN COMBINATION
WITH THE APPROPRIATE SAFEGUARDS
AND PROTOCOLS THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT TODAY. CAN ENSURE A SECURE
ELECTION ENVIRONMENT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
THAT SAID IT REMAINS INCUMBENT
UPON US TO BE VIGILANT IN
MONITORING AYE SYSTEMS
ACTIVITY IN ADHERING TO THE
OPERATIONAL PROTOCOLS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO IT SECURITY AND
ELECTION TRANSPARENCY.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE AS
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS HAVE HAVE DONE
SO THAT MUCH OF THE CONCERN
RAISED ABOUT THE INTERFERENCE IN
THE ELECTIONS PROCESS IS RELATED
TO ACTIVITY OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF
VOTING SYSTEMS THAT ELECTIONS
ADMINISTRATION.
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS AND
ALLEGATIONS HAVE CENTERED AROUND
INTERFERENCE WITH POLITICAL DATA
SOURCES AND WITH FALSE OR
MISLEADING MISLEADING SO FROM
MEDIA. OUR MESSAGING.
WHILE WE DO NOT HAVE DIRECT
ABILITY TO COMBAT A REGULATE
THAT ACTIVITY I'M THAT'S
EXTERNAL TO THE VOTING SYSTEMS
AND PROCESSES. WE DO SEE THIS AS
AN INTEGRAL ELEMENT OF THE VOTER
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION UP
PROVISIONS OF OUR OFFICES IN
THAT REGARD WE WANT TO SEEK TO
ESTABLISH AND PROMOTE TRUSTED
SOURCES OF INFORMATION. FOR
VOTERS TO SEEK INFORMATION ABOUT
THE VOTING PROCESS
AND WILL DO THAT BY ACTIVELY
SHARING ANY CLARIFICATIONS OF
WARNINGS THAT CAN HELP VOTERS
IDENTIFY INFORMATION THAT IS NOT
COMING FROM TRUSTED SOURCES.
OUR MAINTAINING THE RESOURCES
FOR THAT TYPE A NOTIFICATION
SYSTEM AND FOR BROUGHT OUT
REGION EDUCATION ACTIVITY HAS
ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY. I
WILL BE CRITICAL TO THAT EFFORT.
IN ADDITION OF WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN I COVERED IN TODAY'S
HEARING IT'S IMPORTANT AND AND
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR THIS FROM ALL
OF US TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
SECURITY THREATS AND
VULNERABILITIES REFERENCED.
LINK TO A RESOURCE THAT.
WHAT CALIFORNIA BENEFITS FROM A
POLICY FOUNDATION THAT HELPS
INSURE SECURITY?
AND THESE HAVE BEEN STATED THAT
ARE WORTH REPEATING THINGS LIKE
A WELL ESTABLISHED VOTING SYSTEM
CERTIFICATION PROCESS
THE REQUIREMENT PAPER BASED
BALLOTS THAT CAN BE VERIFIED BY
VOTERS AND THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
POST ELECTION AUDITING. A CLEAR
EMPHASIS ON TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND A SET OF
VOTING SYSTEM STANDARDS THAT
SUPPORT FUTURE DEVELOPMENT AND
INNOVATION.
HOWEVER DESPITE THAT POLICY
FOUNDATION OUR CORE ELECTIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS LARGELY
OUTDATED AND UNMATCHED TO THAT
POLICY FOUNDATION.
MOST COUNTIES IN THE STATE AS
YOU'VE HEARD ARE RELYING ON
TECHNOLOGY AND EQUIPMENT FOR
VOTING THAT IS MORE THAN TEN TO
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD AND RELIANT ON
USER INTERFACES THAT LACK THE
ACCESSIBILITY. AND FUNCTIONAL
CAPABILITIES TO MEET THE NEEDS
AND EXPECTATIONS OF A LARGE
DIVERSE AND COMPLEX ELECTORATE.
WE ALSO LACKS STABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING TO INVEST IN MODERNIZE
SYSTEMS AND SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
THOSE CHALLENGES.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY OUR CORE
VOTING SYSTEM COMPONENTS DATE
BACK TO NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT ONE
PUNCH CARD VOTING WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED IN CALIFORNIA. AND
LET ME JUST PUT THAT INTO SOME
VERY CLEAR PERSPECTIVE.
THAT MEANS THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE CORE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE USE FOR
VOTING AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PREDATES THE TWO PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS WHO ARE HERE AT THIS
HEARING. AND PREDATES THAT STAFF
AND THE TEAM THAT ARE WORKING ON
THE NEXT GENERATION OF VOTING
SYSTEM IN OUR OFFICE
AND THEY WERE DEVELOPED AFTER
OUR VOTING EQUIPMENT.
EFFORTS IMPLANTS TO MODERNIZE IN
LA COUNTY HAVE BEEN STYMIED BY
SHRINKING AND INSUFFICIENT
PROPRIETARY COMMERCIAL MARKET.
AND AT TIMES BY UNSTABLE
INFLEXIBLE REGULATORY STRUCTURE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE'RE NOW ON
THE CUSP OF INTRODUCING OUR
VOTING SOLUTIONS FOR ALL PEOPLE
INITIATIVE A LINE TO THE VOTING
MODEL ENVISIONED BY THE VOTERS
CHOICE ACT.
AND GROUNDED IN PUBLICLY OWNED
OPEN SOURCE DEVELOPED VOTING
INTERFACES AND SYSTEM
COMPONENTS.
SECURITY AS A HIGH PRIORITY FOR
US IT IS ONE OF OUR CORE
PRINCIPLES IN THE PROJECT.
THE VOTING SYSTEM WILL HAVE
FEATURES FOR SAFE AND SECURE
STORAGE INCLUDING FEATURES SUCH
AS LOCKS AND SECURITY SEALS TO
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
EQUIPMENT WHILE IN THE CUSTODY
OF ELECTION WORKERS. AND WHILE
IN THE STORAGE OF ELECTION
OFFICIALS.
IN PURSUIT OF THIS EFFORT WE
ESTABLISH AND WORK CLOSELY BUT
THE TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
THAT INCLUDED HIGHLY RESPECTED
EXPERTS IN SECURITY. AND WE WILL
ENGAGE IN THIRD PARTY TESTING
AND HACKING EXERCISES PRIOR TO
THE DEPLOYMENT OF THE EQUIPMENT.
FULLY REALIZING THE BENEFITS AND
SECURITY PROVISIONS OF THE NEW
LOS ANGELES COUNTY MODEL AND
OTHERS LIKE IT WILL REQUIRE A
FUNDING COMMITMENT TO SUPPORT
THE INITIAL INVESTMENT.
THE NECESSARY OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY THE
GOVERNOR HAS INCLUDED A HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
VOTING SYSTEM MODERNIZATION
FUNDING IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET.
THAT SIGNALS THE RECOGNITION OF
THE NEED AND A COMMITMENT OF
SUPPORT.
BUT IT FALLS SHORT OF WHAT IS
NEEDED.
YOUR SUPPORT IS NEEDED TO
INCREASE AND CONTINUE THE
FUNDING AND FUTURE BUDGETS INTEL
WE HAVE REPLACED AND IMPLEMENTED
NEW VOTING SYSTEM THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. CONSISTENT WITH THIS
DISCUSSION ON SECURITY.
IN CLOSING I WANT TO ASSURE YOU
THAT I AND MY COLLEAGUES ARE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED ON THE STATE
AND NATIONAL LEVELS IN ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS INFORMATION SHARING
AND COLLABORATION AROUND
CYBERSECURITY IN ELECTION
INTEGRITY.
AS NEW INFORMATION IS THE SENATE
FROM THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
WE INSURE ALL COUNTIES ARE WELL
INFORMED. AS RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING SECURITY PROTOCOLS
CHECKLISTS AND TOOLS ARE MADE
AVAILABLE WE MOVE SWIFTLY TO
ENSURE OUR PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES ARE LINED.
WE RECOGNIZE THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THIS DIALOGUE AND OUR RESPONSE
HAS AND AND THE RESPONSE THAT
HAS ON VOTER CONFIDENCE
PARTICIPATION.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
RAISING THE PROFILE OF THESE
ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
STAND READY TO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE U. S.
ELECTION ASSISTANCE COMMISSION
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY THE SECRETARY STATE.
AND THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ELECTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER LOGAN MS
PALLOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR
BERMAN AND CHAIR STERN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND STAFF I'M HONORED TO
BE HERE TODAY. AND I AM WELL
THANK YOU FOR IMPROVING THE
GENDER DIVERSITY OF HELL A THANK
YOU GOT THAT THAT PROBABLY ONE
OR TWO WOMEN SPEAKING TODAY.
AND SO I'M GAIL PELLERIN SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY CLERK REGISTER
VOTERS WE ARE SMALL COUNTY A
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
REGISTERED VOTERS I HAVE EIGHT
ADD TEAM MEMBERS WHO HELPED ME
WITH THE A THE JOB OF CONDUCTING
ELECTIONS AND.
UP WE ARE ALL CROSS TRAINED SO I
MYSELF AM INVOLVED WITH UPDATING
MY WEBSITE I DO COUNT IT FILING
I ANSWER THE TELEPHONES I HELP
AT THE COUNTER WE ALSO DO
WEDDINGS AND PASSPORTS
FICTITIOUS BUSINESS NAMES. AND
AND WE HAVE A VERY SMALL TRAVEL
BUDGET I'M HERE TODAY ON MY OWN
TIME WHICH I AM A HAPPY TO DO IT
LIKE THAT TO SEE MY DAUGHTER AT
UC DAVIS AND HAD DINNER WITH HER
LAST NIGHT SO. IT'S MY PLEASURE
AND BUT ONE OF THE THINGS TO PUT
ON MY NOTES HERE AS I AM NOT A
CYBERSECURITY EXPERTS. AND THE
REASON IS WE ARE SMALL AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF OTHER DUTIES I DO
HAVE OF. A PERSON WHO RUNS BY IT
DEPARTMENT MARTIN PETE AND WHO
IS THAT MILITARY SECURITY
EXPERTS WHO DOESN'T EXPLAIN JOB
BUT I NEED TO RELY ON OUR COUNTY
INFORMATION SERVICES DEPARTMENT.
SECRETARY STATE YOU KNOW LARGER
COUNTIES THAT HAVE INFORMATION
OR CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION A
CLERK THAT ELECTION OFFICIALS
EAC I ALL THESE GREAT RESOURCES
THAT ARE OUT THERE I NEED TO
RELY ON THEM FOR INFORMATION.
AND IT BUT AT THE COUNTY CLERK
IN CHARGE OF THE SYSTEM YOU KNOW
THAT THE SOMETHING THAT KEEPS ME
UP AT NIGHT. THE SECURITY OF OUR
VOTING SYSTEM UP WE ARE UP
AGAINST TROLLS BULLIES HACKERS A
POTENTIALLY TERRORISTS AND IT'S
GREAT THAT ELECTIONS HAVE BEEN
ADDED TO THE A CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE I UNDERSTAND A
CALIFORNIA THERE'S ALSO SIXTEEN
AREAS THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. AT WITH THE
WATER ELECTRICAL WHICH ACTUALLY
KEEPS ME UP AT NIGHT AS WELL
AND.
AND YOU KNOW THE TECHNOLOGY ALL
TECHNOLOGY HAS
SOME VULNERABILITIES AND WE
DOUBLE CHECK EVERYTHING TRIPLE
CHECK EVERYTHING WE HAD THE
PAPER ABOUT WE DO THE AUDITS
AND.
AND YOU KNOW AND ALL EVIDENCE
THAT'S BEEN GATHERED BY THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITIES HAVE
CONFIRMED THAT WE ARE MAINLY
DEALING WITH TROLLS. WHO ARE
SCANNING OUR SYSTEM BASICALLY
KNOCKING ON THOSE DOORS
PRIMARILY VOTER REGISTRATION SO
I THINK THAT THAT HOW WE'RE?
PRESENTING THIS IN THE MEDIA'S
VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
AND THE EFFORTS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WHERE THERE ARE TWENTY
ONE STATES ARE SCANNED BY
RUSSIAN IP ADDRESSES THERE WAS
ONLY THAT ONE INSTANCE IN EL
ILLINOIS WHERE THEY ACTUALLY
ACCESS THE VOTER DATA NO RECORDS
WERE ALTERED OR DELETED. AND THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT OUR
FIREWALLS HAVE PREVAILED AND
THEY DID NOT GET IN.
AND.
.
I THINK THERE GOAL THOUGH IS TO.
BRING DOUBT INTO PEOPLE'S MINDS
ABOUT THE INTEGRITY AND THE
ACCURACY OF OUR VOTE AND IN THE
HOPES THAT WE STAY HOME AND
DON'T VOTE.
AND SO I REALLY AM TRYING TO GET
OUT THERE TO EDUCATE PEOPLE ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF GETTING SIGNED
UP. AND SHOWING UP ANDREW AND AT
THE POLLS.
AND.
SO WHERE THERE WAS A FAILURE TO
HALF THE VOTE I BELIEVE THERE
WAS A GREAT SUCCESS AND HACKING
IN PEOPLE'S MINDS AND BELIEFS.
AND I HAD THIS IS NOT NEW PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
.
THE FEDERALIST PAPERS FROM
ALEXANDER HAMILTON WARNED
AMERICANS TO BEWARE OF FOREIGN
EFFORTS TO HIJACK U. S.
ELECTIONS.
AND AN INTERESTING I BUT WORK IN
THIS BUSINESS TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AYE WE RECENTLY MOVED OUR OFFICE
AND IN THE PROCESS OF PACKING UP
FILED LIKE FOUND A FOLDER ON
THIS GREAT NEW THING CALLED THE
INTERNET.
AND I HAD THESE GREAT NOTES AND
COMMENTS IN THERE ABOUT HOW
WONDERFUL THIS NEW TOOL IT THEN
AND I ACTUALLY HAVE A SCREEN
SHOT ON ELECTION NIGHT WHEN THE
SECRETARY STATE THOUGHT OF
OFFICE OR. WEBSITE WITH ACT
OF WITH THAT INAPPROPRIATE IMAGE
ON ELECTION NIGHT SO I STILL
HAVE THEM BUT ONCE THAT.
AND BUT IT ALSO THE TODAY WITH
THE INTERNET AND SOCIAL MEDIA IT
MAKES IT MUCH EASIER FOR THESE
TROLLS TO USE BOTS TO SPREAD
THEIR LIES AND DECEIT AND POOR
FUEL ON THIS FIRE. AND YOU KNOW
TWENTY SIXTEEN THERE IS
INFORMATION OUT THERE THAT THAT.
THAT THE POPE HAD ENDORSED
TRUMP AND THAT AFTER THE PARK
WHEN SHOOTING IN RUSSIA AND THE
RUSSIAN SOCIAL MEDIA FIGHT FOR
UP AND RUNNING WITH INFLAMMATORY
PRO AND ANTI GUN CONTROL
MESSAGES WITHIN HOURS OF THOSE
KILLINGS. ALL WITH THE CAMPAIGN
TO DISRUPT AND DIVIDE.
AND AND I GET SO FRUSTRATED WITH
THAT BECAUSE WE ARE BETTER THAN
THAT'S.
AND YEAH I WORKED CLOSELY WITH
THE FACTORY STATE OFFICE ARE
COUNTY FORMATION SERVICES TEAM
UP TO ENSURE THAT OUR SYSTEMS
ARE PROTECTED FOR MANY CYBER
INVASION. ARE VOTER REGISTRATION
NETWORK TO THE FACTORY STATES
OFFICE IS ISOLATED AND WE HAVE A
SOPHISTICATED EN POINTE
PROTECTIONS ON SERVERS AND
WORKSTATIONS.
OF VOTE HOW HAS ONE PIPE TWO
SEPARATE STATE WITHIN THE DATA'S
ALL ENCRYPTED.
AND WE HAVE NEXT GENERATION
FIREWALL THAT SECURITY
APPLIANCES DEPLOYED THROUGHOUT
THE NETWORK WHICH BLOCK KNOWN
THREATS AND PROVIDE REAL TIME
REPORTING OF SUSPICIOUS OR
ABNORMAL BEHAVIOR ON THE
ELECTIONS IT INFRASTRUCTURE I
GOT THAT FROM MY AYE TEACHING.
AND.
WE HAVE NO REMOTE ACCESS
SOFTWARE ON OUR SERVERS AS IF
THERE EVER IS AND KNOWN THREAT
TO ALEXIAN SYSTEMS IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE STATE AND
LOCAL ELECTIONS OFFICIALS BE
NOTIFIED IMMEDIATELY. SO THAT WE
CAN FOR ANY EFFORT TO COMPROMISE
OUR SYSTEMS IT'S SO FRUSTRATING
GETTING THAT THE NEWS MONTHS OR
YEARS LATER. AND OF COURSE
CALIFORNIA AND OF THE
DECENTRALIZED VOTING THAT SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA WERE ALL
INDEPENDENT FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
SO I THINK IT'S MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT A HACK IN THE SYSTEMS.
AND.
OUR VOTING SYSTEM INCLUDE THE
STANDALONE VOTING EQUIPMENT THAT
IS NOT TIED TO ANY NETWORK OR
INTERNET YOU'VE HEARD THAT HERE
TODAY. AND ARE A YOU KNOW WE HOW
THE TEMPER PROOF SEALS WE DO ALL
THE AUDITS AND.
AND THERE IS DEFINITELY A NEED
FOR MORE FUNDING WE HAVE ONE OF
THOSE OLD SYSTEMS.
THAT WE DO NAY REPLACE BUT I
WANT TO GUARANTEE THAT IT IS
SECURE AND WE DO HAVE A LOT OF.
PROCESSES IN PLACE WITH YOU KNOW
TO PERSON CHAIN OF CUSTODY AND
AND LOTS OF LIVES TO MAKE SURE
THAT. EVERYTHING IS PROTECTED
AND AND OF COURSE ALL VOTERS
WILL VOTE ON PAPER RECORDS THAT
ARE THOROUGHLY AUDITED WE AND
THEN IN THE EVENT THAT A VOTER
DOES SHOW UP TO VOTE AND THEIR
NAMES ON THE LIST WE HAD THE
PROVISIONAL VOTING NOW IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE. SAME DAY
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
AS WELL WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO AND
REGISTER UP TO INCLUDING
ELECTION DAY IF THEY'RE NOT
CORRECTLY ON THE LIST. THAT WE
DO THE RESTRICTED ACCESS TO THE
VOTING EQUIPMENT A WE'VE BEEN
INVESTIGATED BY A GRAND JURY
TWICE AND HAD GLOWING REPORTS
WITH OUR SECURITY THAT WE HAVE
THAT WE DID AND IMPLEMENT.
RECENTLY THE THUMB DRIVES ONE
WAY ONE USE AND THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE NEED TO BE
DOING AS WELL. WE MONITOR AND
BACK UP AND LOG OR DATA DAILY.
AND WE ARE DOING THE.
THE PENETRATION TESTING TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A STRONG
SYSTEM AGAINST THAT ANY BREACH
OR ATTACK.
THAT BOTTOM LINE IN MY VIEW IS
AMERICA IS UNDER ATTACK.
IT HAS BEEN UNDER ATTACK.
IT REMAINS UNDER ATTACK.
AND THE US GOVERNMENT IS DOING
VERY LITTLE ABOUT IT.
SO I AM VERY PROUD TO BE HERE
TODAY WITH ALL OF YOU BECAUSE
WE'RE DOING SOMETHING ABOUT IT
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT YOU HAVE VERY
WELL SAID.
LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO MY
COLLEAGUES.
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE OF OUR.
COUNTY ELECTIONS LEADERS.
JUST TURN.
OPUS ART CENTER ALLEN.
A LOT OF FOR BEAUTY THAT HOT HOT
HOT HOT.
YEAH CANNELLA SO IT'S A.
YOU KNOW.
YEAH WELL.
YEAH.
A.
WHY PRETTY APPRECIATE AND NOT
ONLY THE TESTIMONY BUT ALSO ALL
THE HARD WORK THAT GOES BEHIND
HAND YOUR PRESENTATIONS?
SO I'VE HEARD. I'D LOVE TO GET
YOUR THOUGHTS ON AND A PUSH
THAT'S.
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY WITH THE
CROWDS TO OPEN SOURCING.
.
THE THE DID BASICALLY THE
SYSTEMS THAT UNDER GIRD. YOUR
WORK.
AND LEGISLATURE BY THOUGHTS ON
ON THAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE.
IN THE GOOD GOVERNANCE GONNA
WATCH STOCK COMMUNITY ARE REALLY
SEEM TO BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD BE
A VERY GOOD THING.
I DOUBT INSURANCE TAG READY IN
OUR IMPROVE INTEGRITY EFFORTS
AND WOULD LOVE TO GET YOUR
VARIOUS THOUGHTS.
I'M HAPPY TO TALK MEANT FOR YOU
DON'T YOU DON'T TALK ABOUT YEAH
OKAY SO.
IN AND THAT IS ONE OF THAT THE
PRINCIPLES OF THAT THE VOTING
SOLUTIONS FOR ALL PEOPLE.
INITIATIVE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IS TO TO DEVELOP THE THE. THAT
THE CORE UNDERPINNINGS THAT
SYSTEM USING OPEN SOURCE
PLATFORM I THINK WHEN WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT OPEN SOURCE SOLUTIONS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT.
YOU CAN GO BACK TO SECRETARY
PREVIOUS POINT TO THEIR THERE IS
THERE'S A VOCABULARY AROUND OPEN
SOURCE TO IN AND A LOT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS THAT A LOT
OF DIFFERENT OPINIONS ON WHAT
TYPE OF LIFE AND THINK SHOULD BE
USED.
WHETHER WHETHER OPEN SOURCE
MEANS THAT YOU'RE PUBLISHING
THAT OUT ON GET HAVE BEEN MAKING
IT AVAILABLE ARE PERMITTED TO
DOWNLOAD AND AND CONTRIBUTE TO
IT THERE THEIR DIFFERENT WAYS TO
DO THAT. ARE I THINK FROM FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE JUST SPEAKING
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY'S
PROTECTIVE IN THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE ON MOVING FORWARD OUR
FUNDAMENTAL PREMISE IS THAT THAT
WE WANT TO HAVE. THE CORE.
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR VOTING
SYSTEM WE WANT THAT TO BE A
PUBLICLY ON SYSTEM WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT ELECTIONS ARE ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO PUBLIC
THEY SHOULD NOT BE LIMITED TO
PROPRIETARY LIMITED SYSTEMS
WHERE WHERE WHERE THAT SOURCE
CODE CANNOT BE REVIEWED SO WE
HAVE WE HAVE PUT IN THE
PROVISIONS OF OUR F. P. THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF BASED ON THE
DESIGN SPECS THAT WE THAT WE ARE
ON THE IP FOR. THAT THAT BE
DEVELOPED ON AN OPEN SOURCE
PLATFORM HOW THAT GETS LICENSED
AND HOW THAT'S MADE AVAILABLE TO
BE SHARED WITH OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AND HOW THAT
SECURED. A IS STILL VERY
IMPORTANT.
TO DO SO I ALWAYS MAKE THE
DISTINCTION THAT.
WE ARE WE ARE OPERATING ON A
PROJECT THAT IS THEY'VE VOTING
SYSTEMS PROJECT.
NOT OPEN SOURCE
DEVELOPMENT.
IT SAID THAT THE NFL LITTLE BIT
OF ANYONE SO WHERE WERE USING
THE FUNDAMENTALS AND THE
STRENGTH OF OPEN SOURCE BUT IT
IS NOT A DEMONSTRATION OF OPEN
SOURCE AT THE DEMONSTRATION ON.
HOW TO GET THE BEST VOTING
SYSTEM THAT WILL MEET THE NEEDS
OF OUR VOTERS SO IT'S FOR VOTERS
FIRST AND THEN WE WILL?
WE WILL EXTEND THE THE OPEN
SOURCE PLATFORM BEYOND THAT SO
BUT ALL OF THAT SAID I THINK
THAT.
I I CAN TELL YOU FROM THE WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE THAT FOR
INSTANCE THAT OUR TALLY SYSTEM
THAT THAT WE PLAN TO HAVE
CERTIFIED AND AN OPERATING FOR
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS IN
NOVEMBER.
A HAS BEEN DEVELOPED AND IS
BEING DEVELOPED ON AN OPEN
SOURCE PLATFORM AND THE USER
INTERFACE FOR ABOUT MARKING
DEVICES THAT WILL. BE OPERATING
AT ABOUT SENATORS AND TWENTY
TWENTY.
ALSO IS REQUIRED TO BE
DEVELOPED ON AN OPEN SOURCE
PLATFORM A AND I THINK THAT
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT CENTER LEYVA.
REFERENCE IN A QUESTION TO
SECRETARY VIDEO EARLIER IS THAT
THAT WE DO HAVE DISPARITY IN
TERMS OF RESOURCES AND OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES BASED ON
SIZE AND RESOURCES AND LA COUNTY
WHEN WE. UNDERTOOK THIS PROJECT
IN SOME WAYS WE WERE FORCED INTO
THAT'S BECAUSE THERE WASN'T A
SYSTEM AVAILABLE FOR US BUT. OUT
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE BECAUSE OF
OUR SIZE AND BECAUSE OF THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO DO THE SAME WAY. THAT
CAN BE SHARED WITH OTHER
JURISDICTIONS IN WHOLE OR IN
PART AND WHERE ARE THE OPEN
SOURCE DEVELOPMENT WILL ENABLE
US TO DO THAT.
OKAY. MYTHS ABOUT IT'S BECAUSE
IT'S PRETTY QUICK ANSWER FOR ME
AND THAT IS WE WERE OP ARE
LOOKING FOR SYSTEM TO. A
MORE OPEN TO OPEN SOURCE AND
LOOKING AT THOSE SYSTEMS I THINK
THAT THE GOOD THING ABOUT OPEN
SOURCE IS THERE'S OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING SUCH A
SOVEREIGN DEPENDENCE IN THE
POTENTIAL FOR END TO END
VERIFIABLE SYSTEM SO. GOOD STUFF
THAT ARE HAPPENING THE
MARKETPLACE.
AND JUST AS FAR AS THE CODE
BEING AN ESCROW SHOULD THERE BE
ANY DISCREPANCY WITH THE VOTING
SYSTEM THEY CAN ACCESS THAT AND
REVIEW IT SO IT'S NOT THAT IT'S
LOCKED UP AND EVERYTHING.
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE EVERYONE'S ON
THE SAME PAGE WHAT WHY THE.
I'M A* OFFLINE BABS TENET
WHAT WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S EVANS
NERVOUSNESS
THAT IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE ALL PRETTY AMENABLE TO
THIS.
I I.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT THAT THE
NERVOUSNESS IS AROUND THE OUR
LINE.
AS WELL
I ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE FACED
IN LA COUNTY IS THAT. THAT WE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO USE EVEN
THE FEDERAL MONEY AND STATE.
PROPOSITION MONEY.
THAT THAT WAS AVAILABLE FOR THE
REPLACEMENT OF PUNCH CARD VOTING
SYSTEMS WE WERE NOT ABLE TO USE
THAT MONEY EVEN THOUGH WE STILL
HAVE EARMARKED UNLIKE ANYWHERE
NOT ABLE TO USE THAT FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR SYSTEM.
BECAUSE IT IS REGULATED FOR THE
USE OF ALREADY CERTIFIED VOTING
SYSTEMS WHICH WHICH LIMITS YOU
TO THE OPTIONS THAT ARE OUT
THERE AND THAT LIMITED
PROPRIETARY MARKET PARA WE'VE
WE'VE MADE EFFORTS TO CHANGE
THAT.
THROUGH THROUGH LEGISLATION ON
LAST COUPLE YEARS AND AND MANY
OF YOU HAVE BEEN PARTNERS IN
THAT BUT WE STILL HAVE A WAYS TO
GET CAUGHT UP WITH.
WITH THAT IN A WAY THAT WOULD
INCENTIVIZE.
NOT JUST COUNTIES BUT ALSO AT
THE COMMERCIAL MARKET TO START
LOOKING AT MORE OPEN IN THE END.
THEY SOLUTION
I THE REALITY IF I HAD A BUCKET
FULL OF MONEY TODAY AND I WENT
TO THE VOTING SYSTEM STORE TO
BUY A VOTING SYSTEM THERE'S. TWO
ON THE SHELF.
DO YOU THINK SO YOU KNOW THAT'S
JUST NOT A GOOD SELECTION REALLY
HE WON HAVE MORE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE AT ALSO WE NEED TO GET
THE MONEY ONE ONE THING WE FOUND
OUT WE DID GET THAT HALL THEN
THAT PROP FORTY ONE MONEY. IT
PAID FOR THE VOTING SYSTEM BUT
IT DIDN'T PAY FOR THE CARE AND
FEEDING OF THE VOTING SYSTEM SO
THAT THE WAREHOUSE THING WE HAD
TO HIRE A NEW STAFF PERSON TO
MANAGE THE WAREHOUSE AND. AND
YOU KNOW JUST A IT REQUIRED A
LOT MORE LOCAL SOURCES THAT YOU
KNOW FUNDING SOURCES WE HAVE TO
DO AS WELL AND IT'S JUST BEEN A
STRESS PERSONAL COUNTY. OKAY
ANOTHER THING I HEAR ABOUT FROM
FOLKS YOU KNOW AND AND
OBVIOUSLY.
THIS IS A SUPER SENSITIVE RIGHT
TO PEOPLE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE INTEGRITY THE SYSTEM PART OF
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A SECRET BALLOT
WHICH IS A VERY IMPORTANT PART
OF OUR SYSTEM AND YET IT IT
ALSO.
AND LEADS TO AN ACTUAL LEVEL OF
NERVOUSNESS FROM PEOPLE BECAUSE
IT INVOLVES.
I AM YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T JUST
TRACK VOTES.
IVAN SO HOW DO WE ENSURE THE
INTEGRITY OF THE SYSTEM. I'M.
ONE THING WE HAD A HEARING A LOT
ABOUT AND UNITED BENNETT PANELS
IN FORUMS WHERE WHERE FOLKS
BROUGHT UP. THE WHOLE QUESTION
OF OUR AUDITS.
I AND DONE SOME.
CHANGES THAT MADE BEEN MADE IN
THE WAY THAT WE DO AYE THAT'S A
LETTER TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT. IT WITH THINGS THAT WE
CAN TELL CONSTITUENTS IN OUR
DISTRICTS WHO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE AUDITING PROCEDURES
AND.
SO THAT FOLKS CAN UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN AND TO
ENSURE INTEGRITY IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
.
THERE THE YOU GET YOU GET SOME
FOLKS OUT THERE WHO ARE
SOMETIMES CONCERNED ABOUT ABOUT
NINE.
WHAT THEY MAY PERCEIVE AS?
SHORT CUTTING.
THE AUDIT PROCESS AND.
LOVE TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THAT.
SO I WOULD JUST REITERATE LET
LET NIELSEN HIS TESTIMONY I I
DON'T THINK YOU WILL FIND A RED
STAR. IN CALIFORNIA THE DOES NOT
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF MOVING TO
WARDS A RISK WHEN MANY AUDIT
MODEL IN THEIR DIFFERENT WAYS TO
DO THAT.
WE ARE WORKING IN OUR
ASSOCIATION ON THE ON THE BILL
TO TO DO THAT THERE'S THERE'S
THAT UP BILL THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
INTRODUCED.
I IT WHICH BILLS AT THAT TIME AS
TO WHO'S RUNNING AT. ASSEMBLY
MORE QUICKLY WITH RUNNING THAT
HAD THE BILL NUMBER I GET IT
OKAY NON.
IT.
IT'S A COMPLICATED AREA IN NEEDS
AND NEEDS A LOT OF WORK AND SO
THERE THERE THERE IS A COALITION
OF PEOPLE WORKING BOTH INSIDE
THE ASSOCIATION OF CLIQUES
ELECTION OFFICIALS AND WORKING
WITH. STAKEHOLDERS AND AND.
ELECTION INTEGRITY ACTIVISTS ON
ON THAT PROCESS ONE OF THE
THINGS THE CHALLENGING IN THIS
REGARD IS IS A LOT OF THE MODELS
FOR IF BY ME LIMITING AUDITS ARE
BASED ON.
A STATEWIDE ELECTION RESULTS AND
IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE WEIRD.
AT. WE DISTRIBUTED AND AND WE WE
DON'T TEND TO THE LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T TEND TO MANDATE.
THINKS TO APPLY TO ALL COUNTIES
BECAUSE THERE'S A COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT AND THAT
CUTS HAVE TO BE PAID SO WE ARE
WE'RE ACTIVELY TRYING TO WORK ON
THE STRUCTURE THAT WOULD ALLOW
FOR COUNTIES TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION I THINK IT'LL TAKE
AWHILE TO DO THAT. A AND OUR
INTENT IS FOR THAT TO BE USED AS
A REPLACEMENT OF THE ONE PERCENT
MANUAL TALLY THAT'S THAT'S
CURRENTLY IN PLACE THERE'S
UTILITY IN THE ONE PERCENT
MANUAL TALLY I'M WITHOUT
QUESTION IT PROVIDES
TRANSPARENCY IT'S IT'S EASY FOR
PEOPLE TO. OBSERVE AND
UNDERSTAND IT'S NOT
STATISTICALLY BASED AND IF YOU
GO BACK IN THE LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY IT WAS INTENDED. TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE VIABILITY
IN THE ACCURACY OF THE COUNTY
EQUIPMENT NOT TO. NOT TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE OUTCOME OF
THE PARTICULAR CONTEST WAS
CORRECT RISK LIMITING AUDIT SEEK
TO DO THAT. THAT LATTER TO TO
ACTUALLY REINFORCE THAT THE
OUTCOME ON BASED ON THE
STATISTICAL MODEL IS AS AS YOU
WOULD EXPECTATIVA COUNT MORE
BALLOTS UNTIL YOU REACH THAT
I'M.
THAT THRESHOLD SO I THINK
THERE'S GENERAL SUPPORT I THINK
SOME OF THE CONTROVERSY ARE
CONCERNED STATE THAT THAT YOU'VE
HEARD.
AND AND AT THE EVENT THAT YOU
AND I RECENTLY WHERE AT I'M WERE
MORE ABOUT METHODOLOGY AND ALSO
ABOUT PRACTICE I MEAN
PRACTICALLY SPEAKING. OF WE HAVE
TWENTY EIGHT DAYS TO CERTIFY THE
ELECTION AFTER ELECTION DAY
CRITIQUE THAT INCLUDES.
YET NOW IT'S THIRTY.
THAT INCLUDES A LATE ARRIVING
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS WERE VERY
PROUD IN CALIFORNIA OF THE
DEGREE TO WHICH WE. I CAREFULLY
EXAMINED PROVISIONAL BALLOTS AND
VALIDATING COUNT THOSE THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT TO ENFRANCHISEMENT IF
YOU IF YOU TRY TO SQUEEZE IN A A
ROBUST AUDIT IN THAT SAME
PERIOD.
I'M SOMETHING HAS TO GIVE SO
IT'S A THERE'S A TIMING AND
OPERATIONAL CONCERN BUT
PHILOSOPHICALLY I DON'T THINK
YOU WOULD FIND A REGISTRAR IN
THE STATE THAT WOULD NOT AGREE.
WITH MOVING TOWARDS A MORE
ROBUST WITH LIMITING AUDIT
FUNCTION BIDS EDITOR I'M SORRY.
I WAS GONNA SAY AND I THINK TO
WE WERE LOOTING TO US THAT THE
INCLUSION OF PROVISIONAL BALLOTS
INCLUSION OF VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS WRITING AFTER NEARLY AS
PART OF THE AUDIT PROCESS.
AND THAT SPEAKS I THINK TO THE
INEFFICIENCY THE WILD
INEFFICIENCIES IN THE ONE
PERCENT MANUAL TALLY
AND SOME COUNTIES HAVE THE
PROCEDURES IN PLACE TO BE ABLE
TO INCLUDE THOSE AND SOME HAVE A
LOT OF DIFFICULTY DOING THAT AND
THAT. AGAIN POINTS T WHY WE
NEED THIS WRESTLING ON A
PROCESS.
AND HERE'S THE REALITY WHEN YOU
HAVE A CLOSE CONTEST AS THE
PERSON WHO CAN BE CITING THAT
STATEMENT VOTE ATTESTING TO THE
VOTE THE ACCURACY THAT VOTE. I
WILL BE RECOUNTING EVERY SINGLE
BALLOT IN THAT CONTEST DEPENDING
ON HOW CLOSE IT IS FROM WE'VE
DONE THAT WITH THE CITY OF SANTA
CRUZ RACE BUT WE HAD ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND VOTES IN
THE RECOUNT IT AT ALL AND. I
LOVE YOU KNOW SO SO READ AND I
KNOW REGISTERED ACROSS THE STATE
DO THIS AS WELL SO BELT ESCALATE
THEIR AUDIT WHEN THEY DO HAVE
VERY CLOSE CONTACT THAT WE GOT
YOU DO WE PACK CAO YEAH WE'VE
HAD TYPE VOTES BEFORE TO. YOU
KNOW AND HAD BEEN WAIT CERTIFY
THAT I'M ABSOLUTELY SURE I KNOW
EVERY NUANCE OF EVERY BALLOT IF
I LOOKED.
NO AND BEING SMALL YET WE'RE
STILL MAY VERY.
YEAH.
WE ARE THOSE WHO REMEMBER.
YOU KNOW THAT IN MIND DO YOU CAN
YOU SPEAK TO ANY I'M.
IS THERE ANYTHING WE ARE BE
KEEPING IN MIND IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION SP FOUR
FIFTY.
WITH REGARDS TO THE THEMES THAT
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING TODAY.
I'VE BEEN.
NINA.
MANY THINGS WERE NOT THINKING
ABOUT A GIVEN THE FACT OR ABOUT
TO SHIFT OVER TO THIS NEW
SYSTEM.
I GUESS TWO THINGS COME TO MIND
FOR FOR ME ONE IS AND I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THIS DURING
EARLIER TESTIMONY AND WE.
I BELIEVE THAT THAT
THE PROVISIONS OF THE VOTER
CHOICE ACT AS BEFORE FIFTY AND
GO A LONG WAY AND CONTRIBUTING
TO THE THE COMPREHENSIVE
INCIDENT RESPONSE RECOVERY PLAN
BECAUSE OF THE. ELEVEN DAY
VOTING PERIOD OF VOTE SENATORS
BECAUSE OF THAT PROVISIONS THAT
ALLOW PEOPLE TO CORRECT THEIR
REGISTRATION OR MAKE CHANGES AT
THAT BUT CENTER AT THE TIME THAT
THEY'RE VOTING. THAT.
THAT.
INCREASES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
VOTERS TO TO BE ABLE TO CORRECT
ANY ISSUES THAT HAVE IMPEDED
THEIR ABILITY TO TO VOTE RIGHT
NOW THOSE ON AVAILABLE AT
INDIVIDUAL POLLING PLACES SO. I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT THAT THAT
MODEL OF VOTING GOES A LONG WAY
IN ADDRESSING.
SECURITY CONCERNS
THE THE OTHER PIECE I WOULD SAY
IS IS AGAIN BACK TO THAT THE
RECLAIMING AUDIT MODEL IS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT THE
FIVE COUNTIES THAT ARE.
IMPLEMENTING IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
ARE ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING WITH
IT HOW DO YOU APPLY THE ONE
PERCENT MANUAL TALLY TO ABOUT
CENTER MODEL WHERE VOTERS ARE
VOTING NINE IN MULTIPLE
LOCATIONS SO AGAIN I THINK IT
JUST IT. IT IS MY BELIEF THE
POINT THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THAT AND A MORE ROBUST MONEY.
AUTUMN AND FOR ME LOOKING AT THE
BOAT CENTER MODEL I'M REALLY
LOOKING OUT THE CONNECTIVITY TO
THESE VOTE CENTERS AND. WE KNOW
WE HAVE A HARD ENOUGH TIME AND
SOME OF OUR AREAS WE ACTUALLY DO
OPERATE ABOUT CENTER WATSONVILLE
WHERE THEY DO THE VOTING FOR THE
TWENTY NINE DAYS BEFORE THE
ELECTION. AND WE'RE CONSTANTLY
HAVING CONNECTIVITY ISSUES SO
YOU KNOW BEING A ROLE COUNTY I
CAN IMAGINE SOME THESE. YOU KNOW
OFFSITE OF FACILITIES HOW WELL
THAT'S GOING TO WORK SO AND JUST
KEEPING THE SECURITY AND THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF ALL THOSE
LOCATIONS AS WELL AND STOPPING.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE A NEW
PERSON IN THERE EVERY DAY YOU
HELP THAT CONSISTENT STOPPING
AND TRAINING YOU KNOW AND AND
THEN SO HERE'S THE CHING CHING
THE MONEY STARTS GOING BECAUSE
WE NEED TO HAVE THOSE RESOURCES
TO MAYBE HIRE PEOPLE. AND I
TRAIN THEM SO THEY KNOW HOW TO
USE ALL THE SYSTEMS NOW. OKAY
RIGHT WHAT LAST WILL REQUEST IS
EARLIER A GRADE ONE PAGER OR
VIDEO OR MAYBE I SHOULD JUST GET
A BRIEFING ON THE PROCESS BEHIND
THE RISK LIMITING AUDIT PROCESS.
AND I HAVE A GREAT WHEN I CAN
SEND YOU WOULD YOU MIND OF
YASSER AYE AYE DOES LOVE TO.
BETTER UNDERSTAND.
I'D BE HAPPY TO.
YEAH BECAUSE WE ARE BABIES WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS WE'RE SHIFTING.
FROM THIS ONE PERCENT ANNUAL
TALLY TOWARD THE WRIST LIMITING
AUDIT PROCESS.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW. THAT I'M.
YOU KNOW TRUST YOU GUYS AND AND.
I'D WANNA BETTERS IN THE SYSTEM
SO THAT I CAN BETTER ANSWER
CONSTITUENTS.
AS THEY RAISE CONCERNS AND.
FEARS ABOUT ANY KIND OF SHIFT IN
THIS AREA BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE.
YOU KNOW AYE AYE UNDERSTANDABLY
NERVOUS JUST GIVEN THE ALTHOUGH
THE ATMOSPHERE OUT THERE I'M.
I THINK YOU KNOW I I TWENTY
DOLLARS AND SYSTEM.
IT'S AWESOME SOCCER THAT WE
CANNOT PROVIDE YOU LINK THAT
THAT THE STATE OF COLORADO THAT
JUST DID THE STATEWIDE
RECLAIMING NOT AT THAT SECRETARY
COULD YOU TALK ABOUT. JUST
PUBLISHED A VIDEO.
AS WELL IT'S A LITTLE MORE
COMPLICATED A ONE PAGER BUT WE
CAN'T HAVE AS WELL OKAY THANK
YOU.
THEY VERY MUCH IN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS SANDOR STERN CHAIR
STERN I GOT A COUPLE QUICK ONES.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR COMING UP.
AND FOR MAKING THE.
SLIP ON YOUR OWN DIME ESPECIALLY
THAT SPEAKS TO YOUR COMMITMENT
TO.
THE PUBLIC TRUST IN FOR DINNER
WITH YOUR DAUGHTER I.
YEAH HOBOS GOOD SHE BETTER PAID
IF YOU KNOW YOU KNOW.
ALL MONDAY IT'S ON MY THAT SHE
WAS THERE.
EXACTLY.
YOU KNOW THE. FUTURE A BIT OF A
NINE COUPLE EVEN BACK UP AT
MASTERSON'S.
.
COUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS FOR YOU
ALSO A.
MSI SACK ADMISSION MASTERSON
BROUGHT THAT UP.
WHO?
TERMS OF THE CHALLENGES YOU
WOULD SEE SIGNING UP FOR THAT IS
THAT GONNA BE USEFUL INFORMATION
AT A YEAR THERE ARE.
YOU'RE ON THE.
FORGET THE NAME ZZ THE GCC.
.
SO CHALLENGES ARE EXPEDITIOUSLY
SORT OF ENGAGING IN THAT SYSTEM
YES SIR SO IT'S IT'S VERY EASY
TO SIGN UP IT'S FREE THOSE LIKE
THOSE OF THE TWO IMPORTANT
POINTS I WANT TO POINT OUT.
AND THERE'S USEFUL INFORMATION
THE DIFFICULTY I THINK THAT SOME
ELECTION OFFICES WILL HAVE HIS
SORTING THROUGH THE WHITE NOISE
BECAUSE THERE IS A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT'S THROWN AT
YOU.
AND I I THINK ONCE YOU FIND THAT
BALANCE BETWEEN THE WHITE NOISE
AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT IT WILL BE
VERY USEFUL FOR FOR ALL ACTION
OPS.
AND.
AND INSERT CENTER BECAUSE YOU
HAVE WOMAN PLEASE HERE SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING ON THE GCC IS.
DO WE HAVE A. A BRANDED ELECTION
ISAK AS OPPOSED TO JUST THE
GENERIC MSI SACK AND I AND THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ARE CONTINUING
BECAUSE THAT CAN ALSO HELP.
FATAL TO IT AND AND CUT OUT THE
WHITE RIGHT BECAUSE MSI SACK IS
GONNA HAVE ALL CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE RISK INFORMATION
KNOW THEY ARE THERE ONLY
FORWARDING INFORMATION RELATED
TO ELECTIONS WITH A PROBLEM WITH
THAT IS THERE'S A LOT OF AND
FOR.
BECAUSE YOU COULD YOU COULD GET
JUST THE GENERAL SCANNING
INFORMATION RIGHT RIGHT THAT'S
NOT GONNA BE SPECIFIC TO YOUR
COUNTY. SO THAT'S THE PROBLEM
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
IT'S ORG PRODUCE SOMETHING THAT
WE COULD SEND OUT TO ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS SO THEY CAN ALL JR
DEATH THAT YEAH BECAUSE I WAS
GONNA SAY WHAT CAN WE DO TO
ESPECIALLY TO ENCOURAGE. THE
REGISTRARS LIKE THAT GAIL AND
AND SMALLER COUNTIES TO BE ABLE
TO DO THIS AND HOW BEST PRACTICE
SOME FILTERING OUT LIKE YOU'RE
SAYING WHITE NOISE ESPECIALLY IF
YOU END WHAT MARTIN MARTIN ARE
GOING TO BE.
THE SOUL WATCHERS ON THE WALL
THERE TO BE LOOK AND IT'S A IT'S
A LOT TO ASK FOR SO. IF THERE'S
ANYTHING WE CAN BE DOING ALSO
THE STATE LEVEL TO EITHER
ENCOURAGE PUSH TRAIN.
WOULD LOVE THAT FEEDBACK
BECAUSE WE WANT TO LOOK AFTER
THE SMALL COUNTIES TO ABSOLUTE.
I THINK THAT THAT TO STATE YEAH
PLEASE I KNOW THAT IT IS YEAH
ONE TO SAY THAT THAT.
I THINK THE SECRETARY STATE.
I HAS DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
DISSEMINATING THAT INFORMATION
VERY QUICKLY WHEN WHEN THEY GET
SO THE COMBINATION OF. NEIL AS A
RESOURCE.
REPRESENTING LOCAL OFFICIALS
AND THE SECRETARY STATE THAT IS
HAPPENING I THINK THERE'S
THERE'S MORE THAT CAN BE DONE ON
THAT AND THEN I THINK TWO TALES
FINE IT'S IT'S ACTUALLY
IDENTIFYING. WHO ARE THE MARTINS
IN ALL THE COUNTY ATTITUDES
THAT?
?
BECAUSE IT IS.
EVEN IN THIS MONTH SMALL
COUNTIES I THINK NOW THERE'S
SOMEBODY WHO'S RESPONSIBLE IF
THE CHIEF INFORMATION SECURITY
OFFICER AND SAID IT'S.
AS IMPORTANT IF NOT MORE
IMPORTANT. UP FOR THEM TO GET
THAT INFORMATION THAT IS AS IT
IS THE REGISTRANT IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT CASIO COULD COME
BACK TO OUR COMMITTEE ON JUST
SORT OF LET US KNOW STATUS FOR
SIGN UPS IN CHALLENGES AS IT AS
IT EVOLVES SO THAT WE DON'T HIT
JUNE AND THEN. SO WERE WE WERE
SORT OF WONDERING BUT DOING IT
SOONER THAN LATER JUST REPORT
BACK AND CHECK AND LET US KNOW
OKAY.
.
ON THAT NOTE.
TERMS OF UTILIZING RESOURCES OUT
THERE.
MASTERSON BROUGHT UP GOON CLOUD
FLARE IN THE DESERT OF FREE TIRE
KICKING IF YOU WILL THAT THEY'RE
OFFERING.
AND I ELISE YOU KNOW SEEING LA
YOU GUYS ARE DOING A LOT OF THAT
IN HOUSE.
BUT.
DOES THAT.
IN TERMS OF THE THIRD PARTY
VALIDATION AND TRYING TO FIND
OTHER BRANDS
OUT THERE BEYOND GOVERNMENT
SAYING THE GOVERNMENT'S DOING A
GOOD JOB WHERE THERE'S GOING TO
JUST BE INHERENT DISTRUST FROM
PEOPLE WHO DON'T TRUST
GOVERNMENT PERIOD.
EFFICACY IN THAT APPROACH OF WE
UTILIZE THAT DO IT TO YOUR
KNOWLEDGE IN ANY.
.
ANY COUNTIES IN THE STATE
SO WE WE ARE IN IN CONJUNCTION
WITH OUR BE SET PROJECT THE BODY
SOLUTIONS AND PROJECT IN LA
COUNTY WE WILL BRING IN A THIRD
PARTY. I'M HACKING GROUP TO TO
ACTUALLY ATTEMPT TO HACK THE
SYSTEM AND WE THINK AND WE SENT
STAFF FROM OUR.
A PROJECT TEAM TO THE DEATH CON
CONFERENCE IN IN LAS VEGAS WHERE
THEY HAD A. VOTING SYSTEM
HACKING VILLAGE TIME AND YOU
PROBABLY READ ABOUT THAT WHERE
WHERE OUR STAFF WATCH TO SEE HOW
THE. ANA PENETRATED THAT SYSTEMS
AND HOW THEY WORKED ON NOW.
WE WANT TO LOOK AT THAT IN
PRACTICAL TERMS I MEAN SOME OF
SOME OF THAT.
IS BEST PREVENTED BY.
SECURING THE ACCESS TO THE
SYSTEMS AND AND I'M DOING
OPERATIONAL THINGS AND THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS I AM LOOKING LIKE
JUST PERSONNEL NOT GIVING UP
THAT PASSWORD TO THEY'RE. NOT
DANCING THINKING OF MOVING IN
THERE THAT THAT RIGHT. IDEA SO
SO WE'RE WE'RE DOING THAT I
THINK WE RECOGNIZE.
THAT THAT IT ISN'T GOING TO BE
ENOUGH
FOR US TO SAY THAT THAT WE DID
THAT IN HOUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE
THIRD PARTY VALIDATORS. THAT IS
PART OF THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT A
THIRD PARTY TESTING.
AUTHORITY DOES COME IN AND LOOK
AT THE CODE AND AND RUN TEST. A
PENETRATION TEST.
VOLUME TEST ALL OF THOSE THINGS
BEFORE YOU GET THAT SEAL OF
APPROVAL TO MOVE FORWARD I THINK
THE THAT THE MAIN EMPHASIS IS
HOW DO WE CARRY THAT FORWARD SO
EVEN AFTER YOU'RE CERTIFIED
AFTER YOU IMPLEMENT IT.
ESPECIALLY WERE MOVING TO MORE
AGILE MODELS WHERE WE CAN UPDATE
THAT SYSTEMS ON A MORE REGULAR
BASIS WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT
THOSE PROTOCOLS ARE IN PLACES.
AND LET ME JUST ADD IF I COULD
GET HONOR.
SO WE ARE PARTNER WITH CAL TECH.
STARTING THIS MONTH ACTUALLY ON
A NINE MONTH PROJECT.
FOR A THIRD PARTY VALIDATION ON
WHAT WE'RE DOING ON OUR NETWORKS
ARE SYSTEMS VOTER DATABASE. DEAL
USE THAT AS BEST PRACTICE FOR
OTHER COUNTIES IN THE STATE AND
I WOULD JUST ADD GOOGLE'S DOING
GREAT WORK.
.
CENTER FOR INTERNET SECURITY IS
DOING GREAT WORK BUT THE
ACADEMICS ARE ALSO SOMEBODY
MENTIONED LOOKING AT FOR THIRD
PARTY VALIDATION.
AND WHAT WE'RE WORKING WITH A
THIRD PARTY AS WELL TO DO
PENETRATION TESTING IDENTIFY ANY
WEAKNESSES.
SO HE WOULD BE MY ONE.
REQUEST THEN IS THAT.
AS YOU GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS
LET'S FIND A WAY.
YES THERE WE THE CERTIFICATION
AT THE END AND YOU'LL GO THROUGH
WHATEVER.
THIRD PARTY VALIDATION GOING
THROUGH BUT PUBLICIZING THAT
PROCESS AND LETTING THE PUBLIC
KNOW THAT. WE ARE DOING THIS
SORT OF WHITE HAT HACKING
EXERCISES IN THAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THIS TIRE KICKING
PROCESS BEFORE THEY GO TO THE
POLLS. THERE'S LET'S FIND SOME
WAY TO PUBLICLY COMMUNICATE THAT
AND.
I I WANT TO.
FOLLOW THAT UP THOUGH WITH WE
DON'T WANT TO ADD EVEN FURTHER
TO YOUR PERSONNEL AND RESOURCE
BURDENS ON THAT FRONT SO THE
OTHER PART I'D LIKE IS IF WE ARE
GOING TO ACCURATELY BE
COMMUNICATING BACK TO THE PUBLIC
ABOUT WHAT. YOU KNOW WHAT'S
BEING DONE ON DEFENSE WHAT'S
BEING SORT OF WHAT'S GOOD
INFORMATION.
IN ADDITION THAT HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR MILLION WHICH IS.
FOR MINOR SAYING REALLY SOLELY
FOCUS ON EQUIPMENT ITSELF ON THE
ON THE CAPITAL BUT NOT ON THE.
AND AND NOT ON THE PERSONNEL.
FEEDBACK ON THAT FRONT WILL BE
VERY VERY HELPFUL
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IF THERE IS.
ONE MORE PERSON.
IN THE COUNTY OF SANTA CRUZ TO
BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT THIS
STUFF OUR PUBLIC INFORMATION
OFFICER SUMMING IT ACTUALLY GET
OUT THERE.
YEAH I I'M I'M VERY INTERESTED
IN IN THAT SO.
YEAH ANYWAY HOPE YOU HOPE YOU
GUYS WILL TAKE THAT INTO
ADVISEMENT.
AND WITH THAT AND THAT'S ALL
I'VE GOT.
CIRCLE A QUICK QUESTIONS.
MISTER LOGAN YOU'D COUNT
ALLUDED TO.
BUT BORN OPEN THIS UP THAT TO
EVERYBODY.
THEY THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR.
KIND OF A FIFTY FIFTY MATCH
WITH COUNTIES
FOR PURCHASING NEW ELECTIONS AND
VOTING SYSTEMS AS AS NOT NOT.
BEING A AS A GOOD FIRST START
BUT NOT BEING ENOUGH.
AND SO I GUESS THE QUESTION I'D
LOVE TO HEAR FROM YOU ALL IS AND
WHAT IS ENOUGH.
GO BEYOND VOTING SYSTEMS OTHER
CERTAIN OTHER THINGS THAT IT
THAT IT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR THE
STATE TO SUPPORT COUNTIES ON.
MAYBE KEEP A LAUNDRY LIST OF
THE TOP TEN.
BUT WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM YOU
KNOW ALL YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
SO I GET SAD I ADMIT WHEN I WAS
PRESIDENT. OF CC GO WAS WORKING
CLOSELY THE SECTOR STATES OFFICE
IDENTIFYING WHAT WOULD BE THE
CAPITAL INVESTMENT NEEDED
ACROSS THE STATE. AND THAT
NUMBER IS ACTUALLY CLOSER ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT SIMILAR TO THE THE
BOND GET ALL THE ANSWER THAT'S
CORRECT AND THAT TAKES IN
CAPITAL ONLY DOESN'T TAKE AND
THEN WRITE DOT THING IN THE
TRAINING AND OTHER ADDITIONAL
COSTS.
OKAY.
AND THEN OF COURSE I AM I AM
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR OF
FOR INCLUDING THAT THAT AND WE
ALSO I THINK A COLLECTIVELY AS
WELL AS MY COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE
STATE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
MANDATES AND YOU KNOW THAT THAT
FUNDING THAT.
HAS BEEN TAKEN AWAY JUST FOR THE
NORMAL OPERATION PIECES IS VERY
DIFFICULT CHALLENGING WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO SET ASIDE MONEY
TO PROTECT CYBER NAM SO.
AND I WOULD JUST THE TWO TWO
THINGS THAT THAT I WOULD.
ADD TO THAT ONE IS THAT WHEN WE
LOOK AT THIS I THINK WE HAVE TO
LOOK BEYOND JUST THE EQUIPMENT
REPLACEMENT ONE OF A THE GREAT
THINGS ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN.
LOS ANGELES IS THAT THIS WAS
BASED ON DATA FROM VOTERS AND
IT'S BASED ON VOTER BEHAVIOR OF
THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT IS BASED
ON THAT AS WELL BUT THE REALITY
IS THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT VOTERS
AGAIN EXPECTED WHEN IT'S
IMPLEMENTED VOTER THIRD BY AND
LARGE CAN EXPECT WHAT THEY.
EXPERIENCE ANYMORE SO A PART OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION COSTS WE HAVE
TO MAKE AN INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH.
OTHERWISE IT WON'T BE
SUCCESSFUL WE DON'T REALIZE THE
FULL VISION OF THOSE REFORMS
JITTER IF WE DON'T DO THAT.
SO SO THAT'S THAT'S LIKE A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND AND
JUST STAYED.
BECAUSE I HAVE TO I FEEL
OBLIGATED TO FADE THAT THAT IT
IS THOSE OF THOSE MANDATES I
MEAN FINALE COUNTY WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO ROLL OUT THIS NEW
VOTING SYSTEM AND EVERY OTHER
MONTH WE HAVE. SPECIAL VACANCY
ELECTIONS THAT THAT ARE BEING
PAID FOR THAT ARE BEING SQUEEZED
OUT OF OUR OPERATIONAL BUDGET
AND HAVE THREE COMING UP IN
APRIL. I'M IN A MATTER OF DAYS
THE GOVERNOR'S GONNA ANNOUNCE
ANOTHER ONE ALL OF WHICH HAVE TO
BE MERGED INTO THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ELECTION CYCLE WITHOUT
ANY FINDINGS AND AND WE'VE A
BILL ON THAT THIS YEAR AS WELL.
INTRODUCED BY SOMEONE NUMBER
CARILLO WHO KNOWS A LOT OF VERY
ABOUT ABOUT US ELECTIONS IT SO.
YEAH HOPEFULLY WOULD THAT
ADDRESSED REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT.
.
MISTER KELLY WHAT I COULD MISTER
LOGAN YOU MENTIONED YA OUT WC
OUT LA COUNTY DEVELOPING ITS
OWN.
VOTING SYSTEM.
AND I THINK YOU ALLUDED TO THIS
EARLIER BUT TO WHAT EXTENT.
YOU KNOW WILL LA BE CONSIDERING.
OR ARE WILLING TO MAKE THAT
SYSTEM AVAILABLE FOR USE BY THE
JURISDICTIONS AND A HAVE YOU
RECEIVEDANY INTEREST FROM OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THEM I WANT TO USE
THE SYSTEM THAT.
THAT YOU'RE KIND OF TAILOR
MAKING.
WE WE CERTAINLY HAVE RECEIVED.
OF THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST IN
IT A BOTH WITHIN CALIFORNIAN
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA WE
ESTABLISHED EARLY ON IN THE
PROJECT THAT WE WANTED THAT TO
BE.
A PART OF A COURT PROCESS IS TO
TO MAKE IT AVAILABLE IN WHOLE OR
IN PART. ON HOW THAT HAPPENS
AND.
CANDIDLY WE WANT WE WE WE NEED
TO BE SURE WE GET IT RIGHT AND
LA COUNTY FOR SURE THAT WE GET
UP AND RUNNING AND GETS.
WE ARE A LONG WAY FROM NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT AND IT'S IT'S
OVERDUE IN LA COUNTY.
SO WE WANT TO DO THAT WE ALSO
ARE VERY CLEAR THAT WE HAVE NO
INTEREST IN BECOMING A VOTING
SYSTEMS VENDOR. RUNNING
ELECTIONS IN LA COUNTY IS
CHALLENGING.
ON IT'S OWN BUT.
BUT WE DO WANT TO LOOK AT AT AT
LICENSING ABILITY TO TO LICENSE
THE THE I. P. THE LICENSE THE
SOFTWARE THE DESIGN SPECS FOR
THE HARDWARE ARE ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE BECAUSE THEY'RE
PUBLICLY OWNED. WE HAVE SOME
ABILITY TO CHAIR SHARE THOSE IN
WAYS THAT THAT THAT.
ARE TYPICALLY AVAILABLE AND WE'D
LIKE TO TO MAXIMIZE THOSE ALSO
ALL THE DATA AND ALL OF THE WORK
THAT'S GONE IN THAT THAT. THE
FOCUS GROUPS AND WORK WITH
VOTERS THAT IS ALREADY AVAILABLE
ON OUR WEBSITE IS AVAILABLE.
TO ANYONE WHO WANTS TO USE THAT
TO IT TO SUPPORT. ANY KIND OF
SIMILAR EFFORT THERE AND GREAT.
AND MISTER KELLY A THAT AS A
MEMBER OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY'S ELECTIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE GOVERNING
COORDINATING COUNCIL.
WHAT'S YOUR SENSE ABOUT HOW
SERIOUSLY DHS IS TAKING ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES TO HELP.
PROTECT ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURE
EXTREMELY SERIOUSLY THERE HAVE
BEEN. A NUMBER OF.
IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS THAT HAVE
TAKEN PLACE SINCE WE FORMED.
AND I THINK THE RISK UP THE
SCHISM AT FIRST ERA AS TO DHS IS
COMMITMENT TO THOSE. BUT I CAN
TELL YOU FROM THE LEADERSHIP AT
THE TOP ALL THE WAY DOWN A IT'S
VERY CLEAR THEY'VE TAKEN A VERY
IMPORTANT AND VERY GOOD HERE
VERSION OF THAT.
.
ALL RIGHT I THINK ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
NOW WE'RE ON THE FORTY FIVE
MINUTES BEHIND.
IT'S A GREAT. JOB CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
ART IS MY DISTINCT HONOR TO
WELCOME OUR LAST
SAID OF.
STING WAS PAINLESS TO THE.
THE TABLE HERE ANDREW GROTTO AND
PAMELA SMITH.
GUYS WANNA COME UP AND TAKE
SEE
.
WELCOME MR GROTTO.
MISS SMITH.
JUST FOR A QUICK INTRODUCTION
FOR A MEMBERS HERE.
INTEGRATE AS.
WILLIAM J. PERRY INTERNATIONAL
SECURITY FELLOW AT THE CENTER
FOR INTERNATIONAL SECURITY AND
COOPERATION IN A RESEARCH FELLOW
AT THE HOOVER INSTITUTION BOTH
AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY WE'VE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THEIR
WORK AT CENTER FOR INTERNATIONAL
SECURITY COOPERATION EARLIER. A
BEFORE STANFORD PRESERVATIVE WAS
A SENIOR DIRECTOR CYBERSECURITY
POLICY THE WHITE HOUSE AND BOTH
THE OBAMA AND TRUMP
ADMINISTRATIONS.
BUT A KEY ROLE IN SHAPING
PRESENT OBAMA CYBERSECURITY
NATIONAL ACTION PLAN IS ALSO THE
PRINCIPAL ARCHITECT.
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CYBERSECURITY EXECUTIVE ORDER
STRENGTHENING THE CYBERSECURITY
FEDERAL NETWORKS AND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE ALSO JOINING US
ON THIS PANEL IS MISS PAMELA
SMITH A SENIOR ADVISER TO
VERIFIED VOTING AN ORGANIZATION.
WHICH IS SERVED AS PRESIDENT FOR
TEN YEARS.
SHE PROVIDES INFORMATION.
ON VERIFIED VOTING ISSUES BOTH
TO US HOUSE REPRESENTATIVES.
ON HOUSE ADMINISTRATION AND
VARIOUS OTHER BODIES SHOULD
AUTHOR OF.
A SEVERAL A KEY PUBLICATIONS ON
ELECTION SECURITY AND IS ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA LECTIONIS NETWORK AND
MEMBER OF THE TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTING'S. VOTING SOLUTIONS FOR
ALL PEOPLE PROJECT THAT
REGISTRAR LOGIN JUST.
MENTION SO THANK YOU BOTH FOR
GOING AND I WILL LET YOU HAVE IT
OUT AS TO WHO GOES FIRST.
.
PLEASE MR GRETA WELCOME GREAT
WELL I THINK YOU CHAIRMAN STERN
AND CHAIRMAN BERMAN FOR FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY AND THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR.
YOUR TIME ATTENTION THIS
MORNING.
PRESERVING THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTORAL INFRASTRUCTUREIS
OBVIOUSLY VITAL TO ORGANIZE.
AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT AMERICAN
AND IS A NEW WE ARE RE REGISTER
CALIFORNIA VOTER FOR YOUR.
A FOCUS ON THIS TOPIC.
BUT NORMALLY INTEREST IN OUR
LIKE TOOL INFRASTRUCTURE P.
IN EVEN NUMBERED YEARS ONLY TO
FADE. ARE IN ODD NUMBERED YEARS
AS OUR ATTENTION AS A NATION.
TWO OTHER PRIORITIES.
THIS WAS THE CASE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HOWEVER.
AS RESOLVED IMPORTANT WORK DONE
BY ELECTION PROFESSIONALS CIVIL
SOCIETY AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGHOUT TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
I DO HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA AT
THIS POINT
AFTER WHAT CYBERSECURITY BEST
PRACTICES LOOK LIKE FOR
ELECTORAL AT FIRST.
THAT WASN'T THE CASE I THINK IN
TWO THOUSAND
TINA MY S..
SO I BELIEVE THAT THE KEY
QUESTION IS KEY CYBERSECURITY
QUESTIONS BUT TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ELECTION CYCLE.
NOT REVOLVE AROUND
IMPLEMENTATION.
AN INCIDENT RESPONSE INCLUDING
PUBLIC.
AND DO STATE LOCAL ELECTION
OFFICIALS HAVE SUFFICIENT
MANAGEMENT STAFF AND BUDGET
RESOURCES.
IMPLEMENT BEST PRACTICE.
AND ARE AND SINCE I INCIDENTS
CAN STILL HAPPEN EVEN WHEN.
ON BEST PRACTICES ARE
IMPLEMENTED PERFECTLY A. OUR
CONTINGENCY PLANS A CALIBRATED
FOR THE CHANCE
I HAD.
DO YOU RECEIVE A LOT INFORMATION
ALREADY THIS MORNING FROM OUR
STATE'S ELECTION PROFESSIONALS
ABOUT THEIR COGNIZANCE OF
SECRETARY BEST PRACTICES.
AND THE READING THAT SUCH
CONDUCT CYBERSECURITY ACTION
THIS FALL ON THE FOCUS WAS
UNDERSTANDABLY ON. A WHAT THESE
ELECTION PROFESSIONALS ARE DOING
TO ENSURE THAT ELECTION OUTCOMES
IN NOVEMBER REFLECT WILL THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE.
ABOUT WHAT I WANNA PRIMARILY
EMPHASIZE IN MY REPAIRED REMARKS
TODAY IS THE EQUALLY VITAL ROLE
THAT CANDIDATES FOR PUBLIC
OFFICE I MUST PLAY A HOLDING THE
PUBLIC'S CONFIDENCE IN OUR
ELECTORAL AT FIRST.
YOU TWO ARE THE FRONT LINES OF
COMBAT INSIDE RISKS TO
ELECTORAL.
A PROVIDES PERSPECTIVE AND SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW
CANDIDATES FOR OFFICE.
ATTRIBUTE OF THE FIGHT.
BUT FOR CONTEXT I BEGIN WITH A
BRIEF REMINDER OF THE THREAT OR
FACE NITTANY.
I IN JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IS IS AS YOU ALL KNOW
THE U. S. INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ISSUED AN UNCLASSIFIED REPORT ON
RUSSIA'S INTERFERENCE NO
ELECTION PROCESS AND I QUOTE. WE
ASSESSED WITH HIGH CONFIDENCE
THAT RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
ORDERING INFLUENCE CAMPAIGN IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN U. S.
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION THE
CONSISTENT GOALS OF WHICH WOULD
UNDERMINE PUBLIC FAITH IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
THEN IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR.
CIA DIRECTOR MIKE PAPALEO A
SAID HE EXPECTED RUSSIA TO
INTERFERE THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ELECTION. AS PART OF
THE KREMLIN'S STRATEGY TO QUOTE
UNDERMINE WESTERN DEMOCRACY.
HOW WILL THE KREMLIN ATTEMPTED?
THROUGH SO CALLED ACTIVE
MEASURES.
ACTIVE MEASURES IS THE ENGLISH
TERM FOR RUSSIA'S DOCTRINE OF
INFORMATION WARFARE
A COMBINED HACKING.
A WITH INFORMATION OPERATIONS
AND AND AND OTHER.
ACTIONS OUGHT TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF RUSSIA'S CAPABILITIES
IN THIS AREA.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
ACCORDING TO MEDIA REPORTS.
RUSSIA CONDUCTED.
INFILTRATION AGAINST.
UKRAINE'S CENTRAL ELECTION
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY DELETED FILES AND HEADS
AND AND ATTEMPT TO INSTALL
MALWARE THE WHAT CHANGED OUR
VOTES.
I IN SUPPORT OF ULTRA RIGHT WING
NATIONALIST PARTY.
THE WHO.
WHO SERVICE CONVENIENT FOIL FOR
RUSSIA'S?
IT A PROPAGANDA THAT
BUT UKRAINE SPA AND FASCISM.
UNFORTUNATELY. UKRAINE'S LOOKING
PROFESSIONALS DISCOVERED THIS
AND STOP HAPPY THAT DIDN'T STOP.
RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA AND ITS
OVERALL DISINFORMATION APPARATUS
IN SPREADING FALSE NARRATIVE
THAT IN FACT THESE ULTRA
NATIONALISTS.
.
THE EFFECT WAS TO SORT OUT
UKRAINE ABOUT INTEGRITY THEIR
ELECTION.
REGIONAL AND
GLOBAL.
AND ISSUED UNDER MY.
I THINGS EXPECT RUSSIA TO INUSE
ACTIVE MEASURES IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN I THINK.
THERE WERE MEASURES WILL BE
AIMED AT FEW FEEDING CORROSIVE
NARRATIVES ABOUT ELECTION FRAUD
ABOUT MILES TO POLLING PLACES
ABOUT LONG LINES AND OTHER
IRREGULARITIES
A BEFORE AND DURING ELECTION.
NOW NOTICE HOW THE SUCCESS OF
THE KREMLIN'S STRATEGY DOESN'T
NECESSARILY DEPEND ON ANY ACTUAL
HACKS IRREGULAR.
OF THE KREMLIN WINS BY SLOWING
DOWN.
I WISH YOU TO CUT IT WOULD
ACCOMPLISH
ABOUT MAKE IT HARD FOR US TO
DISCERN GROUND TRUTH
I TO SEPARATE FACT FROM TO
SUPERMAN.
DOUBT IS CORROSIVE TO.
THAT OBSERVATION TAKES ME THE
FIRST OF THE THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT WHAT WE.
GIVEN THIS THREAT IT IS VITAL
THAT ARE WATCHING PROFESSIONALS
PRACTICE THEIR CYBERSECURITY
INCIDENT RESPONSE PLANS BEFORE
NOVEMBER THROUGH THROUGH
EXERCISE.
I KNOW THE CONTINGENCY PLANNING
IS ALREADY PART THE DNA OF OUR
ELECTION PROFESSIONALS.
BUT IN THIS CONTEXT IT YOU KNOW
MY IN MY VIEW IS THAT IT NEEDS
TO FOCUS YET READY TO FOCUS ON
TWO GOALS ONE OBVIOUSLY MAKING
SURE THAT THAT THE ELECTION
RESULTS REFLECT WILL BE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. BUT ALSO
UPHOLDING CONFIDENCE IN THE
OUTCOME
IT'S POSSIBLE TO CERTIFY
ELECTION OUTCOME AND STILL LOSE
THE PUBLIC'S CONFIDENCE THAT THE
ELECTION HAPPENED.
BUT THE WAY THAT THAT.
WE WOULD EXPECT IT TO.
ARE THESE EXERCISES DON'T NEED
TO BE ALLOWED AFFAIRS UP DID YOU
NEED TO BE REPLACED ENOUGH TO
HELP OUR PROFESSIONALS TEST
OTHER TECHNICAL RESPONSE PLANS
AND VITALLY THE PUBLIC AFFAIRS.
ARE THESE EXERCISES WILL HELP
IDENTIFY AND RESOLVE PROBLEMS I
GENERAL MAIL THEM TO BUILD SOME
MUSCLE MEMORY AROUND HOW DOES
NOT RESPOND TO CYBERSECURITY
INCIDENTS REGARDLESS A
PERPETRATOR INCLUDING. ANY
ACTIVE MEASURES THEY MAY EMANATE
FROM.
THAT'S WHAT WAS RECOMMENDED.
MY SECOND RECOMMENDATION IS THAT
THOSE OF YOU RUNNING FOR
REELECTION DEVELOP YOUR OWN.
PLANS TO PURPORTED.
CYBER SCREENS.
THE TWITTER MEME ABOUT HACKED E.
POLL BOOKING OR DISTRICT STARTS
TO DEVELOP ON ELECTION DAY.
STORIES ABOUT VIOLENT PROTESTS
AT A POLLING PLACE SHOW UP IN
FACEBOOK NEWSFEEDS
HOW YOUR YOUR TEAM SPOT.
HOOSIER TEAM CALLED THE FIRST
INSTANCE FOR GROUND.
A WHAT DO DILLON IS APPROPRIATE
A BEFORE MAKING.
I SPENT MOST OF MY CAREER THE
INTERSECTION OF POLITICS AND
POLICY.
AND POST IT IN POLICY SO I FULLY
APPRECIATE THE RELENTLESS.
AT NEW CYCLE AND HOW INTENSE
CAMPAIGNS CAN BE A THAT SAID
DON'T ALLOW YOU YOUR CAMPAIGN TO
BE CAUGHT BY THE KREMLIN IS PART
OF AN ACTIVE.
MY ADVICE IS TO DEVELOP INSTANT
RESPONSE YOUR OWN INCIDENT
RESPONSE PLANS IN ADVANCE
PRACTICE.
IDEALLY DEVELOPMENT COORDINATION
WITH WITHOUT ELECTION OFFICIALS
WHO WHO ARE YOU FOR FROM TODAY
AND BY THE WAY TO MANAGE YOUR
OPPONENTS TO THE SAME.
BOB DON'T STOP THEIR POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS ARE ARE VITAL
ELECTORAL INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL
BY DIFFERENT OF COURSE THAN.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ADMINISTERED
BY STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BUT
IMPORTANT IN THE LAST.
I CAMPAIGNS MUST ALSO INFLUENCE
ARE RISKY BEST PRACTICES TO
PROTECT THEIR SYSTEMS AND IT
WILL COMPROMISE.
IT STARTS WITH CREATING A
CULTURE.
SECURITY AND AND BUILDING FROM
THERE.
WHAT CLOSE WITH A THIRD
RECOMMENDATION A TOPIC IT'S A
BIT MORE FUTURE ORIENTED BUT I
THINK I ACTION MUST BUS START
NOW?
PICKED UP ON SENATOR STEARNS
APPOINT A OPENING COMMENTS WHERE
HE DESCRIBED ELECTORAL SYSTEM AS
THE BONES OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
CIVIC DISCOURSE I WOULD ARGUE
IS THE SOLE.
AREN'T WE PARTY SCENE THE TOXIC
IMPACT THE FAKE NEWS CAN HAVE.
AND THE FORM OF DOCTORED PHOTOS
AND MEET UP TAXED
ON OUR CIVIL DISORDER CIVIC.
OF MY STAFF RECALL THE DAMPENING
AYE DOCUMENT FORTHCOMING PAPER
WHAT'S COMING NEXT IS FAKE VIDEO
A SO CALLED DEEP FAKES ARE THAT
USE MACHINE LEARNING
TECHNOLOGIES TO GENERATE SPOOKED
VIDEOS.
BUT THESE VIDEOS CAN DEPICT A
PERSON SAYING AND DOING WHAT
EVER THE AUTHOR THE VIDEO
DOESN'T DESIRES WITH POTENTIALLY
BREATHTAKING REALISM.
BUT YOU MAY SEE SOME EXAMPLES OF
DEEP FIX ALREADY OTHER ALREADY
IMPRESSIVELY PERSUASIVE AND SOON
IT WILL BE VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
DISTINGUISHED FAKE VIDEO FROM A
REAL ONE.
OTHER MANY MOST APPLICATIONS OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY BUT WE'RE
ESPECIALLY CONCERNED BUT MISUSED
IN ELECTION CAMPAIGNS TO MAKE IT
EVEN HARDER FOR AMERICANS TO
SEPARATE FACT WITH APPLICATION.
AND LEARN TRUTHS ABOUT
CANDIDATES AND ISSUES.
NOW COMPANIES SUCH AS FACEBOOK
AND TWITTER HAVE A SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO PREVENT THE
PLATFORMS I'M FOR BEING ABUSED
SPREAD ALMOST STEEP TAKES WHICH
HOLDEN TO A HIGH STANDARD.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT THERE IS
KNOW TECHNOLOGICAL OR REGULATORY
SO REPORT.
WE MUST ALSO LOOK TO THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO RUN FOR OFFICE HOLD
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS IN OUR
POLITICAL INSTITUTE
IT'S FOR LEADERSHIP.
THE RISK OF THE RISK OF MISUSE
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY.
IN AN ELECTORAL CONTEXT IS AS
MUCH A FUNCTION OF WHAT OUR
POLITICAL LEADERS CONSIDER TO BE
APPROPRIATE NORMS
BEHAVIOR.
AS IT IS A FUNCTION OF WHAT
TECHNOLOGY CAN DO.
BOB PUT DIFFERENTLY EXCLUSIVE
FOCUS ON TECHNOLOGICAL TOOLS
IGNORES THE KEY ROLE THE
CANDIDATES FOR.
AND THEY'RE FOR ALLIES PLAY IN
SETTING ENFORCING A BREAKING OF
CONDUCT IN OUR POLITICAL
DISCOURSE CANDIDATES NEED TO
JOIN THE FIGHT.
A FOR THAT REASON I BELIEVE AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF MANAGING THE
RISK THAT THIS TECHNOLOGY POSES
TOWARD DEMOCRACY IS FOR LEADERS
TO ESTABLISH A CLEAR NORMAL
RESTRAINT.
AROUND
I WHICH LEADS TO MY THIRD AND
FINAL RECOMMENDATION.
CANDIDATES IN THE FORMAL
CAMPAIGN INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING THE NATIONAL POLITICAL
PARTIES SHOULD MUTUALLY AGREED
TO NOT PRODUCE PROMOTER
OTHERWISE DISTRIBUTE A FAKE
VIDEO.
TO PICKING A PERSON WITHOUT THAT
PERSON.
OUR THEY SHOULD ALSO SENT A
CLEAR MESSAGE THEIR ALLIES AND
PROXIES THAT THEY SHOULD OUT OF
USES TECHNOLOGY EITHER AND
ENERGETICALLY CALL UP GROUPS
IT FIGHTS.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY PREPARED
REMARKS I LOOK FORWARD YEAR OF
QUESTIONS I HOPE WE CAN HAVE A
WIDE RANGING HALF.
FIGURE MUCH CHRIS SMITH. THANK
YOU.
A CHAIRED BERMAN CHAIR STERN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME.
TODAY I'M HONORED BY THAT. IN
MY APACITY IT VERIFIED VOTING
I'VE WORKED WITH ADVOCATES AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS ON LAWMAKERS
FROM ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND
I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHEN YOU
EVALUATE HOW STATES ARE DOING ON
METRICS THAT RELATE TO SECURITY
SOME DO BETTER THAN OTHERS. AND
THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT
AND THE ONES THAT EMBRACE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE ARE THE
ONES THAT DO THE BEST.
SO THEREFORE I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THIS CHANCE TO SHARE ON THIS
TOPIC AND THAT YOU'RE HAVING
THIS HEARING.
AND BY THE WAY I TOLD MATT
MASTERSON NOT TO TAKE ALL MY
BEST LINES BUT I THINK YOU CAN
LISTEN SO YOU MAY HEAR.
SOMETHING ECHOED IN WHAT I SAY
I'M JUST A FRAME UP YOU KNOW I
LOOK AT SECURITY AT ALL SECURITY
ELECTIONS THROUGH THE FILTER OF
HOW WILL THIS AFFECT.
THE ABILITY OF VOTERS TO CAST AN
EFFECTIVE BALLOT.
AND EFFECTIVE BALLOT THE IN THE
BALLOTS AVAILABLE TO THEM
THEY'RE NOT TRIPPED UP BY A
FAILED ELECTRONIC PULL BOOKER
TAMPERED REGISTRATION LIST THAT
THEY GET THE CORRECT BALLOT IT'S
PRESENTED COMPLETED IT'S
FEASIBLE TO MARK.
CHECK VERIFY CAST IT SAFELY AND
PRIVATELY AND THAT IT'S COUNTED
CORRECTLY ALONG WITH ALL THE
OTHER BALLOTS.
AND THAT WE CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT
FACT.
TO THE SATISFACTION OF THE
PUBLIC INCLUDING THOSE ON THE
SIDE OF LOSING CANDIDATES OR
ISSUES.
VOTERS NEED TO KNOW THAT
ELECTIONS ARE WORKING THE WAY
THAT THEY SHOULD OR ELSE THEY
WON'T HAVE CONFIDENCE TO ENGAGE
IN NOTHING SADDER THAN THROWING
A PARTY AND NOBODY SHOWS UP SO.
THERE OBSTACLES TO VOTING OF
MANY KINDS THERE ARE MANY GROUPS
THAT WORK HARD TO REMOVE SOME OF
THOSE OBSTACLES AND HELP VOTERS
ENGAGE INCLUDING OUR FRONTLINE
OF THE ELECTION OFFICIAL
COMMUNITY.
BY ENSURING THAT VOTERS KNOW
WE'RE TAKING ALL POSSIBLE STEPS
ON SECURITY WE'RE REMOVING THE
OBSTACLE OF LACK OF CONFIDENCE.
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT
SECOND THING TO EMPHASIZE IN
CYBERSECURITY ISSUES IN
PARTICULAR PREVENTION AND
DETECTION OF TAMPERING IN BREACH
IS REALLY IMPORTANT BUT FOR
ELECTION OUTCOMES AND ENSURING
THAT.
THE VOTERS WHO SHOW UP CAN CAST
AN EFFECTIVE BALLOT WHAT'S
CRITICAL IS THE ABILITY TO
RECOVER.
BOTH REAL TIME AFTER THE FACT AS
COMMISSIONER MASTERSON
REFERENCED EVEN IF THERE IS A
BREACH EVEN IF THERE WAS
TAMPERING.
EVEN IF SOME SYSTEMS FAILED OR
CAUSE TO FAIL ON ELECTION DAY
THAT PEOPLE CAN STILL VOTE. AND
THAT THEIR VOTES ARE STILL
COUNTED CORRECTLY.
WE GO TO ELECTIONS WITH THE
SYSTEMS WE HAVE THEIR ELECTIONS
ALL THE TIME THEY'RE ALL
IMPORTANT NEW STANDARDS THAT WE
SAT.
THOUGH GOOD ARE NOT
RETROACTIVELY APPLIED
SO WE HAVE TO HAVE STRATEGIES
FOR RECOVERY NO MATTER WHAT.
AND SECURITY IS NOT AN ON OFF
YES NO THING ITS LAYERS.
THERE'S ALWAYS ANOTHER
VULNERABILITY TO BE FOUND.
AND IF WE SAY OUR SYSTEMS ARE
SECURE IT'S A LITTLE BIT LIKE
PAINTING A TARGET ON YOUR BACK.
.
INCREMENTAL SECURITY MEASURES
CAN HARDEN TO MAKE A SYSTEM MORE
SECURE THAN IT WAS BEFORE AND WE
SHOULD TAKE THOSE MEASURES.
WE SHOULD MAKE IT EASY FOR
TAMPERING TO OCCUR.
BUT WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THE INCREASINGLY SAVVY PUBLIC
ALREADY KNOWS THAT THERE'S NO
SUCH THING AS TAMPER PROOF.
BUT WE CAN SAY WE TAKE THE STEPS
TO ENSURE THAT NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THE ACCURACY THE
OUTCOME. AND THAT EVERYBODY WHO
WANT TO PARTICIPATE WAS ABLE TO
DO SO.
IT'S NOT PERFECTION IT'S
DILIGENCE.
IN THAT LIGHT I WOULD SAY
THERE'S A NUMBER OF THINGS
CALIFORNIA DOES WELL AND HAS
DONE WELL OVER TIME.
COMPARING WITH ALL THE STATE'S
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE A PRETTY
GOOD JOB OF LIFTING UP THE ISSUE
OF SECURITY.
WE'VE BEEN A LEADER IN THIS
SPACE AND I THINK WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO LEAD. OUR
SECRETARIES OF STATE OVER A
NUMBER OF.
ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE DONE
THINGS LIKE REQUIRING AUDITABLE
SYSTEMS REQUIRING BACKUP PAPER
BALLOTS CALLING FOR AUDITABLE. A
SYSTEMS BEFORE MOST OF THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY OF VOLUME TESTING
FOR CERTIFICATION NEW AND
IMPROVED CERTIFICATION.
TOP TO BOTTOM REVIEW OF VOTING
SYSTEMS INCLUDING ON
ACCESSIBILITY INCLUDING A
PARALLEL EFFORT A TASK FORCE ON
POST ELECTION AUDITING WHICH.
RECOMMENDED.
RESPONDING AUDITS.
.
WE'VE DONE SO MANY THINGS THAT
HAVE REALLY HELPED TO THEN MAKE
IT POSSIBLE FOR COUNTIES LIKE LA
AND. SAN FRANCISCO DID STEP UP
AND DEVELOP. MORE SECURE SYSTEMS
THAT MEET TODAY'S VOTERS NEEDS.
THEN WE'VE PILOTED THE AT RISK
LIMITING AUDITS IN A NUMBER OF
COUNTY STARTING BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN.
.
WE ALSO A PROHIBIT A CONNECTION
TO THE INTERNET WITH ONE NOTABLE
EXCEPTION THE FAX RETURN A VOTED
BALLOTS. OF FOR SOME VOTERS AND
I THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY OF ALL
CALIFORNIA HAS UNDERSTOOD OVER
THE YEARS BETTER THAN A NUMBER
OF OTHER STATES THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO LET THE PUBLIC
OBSERVE ALL PHASES OF THE
ELECTION PROCESS THAT THAT'S A.
MAJOR TRUST BUILDER.
.
WHAT CAN CALIFORNIA DO BETTER?
IT'S BEEN TOUCHED ON BETTER
AUDITING.
.
RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT
SOUND AUDITS WHICH THE PUBLIC
CAN OBSERVE HAVE A POSITIVE
EFFECT ON VOTER CONFIDENCE BUT
WE NEED TO PROVIDE MUCH MORE
AUTHORITATIVE CONFIRMATION.
ABOUT THE CORRECTNESS IN THE OF
THE VOTE ESPECIALLY IN TODAY'S
ENVIRONMENT.
PUT ANOTHER WAY WE SHOULD REDUCE
THE RISK OF CONFIRMING AN
INCORRECT DOT COM SO THAT'S WHAT
RISK RUINING AUDITS ARE ALL
ABOUT.
.
AND I DON'T THINK EVERYONE WILL
AGREE BUT THE RECENT CHANGES
THROUGH AB EIGHT FORTY TO THE
ONE PERCENT MANUAL TALLY HAVE
FURTHER WEAKENED IT.
IT CAN STILL ACCOMPLISH SOME
USEFUL THINGS BUT IT DOESN'T
CONFIRM ELECTION OUTCOMES ARE
CORRECT.
OF COURSE IT DOESN'T LIVE BY
ITSELF AS THE ONLY MEANS FOR
CHECKING AS GIL PELERIN
REFERENCED WE HAVE RELATIVELY
EASY TO OBTAIN RECOUNTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH ARE ALSO OBSERVE.
NONE THE LESS EFFORTS ARE
UNDERWAY TO ADOPT RISK LIVING
GODDESS IN CALIFORNIA AND.
THOSE EFFORTS CAN'T HAPPEN SOON
ENOUGH
WE'RE WE HAVE CHALLENGES WITH
OLDER EQUIPMENT THAT MAYBE
DOESN'T LEND ITSELF TO GRANULAR
BALLOT LEVEL VERY EFFICIENT RISK
LIMITING AUDITS WE CAN DO
SOMETHING CALLED BALLOT POLLING
AUDITS IT'S ANOTHER KIND. OF
RISK LIMITING AUDIT.
AND.
THAT CAN BE DONE WITH COUNTIES
A CROSS COUNTY BORDER CONTESTS.
AND STATEWIDE CONTESTS WITH
RELATIVELY LITTLE EFFORT.
WHERE QUITMAN PERMITS OR AS WE
ADOPT NEW EQUIPMENT THAT DOES
PERMIT WE SHOULD DEFINITELY DO
FULL RISK LIMITING AUDITS AND I
AGREE WITH MILT KELLY ON THE
SUGGESTED TO AUDIT VOTER
REGISTRATION DATA BASES AS WELL?
THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION I
WOULD HAVE WOULD BE TO LIMIT OR
EVEN ELIMINATE ELECTRONIC RETURN
OF VOTED BALLOTS WE HAVE TO
BETTER SERVE OUR MILITARY AND
OVERSEAS VOTERS PRIVACY AND
SECURITY.
AND WHILE WE LIMIT OUR
ELECTRONIC RETURN IN THIS STATE
TO FAX MOST FAXES DONE OVER THE
INTERNET TODAY. AND HAS THE SAME
VULNERABILITIES AS OTHER KINDS
OF ELECTRONIC RETURN MATH IT'S
IT'S A BIG TARGET.
WE COULD POTENTIALLY ADD MORE
TIME FOR LATE ARRIVING MILITARY
BALLOTS AND EXPAND THE USE OF
TRACKING EXPRESSED LABELS AND
OTHER. UP PRACTICES LIKE THAT
THE THIRD THING AND I THINK.
WE'VE WE'VE SORT OF BEEN.
DANCING AROUND THE EDGES OF THIS
BUT I THINK WE SHOULD FORM
ELECTION SECURITY ADVISORY
COUNCIL.
SIMILAR TO THE LANGUAGE ACCESS
ADVISORY COUNCIL OR THE VOTING
ACCESSIBILITY ADVISORY COUNCILS
THAT EXIST A SOUNDING BOARD OF
TALENTED EXPERTS FROM OUR MANY
UNIVERSITIES AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGY HUBS.
SECRETARY PRETTY A MATCH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND OTHERS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO CAN HELP
BOLSTER THE INSIDE TALENT THAT
ALREADY EXISTS AT THE OFFICE OF
THE SECRETARY AND AND AMONG THE
COUNTIES.
IT SPEAKS TO WHAT NEIL KELLY
SAID ABOUT USING ACADEMICS AS
THIRD PARTY VALIDATORS AND
RESOURCES AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. OF THE EFFORTS OF THE
STATE TO SPONSOR CYBERSECURITY
TRAINING FOR COUNTIES AND WE
WOULD SUPPORT GATHERINGS OF THE
COUNTY'S IT EXPERTS FOR EXAMPLE
THAT ARE ALREADY WORKING IN THE
COUNTY SO THAT THEY CAN. SHARE
THEIR BEST PRACTICES AND
INSIGHTS MORE READILY.
ALONG THESE LINES LOS ANGELES
HAS HAD A TECHNICAL ADVISER
GROUP.
INVOLVED IN THE DEVELOPMENT F
THEIR NEW VOTING SYSTEM FROM THE
BEGINNING A PROCESS AND IT'S
BEEN REALLY WORTHWHILE OR ELSE
DEAN WOULD HAVE DID STE
DISBANDED US ALREADY.
.
AND I WOULD ADD THAT COLORADO'S
RISK LOOT RISK LIMITING AUDIT
IMPLEMENTATION WAS SUCCESSFUL IN
NO SMALL PART BECAUSE OF A.
SLIGHTLY ON SONG BUT TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF EFFORT AND
COLLABORATION THAT WENT INTO
HAMMERING OUT ALL THE DETAILS OF
PROTOCOLS OF HOW TO DO IT.
AT A VERY GRANULAR LEVEL
THOUSANDS OF PERSON HOURS WERE
DONATED.
TO THAT EFFORT AND MADE IT ARE
MUCH MORE FEASIBLE AND
SUCCESSFUL.
.
AT LEAST ONE OF THE EXPERTS WHO
VOLUNTEERED REALLY SIGNIFICANT
EFFORT OF IS THE NATION'S
LEADING EXPERT ON AUDITING LIVES
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WE CAN DO THIS.
AND I THINK MY FOURTH
RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE IT'S
PROBABLY NOW UP BY NOW KIND OF
OBVIOUS BUT I'LL SAY IT HIGHER
MATT MASTERSON.
A NO I MEAN FULL FUNDING FOR
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO BE ABLE TO
DO WHAT THEY NEED TO SAFEGUARD
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
INTEGRITY OF THE VOTE. AND THE
VOTER REGISTRATION ROLLS FUNDING
FOR ELECTION MANDATES NEEDS TO
BE RESTORED IN THE STATE BUDGET
SUCH THAT THE STATE IS A PARTNER
TO THE COUNTIES AS THE SECRETARY
SAID.
I'LL CLOSE BY SAYING THERE'S
REALLY BEEN A SEA CHANGE IN
THINKING ON ELECTION SECURITY.
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE OVERT
ATTACKS ON OUR DEMOCRACY AND
WE'RE EVEN USING A WHOLE NEW
LANGUAGE OR VOCABULARY ON
CYBERSECURITY TODAY. WE'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT LEAPS FORWARD IN
LEARNING AND BEST PRACTICES FOR
HOW TO ADDRESS WHAT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN A THREAT BUT IS NOW NO
LONGER THEORETICAL IN NATURE.
I MORE THAN GRATIFIED THAT THIS
HEARING HAS BEEN HELD TODAY AND
TO HAVE BEEN A PART OF IT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS.
I JUST A COUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS
ONE.
WHICH MEANS TONY GO WITH.
NOW WITH THIS ONE AND FROM IS
SMITH FOR SOLVE THANK YOU BOTH
OF FOR PARTICIPATING TODAY
REALLY APPRECIATE IT OBVIOUSLY
FOR. ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE OVER OVER MANY YEARS ON
THIS ISSUE WHICH IS A MORE
IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER. NOT AT
TIMES THERE ARE TRADE OFFS
BETWEEN LOOKING SECURITY AND
ELECTION ACCESSIBILITY.
FOR EXAMPLE MAKING IT POSSIBLE
FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE IN AND YOU
ALLUDED TO THIS.
MAKING IT POSSIBLE FOR YOUR
VOTE OVER THE INTERNET CAN BE
GREAT FOR ELECTION ACCESSIBILITY
BOARD HAVE VERY A LARGE AND THEN
POSSIBLY INSURMOUNTABLE SECURITY
CHALLENGES.
AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN INVOLVED
IN ADVOCACY IN THIS POLICY AREA
FOR A LONG TIME.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DO YOU HAVE ANY
SUGGESTIONS FOR HOW TO NAVIGATE
THOSE TYPES OF TRADE OFFS
BETWEEN ACCESSIBILITY AND
SECURITY.
I IN ALLOCATION SYSTEMS.
WELL I THINK THEIR FIRST THING
TO DO IS TO.
NOT THINK THAT WE CAN'T HAVE IT
ALL.
YOU KNOW THE THE PROCESS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HAS BEEN A
CONSTANT.
.
OPEN DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THE
ISSUES ARE
AND HOW DO WE RESOLVE THEM SO
THAT WE HAVE MAXIMUM
ACCESSIBILITY AND A SECURE
SYSTEM AND I THINK THAT. A.
YOU KNOW KNOCK WOOD BUT IF
EVERYTHING GOES WELL THAT'S WHAT
YOU'LL SEE ME.
I WAS A VERY PLEASED TO WORK ON
A PROJECT WITH THE CENTER FOR
CIVIC DESIGN AND OTHERS.
ON RISK ON REMOTE ACCESSIBLE
BALLOT MARKETING.
YOU KNOW PARTICULARLY WITH
RESPECT TO MARKING OR CASTING
BALLOTS OVER THE INTERNET THIS
HAS BEEN AN ISSUE HOW DO YOU
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM IT IT CAN
BRING BENEFITS BECAUSE OF HOW
THE TECHNOLOGY.
IT BECAUSE OF ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY THAT VOTERS MAY HAVE
IN THEIR OWN HOMES.
AND THAT CAN FACILITATE THE
PROCESS GREATLY.
BUT ISN'T IT.
POSSIBLE THAT WE CAN DO THAT
WITHOUT HAVING TO EXPOSE THOSE
THAT THE VOTERS PRIVACY AND THE
SECURITY OF THEIR CHOICES. AND
SO WE WORKED ON THAT AND I'M
REALLY GRATIFIED TO SAY THAT THE
PRINCIPLES AND BEST PRACTICES
THAT WE CAME UP WITH IN
COLLABORATION WITH. NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF THE BLIND AND MANY
OTHER ADVOCATES.
WERE UP PUT FORWARD TO.
THE TGC AND.
BY NO STE AND.
HAVE ESSENTIALLY BEEN ADOPTED
IN CALIFORNIA AS PART OF HOW WE
DO REMOTE ACCESS WILL BALLOT
MARKING FOR US BEFORE FIFTY.
SO IT CAN BE DONE AND I THINK
YOU KNOW WE WE MAY GET THERE WE
MIGHT NOT GET THERE IN MY
LIFETIME AS FAR AS INTERNET
VOTING IS CONCERNED. BUT WHAT'S
IMPORTANT IS WE CAN DO THINGS
TODAY.
THAT THAT GIVE US BOTH OR IS AS
MUCH A BOTH AS WE CAN HAVE.
THANK YOU.
I HAD A BRIEF JUST A BRIEF BUT
NOT ON THAT WHICH I THINK IT YOU
KNOW THAT TO ME SECURITY ENABLES
ACCESSIBILITY RIGHT.
I THINK VIEW LOOKING AT THAT
THAT THAT THAT THE ISSUE FROM
THAT PROSPECTIVE I THINK GETS
IT.
DOT GETS THE POINT THAT WE
REALLY SHOULD BE ABLE TO.
PEOPLE GET.
THANK YOU.
AND MISTER GRASSO.
.
OR THIS ONE YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A
HIGH LEVEL ROLES DOING WHATEVER
SECURITY ISSUES IN BOTH THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DESIGNATION OF ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE. AS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS MADE IN THE
LAST FEW DAYS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND THAT WAS
SUBSEQUENTLY REAFFIRMED BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN HOW THE
DESIGNATION WILL AID IN
IMPROVING ELECTION IN FOR
SECTION INFRASTRUCTURE SECURITY.
AND YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHETHER
THE COMMITMENT TO THE
DESIGNATION HAS CHANGED AT ALL
WITH A CHANGE IN ADMINISTRATION.
YEAH I THINK MATT MASTERSON'S
COMMENTS RESPOND.
YOU KNOW AND AND SOME OF THE
OTHER ELECTION PROFESSIONALS
THAT THAT THE DHS IS REALLY
COMMITTED TO.
MAKING SURE THAT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
AVAILABLE AS A RESOURCE
FOR ELECTION OFFICIALS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU A DAY IN AND
MATT MENTIONED I THINK.
YET THAT THE BENEFITS FROM
INFORMATION SHARING PROSPECTIVE
OF OF A CRITICAL DISTRICT
DESIGNATION I WOULD ADD. ANOTHER
ONE WHICH IS THAT YOU KNOW.
DESIGNATING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE%
IS CRITICAL SENDS A SIGNAL TO.
BOTH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS THAT WOULD
SEEK TO.
HOLD US AT RISK THAT.
WE ATTACH HIGH INSIGNIFICANCE.
IT.
PUTS US IN A POSITION TO
POTENTIALLY ENACT SANCTIONS ON.
CERTAIN WISHES ACTORS UNDER
OTHER TREASURE DEPARTMENTS THAT
OFFERS ONE ASKS CONTROL OCTOPUS
SANCTIONS AUTHORITY. BOMBS A
DESERT THERE'S A THERE'S A
STRATEGIC.
FOREIGN POLICY NATIONAL
SECURITY OVERLY TO THIS IS.
THANK YOU.
ONE LAST QUESTION LAST YEAR'S
EVERY UNIVERSITY HAS ITS THIRD
ANNUAL CYBER BOOT CAMP. UP FOR
CONGRESSIONAL STAFFERS AS YOU TO
STANFORD UNIVERSITY FROM THE
TWENTY FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
A JUST THING AND THAT.
JUST. AND PROGRESS NOT THEY
NEVER LET ME AND BUT YOU KNOW
I'LL ADD THAT VERIFIED VOTING
WAS FOUNDED BY PROFESSOR FROM
STANFORD ALL THERE YOU GO.
IS IT IS A LOVE FEST TWENTY
FOUR THEY LOVE. YET.
ANYBODY CAL TOO SO YEAH.
SOME OF THE TOPICS DISCUSSED AT
THAT BOOT CAMP WERE WIDE
OFFENSES HARDER THAN CYBER
OFFENSE AND THE DIFFICULTIES OF
APPLYING EXISTING LA TO
ACCELERATING TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS
ON THE WE STRUGGLE WITH
EVERYDAY.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THOSE
PRINCIPLES WITH RESPECT TO
ELECTION SECURITY YEAH I THINK
YOU KNOW THAT I THINK IT I MEAN
THAT THE CHALLENGE THAT. ARE
LIKE PROFESSIONALS HAVE TO FACE
IS IMAGINE IS A PHYSICAL WORLD
NOW TO TRY TO MAKE THIS WORKS
OBSERVE BEAR WITH ME HERE MATH
TEST TESTS ON YOU GUYS.
SO IMAGINE.
YOU KNOW A THAT INSTEAD OF
DEFENDING VOTING SYSTEMS BY
THIRD WERE WERE DEFENDING A A
STEEP. RIGHT.
AND YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE JUST BASED ON.
THE RATE OF OWN ABILITIES AND
SOFTWARE AND JUST YOU KNOW HUMAN
ERROR. WHICH IS A MUCH STIPULATE
THAT THERE ARE WE KNOW THERE ARE
TEN WAYS IN.
TO THE STATE.
RIGHT.
.
DON'T OF THE DEFENDERS JOB IS
TO.
DISCOVER AND PATCH
ALL TEN OF THOSE ROUTES IN.
THE I PERSONALLY ONLY TO FIND
ONE OF THEM WHAT THE ODDS OF THE
DEFENDER FINDING THE EXACT SAME.
WAY IN.
THAT THE DEFENDER DISCOVERS
FIRST IT'S ACTUALLY QUITE QUITE
QUITE SMALL WHO DOES IT
ASYMMETRY.
YOU KNOW.
THREAT HERE I'M THE AND THAT
THAT'S WHY THIS IS A HARD
CHALLENGE BOTH BOTH FOR A
LECTURE PROFESSIONALS BUT INSIDE
I FEEL GENERALLY.
ARMED. THE ON ON YOUR ON YOUR
YOUR YOUR BROADER QUESTION
ABOUT.
BECAUSE WHAT HE SAID.
TRY TO KEEP LAW TO KEEP LAWS AND
POLICIES UP WITH WITH.
TECHNOLOGY AND AND AND YOU'VE
ALL THE LANDSCAPE.
YOU I MEAN YOU KNOW WASHINGTON
MOVES SLOWLY A HUMANS.
MOVE SLOWLY RIGHT I MEAN THE
THESE ARE REALLY COMPLEX
CHALLENGES ARE ROOTED IN SOME
PRETTY COMPLICATED TECHNOLOGIES.
WITH.
NUMEROUS EQUITIES AT STAKE
OFTEN EQUITIES THAT OUR
INTENTION WITH EACH OTHER SO.
YOU KNOW I'M IN YOU KNOW IN MY
FORMER JOB RIGHT AND WE ARE
CONSTANTLY TRYING TO BALANCE.
SENATE ECONOMIC EQUITIES AROUND
IN YOUR ENSURING THAT UNITED
STATES THAT PRESERVES ITS
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN INNOVATION.
UP WITH.
THREATS THAT MIGHT REQUIRE
REGULATION AND THERE'S A TRADE
OFF THEIR
AND THAT'S JUST REALLY HARD
HARD.
THAT QUESTION TO GET AT ARM YOU
KNOW ANOTHER ANOTHER.
AREA RIGHT REALLY SAW THIS PLAY
OUT WAS IN FEDERAL IT WHICH IS
PART MY RESPONSIBILITY.
AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
.
SUBSTANTIVE FEDERAL IT. AND YOU
KNOW I I THINK THAT YOU KNOW.
WE IS A AS A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE OF THE NUMBER STE JUST BEGIN
TO CHANGE OVER THE YEARS BUT YOU
KNOW WE WE SPENT SOMETHING LIKE.
.
EIGHTY PERCENT OF OUR IT BUDGET
ON OPERATIONS AND MAKE.
SUPPOSED CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
WHICH IS SWITCHES OFF BY ABOUT
YOU TEN PERCENT APPEARED THE
PRIVACY.
AND I I WOULD I WOULD I WOULD
BET THAT ARE ARE ARE BACK
COLLEAGUES.
AT THE STATE COUNTY WILL HAVE
SIMILAR CHALLENGE WHERE.
THE MONEY COMES IN FOR IT YOU
KNOW WHERE WHERE THEY WORK WHERE
THE MONEY FOR. YOU KNOW CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS COMES IN THESE KIND
OF SPURTS AND MEANWHILE. THERE
I'M SPEND MORE AND MORE MONEY I
JUST MEAN TEEN THE EVEN SYSTEMS.
THEY HAVE
ARM YOU KNOW WE'D THAT THERE'S A
PRETTY INNOVATIVE IDEAS OUT
THERE FOR HOW TO CRACK THIS NOT.
.
YOU KNOW WE AGAIN YOU AT THE END
OF THE ABOUT ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED ON THE NINETEEN
MODERNIZATION FIND.
CONGRESSMAN HEARD A REPUBLICAN
TEXAS PICK THIS IDEA UP THE LAST
CONGRESS AND UP.
IN IN IN THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION ACT THE IDEA THERE
IS THAT.
AGENCIES CAN ESSENTIALLY.
THEY THEY SUBMIT APPLICATIONS
FOR PROJECTS TO MODERNIZE RIGHTY
AND ENABLE THEM BORROW MONEY ON
THIS FUND THAT HAVE TO REPAY
BACK OVER TIME.
USING THE SAVINGS THAT THEY
ACQUIRE FROM
FROM HAVING UPDATED THEIR
SYSTEMS NOT HAVING TO DEAL WITH
THAT THE LEGACY.
.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S ALL I GOT GESTURE PREP.
.
THROW A FEW MORE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU GUYS BEFORE WE WRAP UP HERE.
.
NEW THREATS THAT WE DIDN'T SEE
LAST CYCLE.
IF YOU'RE IN YOUR CRYSTAL BALL
TRYING TO THINK THROUGH THE MIND
OF THE.
ATTACKER VERSUS THE DEFENDER AND
PICKING ONE OF THOSE TEN EXITS
MEAN WHAT.
WHAT NEW STUFF FOR THEY GOING TO
BE THROWING AT US THAT WE HAVE
AND THAT WE DIDN'T SEE LAST
TIME?
SO YEAH IT'S ALWAYS YOU KNOW IT
WAS DANGEROUS TO PUT THE FUTURE
BUT NOW THAT I'M AN ACADEMIC NOT
SPEAKING FOR THE GOVERNMENT I
FEEL LIBERATED SO I WILL I WILL
TELL.
.
YES AYE I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
ONE REALLY IMPORTANT DIFFERENCE.
THIS UPCOMING ELECTION
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ELECTIONS
AT THE TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN
ELECTION WAS FUNDAMENTALLY A
NATIONAL ELECTION RIGHT.
IF YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT WHAT.
WITH THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
WROTE IN THE RUN CLASSIFIED.
REPORT FROM JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND SO
TEEN.
THE RUSSIANS FOCUS WAS ON
NATIONAL PUBLIC.
AND THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IT'S IT'S
A MORE DIFFUSE.
AND MORE REGIONAL.
MORE REGIONAL ELECTION AND.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT CONCERNS ME
IS THAT YOU KNOW WITH THE HOUSE
A POTENTIALLY IN PLAY ACCORDING
TO US TO SOME POLITICAL
ANALYSTS.
AND WITH YOU KNOW HUGE STAKES
AHEAD FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS IN STATE.
RACES.
THAT YOU KNOW.
I WAS FIGHTING.
YOU KNOW USEFUL PARA PERMIT EVIL
GENIUS HAD ON.
YOU KNOW THAT YOU KNOW.
REDIRECTING ENERGY AT STATE AND
LOCAL RACES ARE BOTH OF THE.
CONGRESSIONAL LEVEL BUT ALSO AT
THE STATE HOUSE AND STATE
POLITICAL LEVEL.
YOU KNOW IF THE IF THE GOAL IS
TO SOW CHAOS RIGHT.
THAT'S A PRETTY ATTRACTIVE
TARGET FOR FOR FOREIGN ADVERSARY
AND SO DO YOU THINK THOSE CLOSER
TO SMALLER LESS SOPHISTICATED
JURISDICTION'S OUR OUR REPORT
POTENTIALLY THAT THAT MORE IDEAL
TYPE IF YOU'RE ABLE TO HIT.
SO THERE'S.
A TO GO KEEP GOING BACK YOUR
STADIUM BUT THERE'S ONE BIG EXIT
RIGHT CALL THAT THE ORANGE
COUNTY YOU'RE THE LA COUNTY YOUR
YOU KNOW.
SOMEWHERE ON YOU KNOW.
ON THE EAST COAST SOME.
WHEN THESE HUGE VOTING PRECINCTS
VERSES.
A LOT OF LITTLE SMALL
PENETRATIONS THAT SORT OF
COLLECTIVELY SO THAT THIS COURT
I MEAN.
DOES THAT MEAN.
THAT
YES SO STERN YOU YET SO YOU KNOW
I I MEAN I YOU KNOW.
I THINK IT'S IT'S
SOME UNREALISTIC AND UNFAIR TO
EXPECT A LOCAL ARE COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICIAL TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES AGAINST.
THE RUSSIAN RUSSIAN MILITARY
INTELLIGENCE THAT IS NOT A FAIR.
I MEAN IF IF RUSSIAN MILITARY
DILIGENCE WANTS TO METAL.
THE ODDS ARE ON THEIR SIDE THAT
THEY WILL SUCCEED SOMEWHERE
ANOTHER.
THIS IS MY EMPHASIZED INCIDENT
RESPONSE.
OCCASIONS IN MY REMARKS.
I AM WE HAVE TO REPAIR FOR THE
POSSIBILITY.
THAT.
THERE'S INCIDENT.
AND.
YOU KNOW REAL OR FABRICATE.
AND ENSURE THAT DEBT THAT THERE
ARE ELECTION PROFESSIONALS THAT
ARE THAT THE CANDIDATES THAT THE
MEDIA ARE IN A POSITION TO.
PORT.
ACCURATE FACTS HAVE YOU SEEN
THAT DONE WELL ANYWHERE YOU MANY
EXAMPLES OF WHERE GOVERNMENT AND
PRIVATE SECTOR
HAD AN ADEQUATE RESPONSE THAT
SORT OF WAS IT QUICK RESTORATION
OF CONFIDENCE LEANING IN THE
MUSE IT'S YEAH YOU KNOW I IT'S
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO IDENTIFY
EXAMPLES BECAUSE YES.
THIS THIS THREAT SPACE IS STILL
RELATIVELY NEW REPAIRED OTHER
POLICY DOMAINS I THINK THAT DOM
HYPOTHETICALLY THOUGH LIKE WHAT
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN SO I I
THOUGHT I I THINK YOU KNOW
EXERCISE YOU CONDUCTING AN
EXERCISE THAT INVOLVES.
STATE LOCAL OFFICIALS THAT THE
STATE AND YOU KNOW THAT.
YOU KNOW DID ELECTION FOR
STRUCTURE.
GCC AND AND AND AND THAT'S YOU
SEE.
AND MAYBE EVEN FIGURED OUT HOW
TO GET MEDIA INVOLVED COULD BE
YOU KNOW USEFUL EXERCISE OF THE
DAM TO TRICK THEIR. RIGHT IS TO
ENSURE THE EXERCISE ACCOMPLISHES
ITS GOAL WHICH IS TO.
HOPE
IDENTIFY ISSUES FIX THEN BUILD
CONFIDENCE ENOUGH MEMORY NOT
ACTUALLY.
BECOME IT'S OWN SORT OF FEEL
PUBLIC AFFAIRS FIASCO RIGHT
BECAUSE AGAIN DUE TO THE GOAL IS
TO IDENTIFY PROBLEMS.
IT'S HARD TO DO IF IF IF
STAKEHOLDERS
I FEEL LIKE THEY CAN'T BE
FORTHCOMING AND ABOUT PROBLEMS
THAT FEAR OF YOU KNOW GETTING
HUNG OUT TO DRY BY THE PRESS OR
BY UP IN A POLITICAL.
RIGHT.
UNIT PIGGYBACK ON WHAT IS A
GOOD JOB AND I BECAUSE I DID
HAVE A SORT OF MORE CITIES AND
FOCUSED QUESTION YOU TO IN TERMS
A UTILIZING THE POWER OR YOUR
NETWORKS AND OTHER NETWORKS OUT
THERE THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
RELATED TO JUST SAY. YOU KNOW
WHILE WE'VE BEEN LEARNING.
SO HAVE THE ADVERSARIES.
I THINK WE CAN ASSUME THE
ATTACKERS ALREADY IN THE
STADIUM.
A I THINK THAT THERE ARE NO
TWELVE NOT TEN ROUTES OF
INGRESS.
YOU HAVE TO BE THINKING IN THOSE
TERMS AND THAT'S WHY I EMPHASIZE
RECOVERABILITY.
THE ABILITY TO RECOVER
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS IS
REALLY CRUCIAL ANYMORE DETAIL
THOUGH WHAT WILLOW YOU MEAN BY
RECOVERY WHAT IS RECOVERY LOOK
LIKE YOU SO.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE COUNTIES.
A LOT OF THE COUNTIES ACTUALLY
BUT I IKNOW IN PARTICULAR OF
ONE OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY RIGHT
HERE TO LEVINE PUT TOGETHER
REALLY OUTSTANDING DISASTER
RECOVERY KIND OF PLAN.
IT WAS VERY COMPREHENSIVE.
AND IT'S THE KIND OF THING THAT
YOU KNOW HELPS IF THERE'S A
FLOOD ON ELECTION DAY AND YOU
HAVE TO GET PEOPLE FROM THE SIDE
OF THE RIVER NOT OUTSIDE OF THE
RIVER TO COMMENT BEEN EELIN SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN STILL VOTE IT'S
ALL ABOUT PEOPLE CAN STILL VOTE.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT IF YOU
HAVE AN AUDITABLE SYSTEM.
AND YOU CAN CONDUCT A ROBUST
AUDIT YOU WILL KNOW WHETHER EVEN
IF SOMEBODY WAS IN.
TAMPERING WITH THE SOFTWARE
THAT THE OUTCOME WAS IN FACT
CORRECT YOU CAN IDENTIFY THAT
THERE WAS AN ANOMALY OR PROBLEMI
COULD STILL GET A CORRECT DEL
COM IF YOU HAVE A FULLY
AUDITABLE SYSTEM.
COURSE THEIR OTHER FACTORS YOU
KNOW THERE'S CHAIN OF CUSTODY
HAS TO BE REALLY ROBUST AND
OTHER KINDS OF PHYSICAL SECURITY
MEASURES.
BUT LIKE I A I EMPHASIZE THE
RECOVERABILITY JUST KIND OF KEEP
US THINKING A STEP AHEAD OF
WHERE OUR ADVERSARIES ARE
BECAUSE OUR ADVERSARIES NO
MAYBE.
YOU KNOW GET INTO A SYSTEM THAT
THEY FOUND A BACK DOOR INTO AND
JUST BEEN WAITING.
FOR THE RIGHT MOMENT WHICH MIGHT
NOT OF BEEN YOU KNOW TWENTY
SIXTEEN SURE WE HAVE SEEN ED
PATTERN OVER TIME YOU YOU KNOW
YOU YOU THAT'S IT LINE WEIGHT.
YOU KNOW THAT RIGHT WHEN I MET
WITH A.
AND HIS BOSS ONE TIME HE SAID TO
ME.
YOU KNOW THERE'S BASICALLY TWO
KINDS OF ORGANIZATIONS THE ONES
THAT AVE BEEN HACKED AND THE
ONES THAT DON'T KNOW IT YET. AND
IF SO AND I THINK THAT'S THAT
ASSUMING THAT KIND OF ASSUME
BREACH IS A GOOD WAY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE AND IT PROTECTION IS.
.
IS A MISGUIDED EXPECTATION I'D
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT AND I
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THE PUBLIC
WILL UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THEY
DON'T EXPECT.
A. PERFECTION.
OR DON'T NEED TO EXPECT
PERFECTION MIGHT TAKE A LITTLE
EDUCATED BUT THEY DON'T EXPECT
PERFECTION BUT THEY DO EXPECT
DILIGENCE THAT YOU'RE MAKING THE
EFFORT AND THAT YOU CAN SHOW
YOUR WORK. YOU KNOW IT I THINK
THAT THAT'S REALLY THE KEY THEY
WERE.
IT THE MORE THEY KNOW.
BECAUSE THE BETTER OFF THEY ARE.
IN A DECISIVE FACTOR THINK HERE
IS
WHAT.
QUALITY OF POLITICAL DISCOURSE
AROUND A GIVEN.
LIKE AND THAT'S WHY COME BACK TO
THE DID THE VITAL IMPORTANCE
LEADERSHIP LEADER FROM THE
CANDIDATES AND AND I WOULD SAY I
MEAN.
THE LOSERS MATTER MORE THAN THE
WINNERS.
THAT I MEAN I I'M I I THINK IT
THE WHO BOTH PARTIES AT LEAST IN
THIS STATE AND DOES NOT IN
PARTY'S. TO REALLY EMPHASIZE.
WHEN YOU LOSE A RACE BECAUSE
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE A
LOSER.
COMMUNICATING DIRECTLY WITH THE
PUBLIC ABOUT
ACCEPTING.
TERMS OF THAT ELECTION AND ODDLY
YOU KNOW FEDERAL YOU'VE SEEN
WINNERS ACTUALLY.
CALL OUT FRAUD BUT. WILL SET
THAT ASIDE IT'S A BIZARRE.
YEAH
IF I HAD TO COME BUT I THINK.
YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO SORT OF
FIND THAT POLITICAL COURAGE
INCREASE IN SPACE
IT WILL TRY TO ADDED TODAY'S
HEARING FINAL LITTLE BIPARTISAN
PLEDGE. THAT WE CAN START TO
ENGAGE IN AND.
DO SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
PUBLICLY VISIBLE TO SAY SURE OF
YOU KNOW I'M I'M STICKING WITH
THIS SYSTEM.
EVEN IF IT DOESN'T ALWAYS
SUPPORT ME I DID WANT TO ASK.
THOUGH.
MISS SMITH.
MEAN WITH THE QUANTITY OR AG TO
BOTH OF YOU WITH THE QUANTITY OF
THREATS OUT THERE ALL ALL THE
SCANNING CONSULAR GONE WE HEARD
FROM.
KELLY.
FIVE THOUSAND SCAN SINCE HE WAS
SITTING IN THE AUDIENCE RIGHT
IT'S IT'S IT'S CONSTANT.
IS THERE.
IS IS THERE A POINT WHICH
THERE'S JUST.
TO WHOM TO MUCH OUT THERE FOR
GOVERNMENT OR EVEN A PLATFORM
LIKE FACEBOOK TO BE ABLE THAT
TRACK IN TERMS OF MISINFORMATION
LIKE I I'M TRYING TO THINK
THROUGH THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO
DISINFORMATION.
RIGHT BEFORE ELECTION IS THEIR
CITIZEN COMPONENT HERE TO IS
THERE A WAY TO INSERT A MEANING
FULLY EQUIPPED THE PUBLIC. WITH
THE ABILITY TO REPORT.
WHAT THEY SEE IS SORT OF REALLY
ELECTION RELATED MISINFORMATION
AS OPPOSED TO?
SPINNER POSTURE WHERE WE ALL
ANGLE ON ISSUES AND TALKING
ABOUT POLICY REALLY ON.
POLLING PLACE INFORMATION AND
THAT SORT OF.
HAVE YOU SEEN THAT WORK.
BEFORE WHERE.
CITIZENS ARE FINDING THINGS
BEFORE GOVERNMENT OR THE PRIVATE
OR THE PLATFORMS CAN AND IS
THERE SOME
BETTER ROLE FOR THAT.
EITHER IN
FROM A MECHANICAL PERSPECTIVE
FOR SPYING THREATS OR FROM A
PERCEPTION PERSPECTIVE TO SAY.
YOU YOU EVER YOU HAVE A ROLE IN
THIS PROCESS TO TO BLOCK FOREIGN
ACTORS FROM IT.
ARE ALEXIAN SO I DON'T KNOW A.
B. BOTH YOU COULD WEIGH IN ON IT
IS A REALLY INTERESTING QUESTION
I DON'T KNOW THAT I CAN ANSWER
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE'VE
SEEN SORT OF. CITIZENS TAKE THE
INITIATIVE TO REPORT HEY THERE'S
SOMETHING STRANGE GOING ON IT.
YOU KNOW WHEN I TRIED TO VOTE
THIS HAPPEN AND I DON'T KNOW
WHY.
AND IT GIVES THE ELECTION
PROTECTION TYPE GROUPS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHECK IN WITH THE
ELECTION OFFICIAL AND MAYBE
THERE THAT THAT'S THE FIRST
ALERT THAT SOMETHING IS WRONG
MAYBE THAT CITIZEN DOESN'T KNOW.
ABOUT TO CALL THE ELECTION
OFFICIAL OR TWO REPORTED TO THEM
DIRECTLY BUT THEY MIGHT HAVE
HEARD ABOUT A HOTLINE AND IF
THAT IF IF EVERYONE'S WORKING
TOGETHER AND DOING THEIR JOB
CORRECTLY. IT'S A CHANCE TO
CONTACT THE ELECTION OFFICIALS
SAY HEY THIS HAPPENED AND LET
THEM INVESTIGATE AND TAKE
ACTION.
AND IT MIGHT BE THE CANARY IN
THE COAL MINE FOR THEM SO IT'S A
VALUABLE THING TO HAVE.
BICU ELECTION OFFICIALS ALL
HAVE LINES COMING IN THAT THEY
CAN TAKE THESE KINDS OF REPORTS
BUT IF YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT
IT'S YOUR COUNTY THAT RUNS YOUR
ELECTION YOU JUST GO AND VOTE
WHERE THEY TELL YOU TO. YOU
DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW THAT
THAT'S THE PLACE TO DO IT.
ACADEMICS OFTEN DO RESEARCH.
JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE GEEKY AND
INTERESTED IN THIS KIND OF STUFF
AND THEY CAN FIND OF WAYS.
.
TWO THEY COULD FIND PROBLEMS AND
THEN FIND WAYS TO HELP RESOLVE
THOSE PROBLEMS AND HAVE VERY
GOOD ADVICE SO THAT'S WHY I
RECOMMENDED THE.
ELECTION SECURITY ADVISORY
COUNCIL THAT WILL INCLUDE A.
THAT TYPE OF EFFORT AND MAYBE
ADDED A. SERVER BECAUSE IN
EUROPE COROLLARY TO THAT
CONCEPT.
AND WHAT IS THE NEIGHBORHOOD
WATCH LOOK LIKE FOR OUR
DEMOCRACY RIGHT WHAT IT HAD.
READ THAT ACTUAL COMMUNITY LEVEL
HOW DO WE EMPOWER THOSE FOLKS
SO.
YEAH ADVISORY COUNCIL BUT THEN
HOW. ARE WE INSTILL THAT PRIDE
IN.
CONSERVATIVE COMMUNITIES IN
LIBERAL COMMUNITIES SO TO SAY
LIKE THIS IS THIS IS YOUR YOUR
RACE SO I KNOW WHAT ELSE IS
YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS RIGHT I
WOULD JUST ADD ONE OTHER THING
TO. IT BEFORE THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT ELECTION CYCLE BEGAN SORT
OF THE BEGINNING OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT.
THAT PEW CHARITABLE TRUSTS ARE
CENTER ON THE STATE'S AB
SPONSORED SOME.
.
CONVENING STE FOR MEDIA THEY DID
FOR FIVE OF THEM AROUND THE
COUNTRY I PARTICIPATED IN ONE.
OF I WAS ON A PANEL WITH THE
PERSON WHO WAS REPRESENTING THE.
VOTING SYSTEM TECHNOLOGY.
.
LOBBYING GROUP.
IF SO.
IT WAS GREAT IT WAS YOU KNOW
SORT OF DIFFERING OPINIONS AND
PERSPECTIVES ON THINGS.
BUT IT WAS SUCH A VALUABLE
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE WE COULD.
PRE ANTICIPATE QUESTIONS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO COME UP FOR THE
USED A REPORTERS AND JOURNALISTS
AND HELP FRAME FOR THEM WHAT
THEY NEEDED TO KNOWN WHAT THEY
NEED TO ASK.
SO THAT YOU DON'T HAVE PROBLEMS
LIKE THE NBC PROBLEM THAT WAS
REFERRED TO EARLIER.
SO THAT PEOPLE ARE USING THE
RIGHT TERMINOLOGY EVEN.
YOU KNOW SAYING ELECTION SYSTEM
NOT VOTING SYSTEM IF THAT'S WHAT
THEY MEAN ARE SAYING
REGISTRATION SYSTEM NOW VOTING
SYSTEM IF THAT'S WHAT THEY MEAN.
AND BEING.
A SORT OF A THIRD PARTY
RESOURCE FOR.
WHEN THE MEDIA WOULD CALL OVER
THE LAST ELECTION CYCLE OF YOU
KNOW HAD TO DO A LOT OF THAT
THEY'D SAY WELL JUST HAVE I JUST
NEED FIVE MINUTES I HAVE THESE
QUESTIONS AND WE DAY. STAY
WHAT'S YOUR QUESTION AND THEN
I'D REALIZE WE HAVE TO START AT
THE BEGINNING A THIRTY MINUTES
LATER WE GET TO THE QUESTION.
ONCE THEY UNDERSTOOD HOW IT
WORKED I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THE MEDIA NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND HOW IT WORKS IN
THERE'S NEW JOURNALISTS ALL THE
TIME TO REPORTERS ON THE BEAT
ALL THE TIME THAT ARE DOING
SOMETHING. NEW FOR THEM SO THEY
DON'T KNOW SO NEEDS TO BE
EDUCATION OF THE PUBLIC AND
EDUCATION OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
THE INTERMEDIARY TO. VERY VERY
USEFUL FEEDBACK.
JUST TO.
BRIEFLY.
BEYOND PERCEPTION
ACTUAL.
CONCRETE SECURITY VALUED FOR A
SORT OF MORE DISTRIBUTED
SENTINEL SYSTEM IS THAT IS THAT
A REAL KIND OF CONCEPT OR IS IT
YEAH I THINK IT IS.
I MEAN I THINK THAT YOU KNOW.
ANYTIME THERE'S A SINGLE POINT
FAILURE YOU'RE HERE LESS SECURE
I I THINK.
THAT IF YOU'RE MORE DISTRIBUTED.
.
YOU KNOW BUT THE YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW THE MORE.
DISTRIBUTED NOTES THAT YOU HAVE
THE LESS.
ABLE THE.
MINISTRY TO THOSE NOTES ARE.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ECONOMIES OF
SCALE.
FOR MANAGEMENT AND STAFF THEME
IN PRODUCING IN THAT.
LARGER ORGANIZATION CONTINUED
MANAGEMENT AND THEN IS THIS IS
A.
IS A BALANCING IT'S HARD BOUNCE.
WELL.
I I FUNDS INCREDIBLY MULLIN
FORESTS I APPRECIATE AND I I
WOULD JUST ASK IF WE CAN CAN
TEN YOU TO RELY ON YOUR
COLLECTIVE EXPERTISE HERE S WE
GO FORWARD.
NOT JUST TODAY BUT YEAH THANK
YOU AND.
THANKS FOR BEING IN CALIFORNIA
TO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF OTHERS SOUGHT
A SECOND WOOD WOOD MISTER CHAIR
SAID.
WE OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
GONNA BE A LOT MORE WORK ON THIS
IN THE COMING YEARS.
AND WE WANT TO.
YEAH.
TO USE THAT WE CAN GET OUT
FRONT.
OF OUR ADVERSARIES.
OR RELIGIOUS MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE.
FIRMED UP OUR.
THE.
FOR LOOK LIKE OF A BETTER TERM
BORDERS IF THERE ARE ANY IN THE
IN THE STADIUM.
AND SO YOU KNOW THIS CAN BE A
LOT OF.
LEGISLATIVE ACTIVITY A LOT OF
WORKING WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
I'VE GOT SOME IDEAS DO YOU KNOW
ABOUT HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE THAT
LOCAL CAMPAIGNS CAN WORK.
WITH SOME OF THESE COMPANIES
THAT OUR ADVERSARIES ARE USING
TO PROMOTE MISINFORMATION AND
CONFUSION AND DOUBT.
IN IN THE PUBLIC'S MIND.
SO YOU HAVE A LOT OF REALLY
GOOD IDEAS I KNOW WE ALL HAVE A
LINE NOTES.
AND AND FOLLOW UP ITEM SO I'M
SURE WE REACHING OUT ON SIR
THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH LIKE
IT'S NOT A BIG YEAR FOR HISTORY
IN THE DAY THANK YOU.
SOARING TO MOVE ON IT TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF
TODAY'S HEARING.
I HAVE FOR.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO HAVE
SIGNED UP I ASK EACH OF YOU TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO THREE
MINUTES.
AND IN THE FIRST IS GONNA BE.
BRENT TURNER MISTER TURNER.
AND UGH UGH GIVE EVERYONE.
KINDA ONE MINUTE HEADS UP.
WHEN YOU GO ONE THAT LETS.
ASSUMES.
HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS BRENT TURN AROUND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF VOTING
OFFICIALS WE ARE THE PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP FOR SOFTWARE
SECURITY. WE WERE THE FIRST TO
DECLARE THE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS IS BROKEN PER ROY
SALTMAN THE INVENTOR OF THE
NATIONAL SECURITY A
CERTIFICATION PROCESS WE ARE THE
PRO BONO BY PIONEERS OF THE
CUTTING EDGE OPEN SOURCE VOTING
SYSTEMS.
THERE HAVE BEEN REFERENCED HERE
WE FIRST DEMONSTRATED THOSE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR UNDER THE
NAME OPEN VOTING CONSORTIUM ARE
LANGUAGES NOW INCLUDED IN
REPRESENTATIVE TULSI GABBARD
RECENT FEDERAL. LEGISLATION
DISCUSSING OPEN SOURCE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH PAPER BALLOTS
I'M HERE ARE SOME HARD TRUTHS.
THE AIR GAPS THAT WERE DISCUSSED
ARE GOOD BUT NOT ENOUGH.
FOR CYBERSECURITY WE MUST PER
PUSH FURTHER TO INOCULATE
AGAINST THE INTERNET.
SECURITY ISSUES AS THE.
THE BAD FOLKS COME IN THROUGH
THE VENDORS
A THIS IS NOT ROCKET SCIENCE DE
CENTRALIZATION IS GOOD BUT NOT
ENOUGH MORE FACT HERE RISK
LIMITING AUDITS AND PAPER
BALLOTS ARE GOOD BUT NOT ENOUGH.
AND ONLY ONE HALF OF THE
CONVERSATION WHAT HIS BEEN
OMITTED TODAY FOR THE MOST PART
OR AT LEAST INSUFFICIENTLY
REFERENCED
IS INFORMATION REGARDING THE
SOFTWARE. THE SOFTWARE IS
CURRENTLY PRIVATIZED AND DO THAT
PRIVATIZATION THE SYSTEMS ARE
NOT ABLE TO BE PROPERLY SECURED
AND NEVER WILL BE AS LONG AS ARE
COMING FROM VENDORS AND OUR
PRIVATE. THE NEXT TRUTH IS THAT
THE SOLUTION SOFTWARE WHICH IS
PUBLIC OPEN SOURCE SOFTWARE IS
AVAILABLE BUT BEING SIDELINED BY
CORPORATE VENDOR INTERESTS.
THE LICENSING TO WHICH.
DEAN LOGAN REFERENCED IS NOT
TRIVIAL IT MUST BE
P. L. GENERAL PUBLIC LICENSE
THREE POINT OH THAT WILL
GUARANTEE. GUARANTEE SHARE
ABILITY THE SOLUTION SYSTEMS ARE
MORE SECURE LEFT TO SPEND
EXPENSIVE CURRENTLY DEPLOYED IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE FOR THE MOST PART
EXCEPT FOR THE TABULATION PIECE.
AND NOW CURRENTLY SLATED FOR SAN
FRANCISCO THEY WILL BE FIFTY
PERCENT LESS EXPENSIVE THAN THE
CURRENT SYSTEMS
WE MUST WATCHDOG AGAINST THE
STATUS QUO PRESERVATIONISTS. AND
GRANT ABSORBING FIVE OH ONE.
THREE'S THAT ARE CONTROLLING
THIS CONVERSATION AND ALSO
SEEPING INTO ACADEMIA
THE OPEN SOURCE ARE YOU GONNA
WHAT'S AT ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU THE OPEN SOURCE
SCIENTISTS ARE CRUCIAL TO YOU
FOR THE TRUTH HERE PLEASE DO NOT
UNDERESTIMATE THE VENDOR
INTEREST THAT CONFLICTS WITH THE
NATIONAL SECURITY. IT CREEPS
INTO ALL ASPECTS AS HAS BEEN
REFERENCED BY MY ASSOCIATE JAMES
WOOLSEY FORMER CIA DIRECTOR.
PEW VERIFIED VOTING AND OTHERS
CONTINUE THE CIRCULAR
CONVERSATION WHILE TAKING GRANT
MONIES
BUYING NEW PROPRIETARY SYSTEMS
IT'S OF THE DEFINITION OF
INSANITY HERE. ANY FURTHER MONEY
MUST GO TOWARD SECURE BOWL OPEN
SOURCE SYSTEMS.
A FINALLY WE SUGGEST SWORN
TESTIMONY THAT FUTURE HEARINGS
FOR OBVIOUS REASONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
TURNER.
THEN NEXT WEEK I HAVE GYM SOBRE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JIM SO PER IBM.
CULTURE THE VOTING TRANSPORTS
AND AUTHORED THE WEBSITE COUNTED
AS CATS THAT ORG.
UP.
I SPOKE.
HERE FOUR YEARS AGO.
WHEN SENATOR PATEA HELD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ABOUT WHAT
HAVE WE LEARNED SINCE FATHER.
AND WE'VE REVIEWED MY NOTES
THERE AND THEY STILL STAND
PRETTY MUCH.
I WILL TRY TO SEND YOU A
POINTER TO THAT.
WHAT'S MISSING HERE.
IN MUCH THE CONVERSATION IS
SOMETHING THAT I. POINTED OUT.
FOUR YEARS AGO I SAID.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THREAT.
SOME INSIDERS.
I STAND BY THAT TODAY.
THAT IS.
PRINCIPALLY THE PROGRAMMERS.
GEOFFREY DEAN'S WITH TWENTY
THREE CONVICTIONS FOR
EMBEZZLEMENT.
PROGRAMMING DEED PEOPLE
MACHINES.
OR CLING KURDISH BEING HIRED TO
WRITE CREATE A MACHINE A VOTING
MACHINE THAT WOULD MAKE VOTES.
INSIDERS.
THE BEST DEFENSE AGAINST.
VERY KIND A PROBLEM IS OPEN
SOURCE.
SO THAT THE PUBLIC CAN LOOK AT
IT A LOT OF PEOPLE CAN LOOK AT
IT IT'S NOT ABSOLUTE.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS
OF LINES OF CODE TOTALLY
INVOLVED BUT IT'S A DETERRENT.
THAT THEY MIGHT BE.
CAUGHT A TREND TO PUT IN
SOMETHING THAT SHOULDN'T BE
THERE.
A.
IBM REALLY FRUSTRATED I'VE BEEN
AT THIS SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
TO SEE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS YET
TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR OPEN
SOURCE DEVELOPMENT.
AND I'VE BEEN HERE ESPECIALLY
THE LAST FEW YEARS SERVICES
BECAUSE WORKING HARD ON THIS
MISTER LOGAN'S.
ARE WORKING HARD ON IT.
THEY NEED SOME HELP SPECIALLY
SAN FRANCISCO. ARE I'M GOING TO
BE AT THE TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MEETING TOMORROW NIGHT
INSTEAD OF CISCO. THEY'VE GOT
VERY GOOD PEOPLE THERE.
AND THEY'RE WORKING HARD ON
THIS.
AND I'M GLAD THAT THE GOVERNOR
PUT IN A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EQUIPMENT.
SPUN IT THAT THERE'S NO MONEY
FOR RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT.
IN SOFTWARE IN SYSTEMS THAT
WOULD SAVE CALIFORNIA. THE
COUNTIES AND EVEN THE STATE.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS DOLLARS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MAYBE TEN
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO SAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS.
SO MY PRIMARY ARE.
URGING HERE IS THAT YOU KEEP
THAT IN THE BUDGET.
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
SO THAT THEY CAN MOVE FORWARD
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
ALSO WON'T FUNDING FOR
CERTIFICATION OF ANY OTHER
CERTIFICATION AND TESTING THE
OTHER OPEN SOURCE IS.
THERE SYSTEMS DEVELOPED THAT
BEING DEVELOPED THE UNIVERSITY
FLORIDA AND TRAVIS COUNTY
APPARENTLY IS CUT BACK ON TRACK.
FOR THEM TO BRING THEIR SYSTEMS
THEN.
IT IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
TO PAY FOR CERTIFICATION
TESTING.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HELP COVER
THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MRS SOBRE.
NEXT I HAVE RICHARD TAM.
A GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME MY
NAME IS RICHARD TAM I AM ANOTHER
CO CHAIR OF THE VOTING RIGHTS
TASK FORCE I WANNA.
SUPPORT WHAT JIM SAID A IN THAT
BUDGET ITEM ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR MILLION. IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT
TO ALLOW THE COUNTY STILL LEASE
SYSTEMS RATHER THAN BY THEM.
FOR THE ONE REASON THAT.
WHEN LA DEVELOPS ITS SYSTEM WHEN
SENATORS CO DEVELOPED THAT
SYSTEM. THEY WILL PICK UP MADE
AVAILABLE AT A GREATLY REDUCED
PRICE TO THE OTHER COUNTIES THEN
THE PRIVATE.
A.
PROPRIETARY CODE BICU HIDDEN
CODE THE OF.
NO PRIVATE VENDORS
SO.
THAT'S HOW THE STATE WOULD SAVE
MONEY IT COULD INVEST SOME MONEY
IN. THE DEVELOPMENT OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND LA SYSTEMS AND
THEN REAP A HUGE HARVEST OF
SAVINGS.
BY THOSE SYSTEMS BEING MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE OTHER COUNTIES.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IS TO RISK LIMITING
AUDITS.
OF WHICH HAWKING ABOUT THE
A PROBLEM WITH THE ONE PERCENT
MANUAL TALLY BEING MADE EVEN
WEAKER. ONE PERCENT MANUAL TALLY
WAS NEVER AN AUDIT.
IT WAS SIMPLY TO CHECK ON
SOMETHING SEATS IF YOU
CONSIDERED AN AUDIT IT WOULD BE
AN EXTREMELY WEAK ONE.
SOME COUNTIES A DOZEN COUNTIES
HAVE ALREADY DONE.
A PILOT RISK LIMITING AUDITS
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO WITH DOCTOR
PHILIP STARK.
OF WHY DON'T WE ALLOW THESE ANY
COUNTY WHO WANTS.
TO CHECK OUT. INSTEAD OF DOING A
ONE PERCENT MANUAL TALLY TO A
RISK LIMITING ORDER. THEY COULD
EASILY TO THAT FOR ALL THE.
GOOD CONTESTS WITHIN COUNTY.
ALL THE OLD OLD. OLD OVER RACES
WITHIN THE COUNTY THEY COULD
EASILY SWITCH FROM DURING THE
ONE PERCENT MANUAL TALLY TO RISK
LIMITING ORDER.
IN THIS NEXT ELECTION WHY WAIT.
UNTIL A BILL GOES THROUGH THAT
THE CA CEO ENDING LOGANO WORKING
ON BECAUSE. THAT WILL.
THAT WON'T IT'S A AT THAT ONE
GOING TO AFFECT UNTIL NEXT YEAR
OR THE YEAR AFTER OR. FOUR YEARS
FROM NOW.
YOU KNOW SO. UP
V. IT COUNTIES CAN EASILY TO
RISK LIVING ARTISTS WITHIN
COUNTY THERE ARE TWO OTHER KINDS
OF RACES.
MOST OF YOU PROBABLY ARE ELECTED
FROM MULTI COUNTIES MANY MANY A
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND SENATORS
ARE OF THEIR DISTRICTS ARE INTO
A THREE DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
THAT GETS A LITTLE MORE
COMPLICATED STATE RACES EVEN ARE
EASIER THAN MULTI COUNTY ONES
FOR RISK LIMITING ORDERS BUT.
IT YOU COULD EASILY TO AN
URGENCY BILL.
TO ALLOW ANY REGISTRARS TO
IMMEDIATELY DIVERS CLUMPING
ARTISTS WITHIN THEIR COUNTY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER DAM
AND NEXT I'VE NICHOLAS HEIGHT
ON.
HI JEREMY NICHOLS SIDE ON WITH
CALIFORNIA COME BECAUSE JUST ONE
SAY.
STARBUCKS SAYING THANK YOU TO
YOU INTO CHAIR STERN IN ABSENTIA
OF FOR PUTTING ON THIS WONDERFUL
HEARING REALLY PUTTING A
SPOTLIGHT ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
I THINK ROLL TESTIMONY WE'VE
HEARD TODAY TWO MAIN THEMES KIND
OF EMERGED TO ME THAT I'VE TAKE
COMMON CAUSE STRONGLY AGREES
WITH.
THE FIRST IS THAT THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE OF ANY INTRUSION INTO
OUR ELECTION SYSTEMS AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN CALIFORNIANS CAN TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS.
THAT'S REALLY THE MAIN TAKEAWAY
AND ONE THAT'S VERY REPORT.
THAT SAID THE SECOND TAKE AWAY
AS WE ARE CALIFORNIAN WE KNOW WE
CAN DO BETTER. AND WE KNOW THAT
WE NEED TO DO BETTER BECAUSE
THOSE WHO DO WANT TO INTERFERE
WITH OUR ELECTIONS THEY'RE GONNA
KEEP STRIVING HARDER AND HARDER
SAYS IS NOT SOMETHING WHERE WE
CAN REST ON OUR LAURELS.
INSTINCTS STATIC WE NEED TO KEEP
IMPROVING.
TWO THINGS THAT I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DO THIS YEAR
THAT WOULD REALLY HAVE A
PROFOUND EFFECT. IS THE FUNDING
ISSUE WHICH BEEN TALKED ABOUT OR
ELECTION SYSTEMS ARE OR FOR OR
EQUIPMENT IS FAR TOO OLD WE
DON'T WANT TO GET IN THE
SITUATION OF FLORIDA CIRCUIT TWO
THOUSAND.
THE SAME ISSUES WE CAN REALLY
EXAMINE PROCESS HE'S AND
PARTICULARLY THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE HUGE STRIDES IS HERE HIM
PUSHING US CLOSER TO HAVING.
FULL RISK LIMITING AUDITS FOR
THIS TO CALIFORNIA THIS IS
REALLY DIRECTION WE NEED TO GO
TO ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
SYSTEMS WITH A STRONG PAPER
BASED ON TING BACK UP. OVER THIS
THANK YOU AGAIN AS CHAIR AND A
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
IN THE ADVOCATES IN THE CLERK
SAID REGISTRARS IN THIS YEAR TO
COME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NICHOLAS.
SO THAT IS OUR LAST MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WHO SIGNED UP TO
SPEAK OUT IS WHEN I THINK
EVERYBODY OF THE PANELISTS
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
FOR PARTICIPATING TODAY I
DIFFERENT ONE RECOGNIZE OF THE
STAFF OF THE.
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
AND THE SENATE I KNOW Y'ALL CALL
IT SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
ELECTIONS AND SOMETHING ELSE
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE UP FOR PUTTING ON
TODAY'S PANEL IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ADDING NICHOLAS REALLY
WRAPPED UP WELL.
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS.
THAT OUR ELECTION SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE SECURE THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN HACKED.
BUT THEY'RE UNDER CONSTANT
THREAT.
AND SO WE NEED TO DO MORE THAN
I TO IMPROVE OUR SYSTEMS AND
CONSTANTLY STAY VIGILANT EYE
WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EVERYBODY. FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY'S HEARING